Frau Hoppenstedt, was hat Sie als Frau veranlasst, in eine Jodelschule einzutreten?
Da regt mich ja die Frage schon auf. Was heißt denn Sie als Frau? Eine Berufsausbildung ist ja nicht grundsätzlich vom Männern gepachtet.
Ich meine ja auch nicht.
Ich finde gerade eine Hausfrau mit Familie sollte eine abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung haben. Weil wenn die Kinder mal aus dem Haus sind oder es passiert irgendwas, dann hab ich nach zwei Jahren Jodelschule mein Jodeldiplom. Da hab ich was in der Hand. Und ich habe als Frau das Gefühl, dass ich auf eigenen Füßen stehe. Oder hab ich was Eigenes? Hab ich mein Jodeldiplom? Ich möchte auch als Frau eine sinnvolle Tätigkeit ausüben und nicht nur am Kochtopf stehen und meinem Mann die Hausschuhe hinterher tragen.
Ist die Gatte auch dieser Ansicht?
Mein Mann möchte eine echte Partnerin haben, die ihre eigenen gastigen Fähigkeiten entwickelt. Für die Familie, für die Gesellschaft. Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Sie jodeln mit meiner Frau? Nein, ich bin von Radio Bremen. Meine Frau jodelt beruflich.
Herr Schmoller hat gerade ein Interview für den Frauen...
Sie studiert, Herr Jodeln, an der Fachschule für Jodeln. Ich habe gerade mit ihrer Frau... Und macht dann in zwei Jahren ihr Jodeldiplom.
Das hab ich eben...
Dann ist sie selbstständig. Eine Frau sollte heutzutage eine abgeschlossene Ausbildung haben und auf eigenen Füßen stehen. Man braucht als Mann eine Partnerin, eine Frau mit eigenem Lebensbereich. Sie muss ihre persönlichen Fähigkeiten entwickeln, damit sie was Eigenes hat. Wenn die Kinder mal aus dem Haus sind, dann hat sie ihr Jodeldiplom, dann hat sie was Eigenes. Sie tun immer so, als wüssten sie alles.
Ich hab ihm das alles doch eben schon...
Du solltest mich vor allem nicht unterbrechen, wenn ich einem Herrn was mitzuteilen habe.
Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch hier zur 196. Ausgabe des Programms. Und heute bitten wir uns mal wieder ein bisschen der Gesellschaft. Die steht ja auch im Titel und ich möchte mein Thema aufgreifen, was auch gerade so in diesen Zeiten mir so das Gefühl gibt, dass es zu den Umstrittenen gehört, wahrscheinlich schon auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise immer wieder war. Aber jetzt auch auf eine bestimmte Form, wie dann noch auf den Tisch kommt und warum das so ist und was da für Aspekte zu beleuchten gibt, das frage ich die Katrin Rönicke, auch bekannt als die Kada. Hallo. Du bist die Kada, du bist die Kada auf Twitter, du bist die Kada im Netz. Und Feminismus ist so ein bisschen dein Thema, oder?
Ja, ich würde eher sagen, meine Haltung. Mein Thema ist ja nicht ein Thema, sondern es entspannt ja alle Themen.
Deine Haltung?
Ja, meine Haltung. Na ja, man hat ja so gewisse Grundeinstellungen, gewisse Grundwerte, die man vielleicht auf alle möglichen Themen anwendet. Und das ist dann eine Haltung. Also mit welcher Haltung gehe ich an Themen ran? Und so gesehen ist Feminismus eine Haltung, dass ganz viele verschiedene Themen betrifft.
Verstehe. Also es ist nicht nur...
Politik, Gesellschaft, Wirtschaft, Biologie, Wissenschaft allgemein.
Und wie bist du da so zugekommen? Ich meine, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, okay, du bist ja eine Frau, du musst ja auch irgendwie was mit Feminismus zu tun haben, aber das ist ja nicht eigentlich so. Was hat dich so dahin geführt in dieser Haltung?
Ich glaube in erster Linie zwei Faktoren in meinem Leben, also die mein Leben sehr stark bestimmt haben. Das eine ist, dass ich in der DDR geboren wurde und dann 89 noch vor der Wende in den Westen gegangen bin. Also da war ich gerade sieben Jahre alt oder noch nicht ganz sieben Jahre alt. Und in der Zeit davor eigentlich auf einem kleinen Dorf mitten in Sachsen-Anhalt gelebt habe und die einzigen anderen Kinder in meinem Alter waren zwei Jungs. Und deswegen nur mit Jungs gespielt habe, die ersten sieben Jahre meines Lebens oder fast nur mit, sehr wenig mit Mädchen und so ein bisschen wie so ein kleiner Junge aufgewachsen bin auch dadurch. Also durch die Wälder gezogen und Mutproben gemacht und hatte auch immer kurze Haare und wurde auch oft mit einem Jungen gehalten. Und dann kam ich in den Westen, nach Westdeutschland, nach Baden-Württemberg in eine wunderschöne kleine idyllische Baden-Württembergische Provinz, bin da auch eingeschult worden und hatte dann so ein bisschen das genaue Gegenteil, wo einfach Mädchen sehr stark auf ihr Geschlecht festgelegt waren. Von sowohl Erwachsenen als auch untereinander sehr großer Druck da war. Also die hatten dann meistens auch lange Haare und sehr viel Rosa. Und hatten es auch schon die ganzen sieben Jahre, die ich halt wie so ein Junge aufgewachsen war, natürlich eintrainiert. Also es gibt Studien darüber, die auch nachgewiesen haben, dass jungen Mädchen von ihren Eltern und von ihrer gesamten Umwelt vom ersten Tag an anders behandelt werden als einfach nur aufgrund ihres Geschlechts. Und da habe ich dann nicht so richtig reingepasst. Also ich hatte dann am Anfang auch immer irgendwie Probleme.
Aber du bist von deinen Eltern jetzt nicht so getrimmt worden. Das war jetzt nicht nur, weil es jemand anderes zum Spielen gab, sondern...
Nee, genau. Das ist in der DDR ein bisschen anders gelaufen. Also da haben ja auch Frauen genauso selbstverständlich gearbeitet wie Männer. Und da gab es auch dieses rosa-hellblaue Ding so gar nicht. Also da hatten Junge und Mädchen ziemlich ähnliche Kleidung. Dieser Spruch, wir hatten ja nichts.
Gott wäre kein Rosa.
Dieser Mangel trifft auch dazu. Also ich habe teilweise Kleidung von Jungen, die irgendwie in der Verwandtschaft waren oder so, ausgetragen. Einfach um Geld zu sparen und derlei Gleichen. Also es war einfach nicht so krass getrimmt. Und diese ganz, ganz starke Trennung entlang von Geschlecht ist ein Stück weit auch ein kapitalistisches Ding. Weil man ja gerade bei Kleidung dann zweimal verdienen kann. Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel ein expeditives Paar erst einen Jungen kriegt und dann ein Mädchen, dann müssen die ja zweimal die Klamotten kaufen. Man kann ja dem Mädchen nicht das gleiche anziehen wie dem Jungen. Da stecken auch wirtschaftliche Interessen dahinter. Na jedenfalls kam ich dann halt so wie so ein kleiner Junge so ein bisschen sozialisiert, was mir nicht bewusst war. Also in meiner eigenen Wahrnehmung war ich ein ganz normales Kind in den Westen und wurde einerseits ausgegrenzt und gemobbt. Weil ich halt aus der DDR kam, also das spielte auch eine sehr große Rolle. Aber ich konnte immer viel besser Anschluss finden, gerade zu den ersten Jahren an Jungen als an Mädchen. Also da wurde ich noch mehr ausgegrenzt. Und meine ersten richtig guten Freunde dort waren dann auch eigentlich eines Jungen. Das hat sich ja sofort gesetzt, hat ein bisschen gedauert, bis ich mich dann so angepasst hatte und auch Rosa war und auch Barbie gespielt habe und diesen ganzen Scheiß, dass ich dann auch Mädchenfreundschaften geschlossen habe. Und das ging bei mir dann aber immer so weiter. Das war quasi die Voraussetzung. Genau, so ungefähr. Also vorher war ich wirklich ausgegrenzt bei denen. Und ich habe aber sehr danach gegiert, auch bei denen integriert zu sein. Also bei meinem eigenen Geschlecht. Es war nicht so, dass ich mich nicht als Mädchen gefühlt habe, sondern ich war halt nicht so wie die. Das, was anders ist, würde man halt eher ausgrenzen. Und ich war halt eher wie die Jungs und deswegen konnten die mich halt eher integrieren.
Da du ja nur bis sieben Jahre da warst, hast du ja wahrscheinlich keinen großen Überblick, aber was ist so, auch vielleicht im Rückblick, mit der ich sicherlich schon mal ein Thema gewesen sein so, warum war es denn jetzt in der DDR anders? Also nur weil jetzt nicht alles in rosa und hellblau verfügbar war, das kann ich ja wohl nicht erklären.
Nein, ganz fundamental ist natürlich, dass Frauen genauso arbeiten gegangen sind wie Männer. Und dass es ganz normal war für eine Frau, ihr Kind in eine Krippe zu geben. Das war Standard. Also Krippen waren Standard. Dass meine Mutter mich erst mit drei in den Kindergarten geschickt hat, war absolut nicht Standard. Das war schon fast eine kleine Rebellion. Also sie hat sich halt gesagt, nee, die ersten drei Jahre will ich zu Hause bleiben, will das selber machen. Das war damals dort das völlige Gegenteil von dem, was normal war. Also allein dieses Frauen und Männer arbeiten gleich viel, beide Arbeitskräfte werden gleich gebraucht. Das war in der DDR auch Gleichberechtigung zwischen Männern und Frauen so eine Art Default. Also das wurde von der Politik auch gezielt propagiert. Ein paar Dinge gab es trotzdem, die ganz entlang von klassischen Geschlechterrollen waren. Es gab einmal im Monat einen Haushaltstag für Frauen, wo die Frauen nicht arbeiten mussten.
Man hat jetzt auch nicht gerade das Gefühl gehabt, dass im Politbüro jetzt eine Quote eingeführt worden wäre.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Wobei es gibt schon diverse Äußerungen von Politikern in der DDR, die gesagt haben, wir müssen auch mehr Frauen in die Politik kriegen. Also es war schon stärker.
Hast du eine Ahnung, warum das so war?
Ich weiß.
Ist das jetzt wirklich nur so die kommunistische Idee? Und wir brauchen alle Arbeiter und Arbeiterinnen, die sich kriegen lassen und der Rest leitet sich daraus ab? Weil ich meine, absurderweise handelt es sich ja noch zumindest bis zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt um dasselbe Volk, was bis zum Krieg auch von der selben Gesamtmengelage geprägt worden ist, die er auch in der Nazi-Zeit auch noch mal so sein Mega-Extrem gefeiert hat. Der Soldat auf der anderen Seite, auf der anderen Seite so die Frau und die Kinder und muss so die Brut erzeugen, die dann auf der anderen Seite wieder kanoniert wird.
Ja, aber genau das ist vielleicht auch der Grund. Also was ja sehr bezeichnet war für die DDR ist eine sehr, sehr, sehr krasse Abgrenzung gegenüber all dem, was man als faschistisch bezeichnet hat. Die Mauer wurde ja auch der antifaschistische Schutzwahl genannt, also gegen die böse kapitalistische BRD. Und sich da auch dagegen abzugrenzen, gegen diesen ganzen Muttermythos, der von den Nazis ja gehegt wurde, ist ja in der Logik nur eine Fortsetzung des Abgrenzens an sich. Also vielleicht hängt das damit zusammen. Ich habe mich damit noch nie so richtig eingehend beschäftigt, woher das genau kam, aber es war schon viel stärker Konsens. Frauen und Männer sind eigentlich gleich. Und wir wollen auch, dass sie gleich sind und gleich wir arbeiten. Und es war die zweite Seite nicht dazu gesagt worden, dass wir eigentlich auch wollen, dass Männer sich genauso mit Kindern kümmern wie Frauen. Also auch in der DDR waren Kindergärtnerinnen eben Kindergärtnerinnen und nicht Kindergärtner. Da gab es schon noch Unterschiede.
Also es war jetzt noch nicht so das Paradies gleichgestellter Umstände, aber ein paar Sachen waren einfach anders. Aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Und das hat sich bei dir eben auch sofort gezeigt. Wie bewusst war denn das in dem Moment?
Gar nicht. Überhaupt nicht. Das war mir nicht bewusst in dem Moment. Ich habe sehr lange damit gekämpft und ich bin eigentlich jetzt erst an dem Punkt, wo ich das so reflektieren und aufarbeiten kann für mich und in der Rückperspektive sehe. Deswegen war das vielleicht auch so. Aber ich habe so ein ziemliches Auf und Ab gemacht. Also zuerst war ich eben stärker bei den Jungs integriert, habe mich dann versucht so anzupassen, dass ich bei den Mädchen auch bin, war aber damit dann auch nicht glücklich und habe dann wieder eine Phase bekommen, so im Alter von zwölf, wo ich gedacht habe, eigentlich will ich ein Junge sein. Ich finde es ganz schrecklich, ein Mädchen zu sein. Ich wollte wirklich ein Junge sein mit zwölf. Ich habe mich auch jetzt beim Karneval als Cowboy verkleidet, habe mir die Haare wieder kurz geschnitten und habe mich da auch sehr bewusst gegen Mädchen abgegrenzt. Dann wieder zurück in das andere Extrem. Also ich bin immer so zwischen den Extremen laviert, weil ich mich nicht wohl gefühlt habe mit dem, was ich hatte. Also mit der Auswahl, die ich hatte. Ich hatte ja nur die Auswahl, entweder strikt Junge oder strikt Mädchen. Es gab dazwischen halt nicht sehr viel, weil das war sozial ganz arg festgeschrieben. Und da mit 13 wiederum bin ich in baufrei, sehr engen Tops rumgerannt und habe gemeint, ich müsste jetzt besonders sexy sein und wäre auch fast magersüchtig geworden. Also wieder das andere Extrem. Es hat sehr lange gedauert, bis ich dann ungefähr mit 14 Jahren geschafft habe, mich von dem komplett frei zu machen. Also wo ich dann gesagt habe, okay, irgendwas läuft hier komplett falsch. Ich bin nicht ich. Ich versuche immer irgendjemandem zu gefallen, mich irgendwo anzupassen. Ne, da gab es schon einen Auslöser. Also ich ging da gerade an zwei so Mädels dran, die halt sehr extrem diesen ganzen sexy und cool und ja, die hatten dann auch schon langsam angefangen Freunde zu haben und rumzuknutschen mit anderen Jungs und so weiter. Also und in die hatte ich mich drangehangen. Und ich habe gedacht, ich will so sein wie die. Und das hat nicht funktioniert. Und es war dann schon eine sehr starke innere Erkenntnis, mir wird es immer schlechter gehen, wenn ich immer mehr versuche so zu sein wie sie. Also lasse ich das jetzt. Und habe es dann wirklich von einem Tag auf den anderen gelassen und gemerkt.
Wobei du ja gar nicht primär darunter gelebt hast, so zu sein wie sie. Und das nicht geschafft hättest, sondern dass ja das, was sie sein wollen, ist sie wollten so sein, wie sie bei den Jungs dann meinen anzukommen.
Genau. Oder auch insgesamt einfach als cool und als bewundernswert wahrgenommen zu werden. Und für mich zu sagen, okay, scheiß jetzt darauf, wer mit mir befreundet ist. Wer mit mir befreundet sein will, der wird es auch sein, wenn ich schlabberege, lange... Also ich habe dann wirklich den Kleiderschrank meines Vaters durchwühlt nach alten Pullovern von ihm, die schon komplett ausgetragen waren, und habe die dann angezogen. Das war so Grunge-Zeit. Also ich habe dann auch ganz viel Grunge gehört. Die waren ein bisschen zu groß. Das war genau das Konzept. Nee, was heißt der Schlapper-Look der Zeit? Der war da, glaube ich, schon fast wieder vorbei. Aber es war dann so mein Ding zu sagen, okay, ich mache jetzt einfach das komplette Extrem, sodass ich mich wohlfühle, dass ich auch so ein bisschen austeste, wer lacht darüber und wer lacht darüber nicht. Also, wer akzeptiert mich so, wie ich bin? Und daran hat sich dann wirklich auch gezeigt, wer sind eigentlich wahre Freunde und so. Und gleichzeitig habe ich dann entsprechend auch andere Musik gehört. Also davor, ich will gar nicht sagen, was ich alles für schreckliche Musik gehört habe, die halt so in war in der Zeit. Das war 1996. Das hat mich, glaube ich, sehr geprägt, aber ich habe das nie wahrgenommen als etwas, was mich feministisch geprägt hat.
Aber Mode scheint generell schon eine große Rolle zu spielen in dem ganzen Spiel, oder?
Auf jeden Fall. Also Mode bzw. Schönheit an sich. Oder auch, wie definiert man eine schöne Frau? Und es ist auch interessant, finde ich, dass Schönheit sowieso fast nur für Frauen definiert wird. Also an Männer wird die Erwartungshaltung, du musst schön sein, ja gar nicht in der Weise gerichtet. Männer müssen nicht schön sein.
Nö, auch wenn ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck habe, dass auch an der Front es etwas bröckelt. So diese aufkommende Metrosexualität und die zunehmende Parfümisierung.
Weil es kapitalistisch interessant ist. Es ist eine weitere Zielgruppe.
Da fällt mir in dem Zusammenhang ein Tavi Gevenson, sagt ihr das was? Das ist so ein junges Mädchen, die mit zehn Jahren angefangen hat in den USA zu bloggen. Die ist auch jetzt erst 16 glaube ich oder 17 und hat irgendwie angefangen halt über Mode zu bloggen. Aber halt so in ihrem ganz eigenen Film. Und ist da jetzt auch extrem bekannt geworden. Also hat jetzt irgendwie ihr eigenes Magazin, also hat man noch nicht mal 18, aber wird irgendwie schon von allen Mode-Experten herumgereicht, das ist total hip, sich mit ihr abzugeben. Macht aber einen sehr down-to-earth-Eindruck. Man hat dann auch so bewusst auch so einen ganz eigenen Stil entwickelt. Unter anderem dann sich irgendwie die Haare grau gefärbt und dann in so einem Oma-Look irgendwie unterwegs zu sein, ne? Und ihr Appell ist halt auch im Wesentlichen der, zu sagen, es ist wichtig, dass man sich selbst gefällt und dass man sozusagen seinen eigenen Stil findet und nicht sozusagen so einer Mode zum Opfer fällt, die von außen versucht, einem ein Bild aufzudrängen, oder eine, weil damit ja im Prinzip eine Anpassung verbunden ist.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also das ist ein ganz, ganz wichtiges Thema. Aber kommen wir zu der zweiten, zu dem zweiten Fundament, warum ich Feministin bin. Das war jetzt ja nur das Erste. Das Zweite ist, dass ich mit 18 dann in die Grüne Jugend gegangen bin, die Jugendorganisation von Bündnis 90 Die Grünen, weil ich in der Schule angefangen hatte, mit einer Freundin so ein bisschen politisch zu diskutieren. Und der Witz ist eigentlich, dass sie jetzt zur Jungen Union gegangen, also die CDU-Jugendorganisation, und hat sich da irgendwie ganz wohl gefühlt. Und ich dachte, voll cool, ich will auch was machen in der Art, aber ich gehe bestimmt nicht zur Jungen Union. Was gibt es denn da so? Und damals gab es ja dann auch schon Internet, also ich hatte dann auch schon Internet und in der Yahoo-Suche nach Grüne- und Jugendorganisationen gesucht und kam dann zur Grünen Jugend und bin dann da einfach mal hingefahren. Und da bin ich auf ein Umfeld gestoßen, wo feministisch sein die Fault-Entstellung ist. Also die haben auch die Quote, die haben sehr viel geschlechterpolitisches Grundsatzprogramm schon gehabt und schon sehr viel darüber diskutiert.
Wie ist die Quote genau? Halb der Hälfte?
Halb der Hälfte in allen Gremien. Also beziehungsweise nicht halb der Hälfte, nicht feste Quote für Männer, sondern es können noch mehr Frauen sein. Aber halt mindestens 50 Prozent Frauen. Genau, nicht mehr Männer. Wobei, da sind auch immer Ausnahmen möglich. Also man kann dann, wenn sich keine Frauen finden, kann ein Frauenquorum, was bedeutet das, alle anwesenden Frauen einer Versammlung, dann beschließen, dass der Platz freigegeben wird für Männer. Also es gibt dann schon so Ausnahmemöglichkeiten. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das jemals vorgekommen ist. Wie auch immer, da kam ich halt rein und hab bis dahin eigentlich nie wirklich über die Kategorie Geschlecht nachgedacht gehabt. Wenn man aber bei der grünen Jugend ist, wird man dazu gezwungen, weil die grüne Jugend ungefähr alle zwei Jahre Debatten darüber führt, ob jetzt die Quote abgeschafft werden sollte oder nicht. Also das kommt wirklich immer so wunderbar alle zwei Jahre wieder, weil ständig neue Leute reinkommen. Und wenn man neu reinkommt und man ist vielleicht ein junger Mann und man hat sich vielleicht genauso wie ich noch nicht so viele Gedanken darüber gemacht, dann stellt man das natürlich erstmal in Frage und findet das ungerecht und findet vielleicht, dass die Frauen ja so emanzipiert sind heute, dass sie das nicht mehr brauchen und so weiter. Und dann ist man, wenn man so wie ich, ich bin halt via die Quote nach drei Monaten grüne Jugend schon in den Landesvorstand gewählt worden. Also die haben eine Frau gebraucht. Ich war schon sehr engagiert in den drei Monaten, so ist es auch nicht, also ich habe auch wirklich was gemacht. Und ich hatte auch eine Gegenkandidatin, die schon länger dabei war, aber es lag unter anderem mit einer Quote, dass ich halt sofort in Verantwortung war in dem Laden. Und wenn dann man Verantwortung hat, die man sich vielleicht vorher gar nicht zugetraut hätte, die man aber dann irgendwann gesagt hat, okay, ihr braucht eine Frau, dann mache ich es halt, dann wächst man mit den Aufgaben. Also das ist was, was mich sehr, sehr geprägt hat, dass ich aufgrund der Quote in etwas reingerutscht bin, wo ich vielleicht in jedem anderen Lebensbereich den Männern das Feld überlassen hätte und gesagt hätte, ach wisst ihr, ich bin noch nicht lang dabei und ich traue mir das auch nicht so richtig zu und überhaupt.
Warum hättest du es den Männern überlassen? Ich meine, wenn du jetzt sagst, ich bin nicht bereit Vertrauen, Verantwortung zu übernehmen, hättest du es ja jedem Beliebigen, also auch einer Frau, überlassen können.
Nee, nicht auf die Art und Weise. Ich hätte nicht aktiv gesagt, ich traue mich nicht Verantwortung zu übernehmen, sondern ich wäre so passiv gewesen, gar nicht erst auf die Idee zu kommen, für ein Amt zu kandidieren. Weiß ich nicht. Das frage ich immer die meisten Frauen. Die meisten Frauen, die ich kenne, die in der grünen Jugend, also auch teilweise Ämter begleitet haben, sind einfach von selber nicht auf die Idee zu kommen, zu kandidieren. Das ist irgendein Sozialisationsding, das man sich zurückhält, das man gar nicht erst darüber nachdenkt. Ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt, aber ich weiß, dass es so ist. Das habe ich in dieser Zeit in der grünen Jugend auch gelernt. Die Männer kandidieren von selber und auf die Frauen muss man zugehen. Also in meiner gesamten Vorstandsarbeit, immer wenn irgendwelche Posten frei geworden sind und es war klar, wir brauchen jetzt eine Frau, auf die mussten wir immer zugehen und die Fragen.
Das ist auch nicht eine sehr interessante Frage, warum das so ist.
Sozialisation, ganz sicher. Also bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Aber was sagt die Sozialisation? Die Sozialisation sagt, der Mann hat Verantwortung zu übernehmen oder hat jede Gelegenheit zu ergreifen.
Ich glaube, es ist sogar sich mit anderen zu messen zum Beispiel. Also ich glaube wirklich, dass es Männern mehr Spaß macht, sich mit anderen zu messen und in Wettbewerb zu treten als Frauen. Also jetzt immer als Durchschnittswerte gedacht. Es gibt natürlich bei allem immer die Ausnahmen und es gibt die schüchternen Männern genauso wie die sehr voranschreitend, sehr prominent auftretenden Frauen oder sehr stark auftretenden Frauen. Aber im Durchschnitt wurden die meisten Menschen anders erzogen. Es gibt eine Studie, die heißt die Baby-X-Studie. Die hat versucht, also der Versuchsaufbau war so, dass man Babys hatte und man hat den Versuchspersonen diese Babys in den Arm gedrückt und geguckt, was machen die mit denen. Und egal welches Geschlecht die Babys hatten, die haben denen entweder Rosastrampler angezogen oder blaue Strampler. Einfach um zu kennzeichnen, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein Junge. Es war aber teilweise so, dass dann Mädchen die blauen Strampler anhatten und Jungs die rosa Strampler. Irgendwann hat den Eltern vorgegaukelt, sie hätten jetzt einen Jungen auf den Arm oder sie hätten jetzt ein Mädchen auf den Arm. Hat die dann beobachtet, oder nicht Eltern, das waren halt X-Besuchspersonen. Man hat die dann beobachtet, wie die mit den Kindern umgehen. Und sie haben wirklich Babys, qua Geschlecht, anders benannt. Also haben gesagt, du süßes kleines Mädchen oder du starker, frecher, kleine Junge. Und das ab einem Alter, wo man das Geschlecht äußerlich noch nicht mal sieht. Also wo wirklich noch nichts da ist, haben die die signifikant anders behandelt. Nur wegen Stramplerfarben.
Auch wenn es eigentlich gar nicht Mädchen waren oder Jungs waren?
Genau, genau. Es war ja teilweise, also wenn da eine dicke Winde drum ist, kann man das ja auch nicht erraten oder so. Es war teilweise gefaked. Also es waren gar keine Jungs und keine Mädchen. Teilweise war es vielleicht auch so. Dann gab es andere Studien, wo Eltern befragt wurden, was sie sich für ihre Kinder wünschen. Also zuerst einmal so abgefragt, was haben sie für Kinder, also was für ein Geschlecht ist das Kind, und was wünschen sie sich für das Kind? Anfang der 90er, da kann ich die Quellen auch noch mal raussuchen. Da haben die Eltern dann relativ klar auch entlang vom Geschlecht gesagt, ich wünsche mir für meine Tochter, dass sie ein fürsorglicher Mensch wird, der viel Liebe empfinden kann für andere, der offen ist und so weiter. Also relativ weiche Attribute. Und für meinen Sohn wünschten sich die meisten, dass er eben erfolgreich wird, durchsetzungsfähig. Ja, und die Berufsbereiche, die sich dann die meisten Eltern für ihre Kinder vorgestellt haben, waren eben auch so.
Und warum denkst du, warum Eltern das so machen?
Weil man es immer schon so gemacht hat. Es ist halt dieses Ding, das historisch schon sehr lange gewachsen ist. Und ich glaube, die meisten hinterfragen das nicht. Die glauben vielleicht, Mädchen sind tatsächlich besser in sowas, qua-naturell oder...
Andererseits kann es natürlich auch schon so eine gewisse Kapitulation vor dem Status quo sein, dass man sagt, meiner Meinung nach kommt eine Frau besser voran, wenn sie sich auch Frauen-typisch anpasst und sich Männer-typisch anpasst.
Ja, vielleicht ist es unbewusst auch so ein vorausallender Gehorsam gegenüber der Gesellschaft.
Weil man will ja das Beste fürs Kind. Man will ja, dass sie den möglichst einfachsten oder zumindest erfolgreichsten, für sie erfolgreichsten, besten, beschütztesten Weg nehmen.
Das kann schon sein. Warum das so ist, hat diese Studie nicht untersucht. Es kam halt einfach raus, es ist so.
Wir waren bei der Grünen Jugend. Ich versuche jetzt auch, den Dreh zu den Babys zu bekommen. Warum sie sich nicht bewerben und warum die Männer immer gewählt werden wollen und die Frauen noch nicht mal auf die Idee kommen, gewählt zu werden.
Genau, sie kommen nicht von alleine auf die Idee. Da habe ich gelernt, Frauen muss man ein Stück weit genauso in den Arsch treten. Also man muss den Männern in den Arsch treten, dass sie sich zurücknehmen und dann eben Plätze für Frauen reservieren sozusagen und sagen, da kommen jetzt aber Frauen hin. Und man muss gleichzeitig den Frauen in den Arsch treten, dass sie diese Plätze auch bitte mal besetzen sollen.
Und diese Quote organisiert quasi diesen Arsch-Tritt hintenrum. Weil Frauen sehen so, es muss ja mit einer Frau gefüllt werden. Und ich meine, am Ende spiegelt die Quote ja eigentlich nur die natürliche Geschlechterverteilung in der Gesellschaft wieder.
Genau, so 50-50. Und über diese Quote führt man dann Debatten. Alle zwei Jahre, wie gesagt, ungefähr. Also gefühlt.
Ja, aber dann kommt da nochmal das Argument mit, wir wollen ja jetzt nicht, kann denn die Parität wichtiger sein als die Qualität? Und die Qualität ist doch sozusagen die Besten, die geeignet sind. Und wenn es denn nun mal Männer sind, dann sollten sie es auch sein, genauso wie es auch Frauen sein könnten, wenn sie es denn sind.
Genau. Das ist das Argument, das man von Männern immer hört, interessanterweise. Und von den meisten Frauen, die dagegen sind, hört man wiederum, ich bin überhaupt nicht so, weiß ich nicht, wie jetzt Frauen unterstellt wird zu sein. Ich bin emanzipiert und ich finde es irgendwie ein Armutszeugnis für Frauen, dass wir die Quote brauchen. Ich finde, dass das Frauen degradiert. So, das ist das Argument, was von Frauen dagegen kommt. Und da lernt man dann, wenn man dann auch noch in einem Landesvorstand ist, und dann ist man ja in Verantwortung, und dann muss man sich ja auch entscheiden, wie positioniere ich mich denn dazu? Und was will ich denn? Also will ich, dass diese Quote weiterhin in meinem Verband existiert? Oder möchte ich, dass sie weggeht? Und dann setzt du dich mit dem Thema das erste Mal auseinander. Und dann setzt du dich nicht nur mit dem Thema auseinander und den pro und contra Argumenten, sondern dann streitest du darüber. Das war richtig. Auf einer Versammlung, wo vielleicht 50 bis 100 Leute sind, allen Geschlechts, die wirklich zwei, drei Stunden über dieses Thema streiten, hin und her. Und dann noch am Rande der Versammlung, weil das ist natürlich das heißt umkämpfeste Thema überhaupt. Und da lernst du dann so richtig, ja, da geht es an die Substanz. Und da kommen nämlich alle diese ganzen Argumente, die wir jetzt auch gerade hatten, Sozialisation, Biologie. Ist es denn gerecht? Philosophische Argumente und so weiter. Wie wollen wir es denn schaffen, dass Frauen gleichberechtigt werden, wenn wir sie anders behandeln? Diese ganzen Dilemata. Mit denen setzt du dich dann auseinander. Bis gerade Anfang 20 hast du dich vielleicht noch nie so intensiv mit sowas beschäftigt, aber zack rein.
Und so musstest du dich damit auch auseinander lassen.
Und so kam das.
Ich meine, wenn es aufgebracht wird, sind es natürlich auch berechtigte Fragen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das sind alles berechtigte Fragen. Da habe ich auch gelernt, die Gegenseite ernst zu nehmen. Weil die natürlichen Gewicht hatte. Also man lernt ja in solchen, das ist wie ein Debattierclub in den USA. Das war für mich die Grüne Jugend. Da lernt man, um Themen zu streiten. Und auch wirklich fair zu streiten. Also es gibt ja auch immer eine Gegenrede und eine Pro-Rede für irgendwelche Sachen. Man muss vorher mit allen Leuten irgendwie kommunizieren. Wenn man einen Antrag schreibt, gucken, ob man ihn an der einen oder anderen Stelle vielleicht verändert. Und wenn ja, warum, welche Argumente gibt es für die Veränderung? Also das ist schon so ein sehr zivilisierter und strukturierter Prozess. Mit Kritik umzugehen, mit Gegenmeinungen umzugehen, mit die eigene Meinung vielleicht auch mal zu revidieren, weil es einem reingestimmt wird oder so, keine Ahnung. Und man muss dann auch oft, wenn man in einem Vorstand ist und man hat vielleicht ein Papier wurde verabschiedet, wo man nicht zu 100 Prozent immer diese Meinung teilt, aber das ist dann als Grundmeinung der Grünen Jugend so verabschiedet, muss man das auch vertreten können. Ein Stück weit zumindest. Man kann natürlich auch sagen, naja, an dem Punkt sehe ich das eigentlich ein bisschen anders, aber im Großen und Ganzen. Die Basisdemokratie. Bei der Grünen Jugend ist sie auch wirklich da, weil jeder, der Mitglied ist, kann zu den Versammlungen fahren, kriegt die Fahrtkosten erstattet und kann mitdiskutieren und mitmachen. Und ich glaube, da hat sich sehr, sehr viel eingeprägt, wie ich heute feministisch bin. Ich habe mich dabei immer noch nicht so genannt. Also das Label Feminismus hat sehr lange bei mir gebraucht, bis ich es dann angenommen habe.
Aber so war es dann. Das waren sozusagen die beiden entscheidenden Schritte, die dich dann zu dem Thema gebracht haben. Ja, jetzt, bisher, Internet hat es ja schon frühsass. Bisher dann auch im Netz aktiv geworden. Hast du einen schönen Begriff Netzfeminismus eingeführt. Da müssen wir auf jeden Fall auch nochmal drüber reden. Machst aber vor allem dein eigenes Blog, The Leftist Elite. Und hast auch noch so einen Gemeinschaftsblog, Frau Lila. Und dann, das dritte Projekt, muss ich nochmal kurz erläutern, die Featurette ist was?
Ist ein Blog-Aggregator im Wesentlichen, der aus Frauenblogs zusammengestellt wird. Also wir nennen es immer unser Magazin, weil letztendlich ist es so ein bisschen wie jede andere Magazin-Webseite, wird es halt zusammengestellt aus verschiedensten Themenbereichen und verschiedensten Autorinnen, die aus verschiedensten Perspektiven alles Mögliche beleuchten. Also wir versuchen es sehr breit zu halten, um ein breites Publikum auch damit anzusprechen. Letztendlich geht es aber einfach darum, diese Bloggerinnen sichtbar zu machen.
Aggregiert das jetzt alles, was in den anderen Blogs geschrieben wird, oder ausgewählte Artikel?
Alles. Also ja, das ist noch ein technisches Ding, das das alles aggregiert. Wir müssen mal gucken, weil es über RSS-Feed läuft.
Ja klar, also mehr so ein technischer Mechanismus, keine redaktionelle Auswahl.
Redaktionell ist nur die Auswahl der Blogs selbst.
Aber wenn die dann auf einmal anfangen, über andere Sachen zu schreiben, dann ändert sich der Spin. Na gut, so sind es immer die technischen Probleme.
Ja, gut, das Ding ist auch noch relativ neu. Es gibt es jetzt seit der Letzten Republik, seit Mai. Wir versuchen, soweit es geht, eben jetzt auch neue Blogs da immer weiter mit einzupflegen. Wir haben jetzt um die 30. Bis auf einen. Also wir haben einen Mann dabei. Das ist der Väter-Blog. Wir finden das Ziel, das wir halt verfolgen, was ja schon ein feministisches Ziel ist, beinhaltet auch, die andere Seite mit reinzunehmen. Und das ist halt wirklich ein Mann, der Hans-Georg Nelles, der auf eine sehr tolle Art und Weise über das Vatersein in Deutschland bloggt und über Väterrechte und so weiter. Den haben wir auch mit reingenommen, aber das ist wirklich die einzige Ausnahme. Und soll es auch beides gehen bleiben, weil das Hauptziel ist Sichtbarkeit von Frauen.
Weil die Sichtbarkeit von Frauen noch nicht so ist, wie sie sein sollte?
Wie sie sein könnte. Das Einblick in, egal welche Blogcharts, und mal ein bisschen hinschauen und durchzählen, wird dir zeigen, unter 5 Prozent oder eine Handvoll Frauenblogs sind vielleicht dabei, aber das ist sehr, sehr wenig. Das ist unterschiedlich. Also da gibt es wieder so verschiedene Faktoren, die darauf einwirken. Ich denke einerseits, dass man beobachten kann, die Stereotype Zuordnungen zu Themen, sowohl bei Männern als auch bei Frauen. Technik allgemein. Politik wird in erster Linie von Männern bespielt. Wirtschaft ganz krass. Es gibt sehr viele Wirtschaftsblogger. Ich habe noch immer keine Wirtschaftsbloggerin gefunden. Ich mache überall den Aufruf, ich will eine Wirtschaftsbloggerin für unser Feature-Ed bitte. Frauen machen gerne so Do-It-Yourself, feministische Sachen auch, Lyrik, Bücher lesen. Also alles, was in Anführungszeichen weichere Themen empfunden werden.
Ist denn jetzt nicht das, wie es sich dann im Netz von sich aus entfaltet, dann auch irgendwie eine Aussage? Weil hindert ja jetzt niemand daran, einen Blog aufzumachen. Also es hält mich als Frau jetzt jemand ab, daran einen Wirtschaftsblog aufzumachen, außer dass ich es selber nicht machen will. Und dann sind wir wieder an demselben Punkt wie dieses, ich trete nicht zur Wahl an.
Ich denke schon, ja.
Weil man das Netz als ein Kräftemessen versteht?
Auf jeden Fall. Gerade in Blogs ist das Netz ja immer auch ein Stück weit ein Kräftemessen. Wenn man sich so manche Kommentarspalten anschaut, ist es, wenn man seine Meinung in das Netz reinschreibt. Und sagen wir mal, es ist ein Wirtschaftsthema. Und Wirtschaft ist ja nun wirklich auch komplex. Also ich habe es gestern erst wieder beobachtet. Mein Freund hat irgendwie was zur Wirtschaft geschrieben. Und dann wird es gleich von allen möglichen Seiten komplett in Frage gestellt, dass er auch nur irgendwas davon verstanden hätte. Und das muss man erstmal aushalten. Also da muss man erstmal die Stärke haben, zu sagen, ich kenne mich aber aus. Und ich weiß, dass das, was ich gesagt habe, logisch ist und dass das auch solide ist. Und deswegen verteidige ich das jetzt vielleicht. Oder ich lasse das nicht an mich ran, was da kritisiert wird. Und so ein bisschen ist es für Frauen natürlich eine kuscheligere Zone, erstens in dem Bereich zu sein, in dem sowieso nicht so viel Kritik geübt wird. Also bei Do-it-yourself-Blogs ist es eigentlich immer nur so, yeah, das sieht toll aus, das hast du schön gebastelt und wunderbar. Also da gibt es fast nur positives Feedback. Wohingegen eben bei Politik und bei Wirtschaft und auch bei Jura schon schnell Streit entfacht. Und gerade weil das so männliche Bereiche sind, sich auch viele Männer dann immer gleich herausgefordert fühlen, wenn da jemand mal eine Meinung sagt. Und dann muss man diese Meinung sofort in Frage stellen. Ist eine Verhaltensweise, die ich grundsätzlich sympathisch finde, weil ich mittlerweile auch so sozialisiert bin durch diese ganze grüne Jugendzeit, dass ich Streit und Meinungshoheit kämpfen eigentlich als was Tolles empfinde. Aber für Frauen ist das oft ein bisschen abschreckend. Und es gibt auch Studien darüber. Da hat man Frauen und Männer hingesetzt und gesagt, löst man mathematische Aufgaben. In zwei verschiedenen Settings. Bei dem einen Setting hat man es nur für sich gelöst und war so allein in seinem Raum. Es hatte keine größere Bedeutung, außer dass es darum ging, diese Aufgaben richtig zu lösen. Und in dem zweiten Setting hat man es gegen jemand anderen gemacht. Also da hat man jemand daneben sitzen gehabt. Und am Ende sollte das verglichen werden. Wer ist eigentlich besser? Und das Ergebnis dieser Studie war, dass die Frauen in dem Setting super gut waren. Und zwar besser als die Männer, wo sie alleine für sich gemacht haben. Und die Männer waren besser und super gut, wenn sie gegen jemand anderes angetreten sind. Das hat also sozusagen direkt die Qualität ihrer Arbeit beeinflusst, wenn sie in einem Wettbewerb standen. Sie waren besser. Und bei Frauen war es genau der umgekehrte Effekt.
Kriegt man das raus? Also ich meine, man kann ja jetzt nicht anfangen, eine Blogquote im Internet einzuführen.
Das geht nicht, genau.
Du darfst jetzt keinen Wirtschaftsblog aufmachen, weil jetzt ist ja erstmal eine Frau dran.
Natürlich, im Internet, das funktioniert nicht. Ich denke halt, die einzigen Mechanismen, die man machen kann, ist, okay, vielleicht gibt es Frauen, die im Netz aktiv sind und die auch Wirtschaftsanung haben, dann müsste man die erstmal miteinander vernetzen. So, dass die gegenseitig miteinander reden und sich auch andere Frauen kennen, die das tun und sich gegenseitig den Rücken stärken können.
Also sie müssen sich selbst vernetzen?
Sich selbst, ja. Also innerhalb ihrer kleinen Community, dass sie mehr werden, dass sie dann vielleicht andere Frauen ansprechen können, hey, mach doch und sei nicht so leise und sich auch gegenseitig unterstützen. Ich glaube, das ist für Frauen immer ganz wichtig, dass sie merken, jemand steht dahinter mir und ich bin nicht nur die, die angegriffen wird, sondern ich habe hinter mir jemanden stehen, der finde das gut, was ich mache. Also es ist auch das, was ich immer mit diesem Netzfeminismus und so weiter immer wieder versuche, ist, Frauen einfach zu vernetzen und zusammenzubringen. Und vor allem auch offline, sowas wie Stammtisch oder sowas hilft sehr, dass man in dem Thema, in dem man aktiv ist, auch Sicherheit empfinden kann und nicht die ganze Zeit das Gefühl hat, ich werde hier permanent in Frage gestellt. Und das Zweite ist, ja, Vorbilder. Also, um Stereotypen zu durchbrechen, helfen eigentlich nur Vorbilder. Und das Problem ist, wenn man ein Vorbild hat, dann gilt dieses immer noch als Ausnahme. Also, die Regel wird nicht durchbrochen, sondern die Ausnahme bestätigt die Regel. Und das ist halt die eine Ausnahme. Na gut. Aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass Frauen wirtschaftsprinzipiell genauso gut können wie Männer. Jetzt um an dem Beispiel zu bleiben. Sondern man bräuchte schon so fünf bis zehn richtig coole Wirtschaftsbloggerinnen, um das Stereotyp wirklich zu durchbrechen.
Ja, also mir würden jetzt auch keine fünf bis zehn wirklich coole Wirtschaftsblogger händlicherseits einfallen.
Nein, das ist halt wirklich cool. Ich meine jetzt halt, unabhängig von deren Inhalte und ob ich die teile, sondern fünf bis zehn Frauen, die sich hinstellen, sagen Wirtschaft, mein Thema, schreibe ich was zu. Und verteidige ich auch, im Zweifel. Das bräuchte es. Und da versuchen wir eben mit der Feature-Vet diese Vorbildfunktion sichtbar zu machen. Also wir haben Frauen, die in Politik bloggen, wir haben Frauen, die zum Thema Recht bloggen. Und versuchen das sichtbar zu machen und dazu zeigen, hey, es gibt das und es gibt die Vorbilder, scheuert euch nicht, guckt euch das an. Und einerseits stärken wir dadurch diejenigen, die es schon tun. Also sie kriegen auch eine Aufmerksamkeit. Wir versuchen halt, die auch besser zu vernetzen. Man braucht nur noch auf eine Seite gehen. Man muss sie nicht irgendwie wie die Nadel im Heuhaufen suchen, sondern sie sind halt da. Und auf der anderen Seite sind sie gleichzeitig Vorbild für andere.
Wenn du sagst, dass mit den Vorbildern das funktioniert, oder ist das das einzige, was funktioniert? Wo hat es denn funktioniert? Da muss es ja auch entsprechende Belege dafür geben, dass diese Vorbilder jetzt so relevant sind.
Ja, zum Beispiel in der Politik. Also da hat man nun ja schon einige Zeitlang Quoten in allen möglichen Parteien, bei den Grünen zuallererst. Und es machen jetzt schon deutlich mehr Frauen auch Politik als früher. Und wir haben eine Kanzlerin und so weiter.
Die aber auch einfach die Ausnahme ist, ne?
Nee, ja, als Kanzlerin vielleicht noch die Ausnahme, aber das Kabinett ist ja schon recht. Es sind ja auch Frauen drin. Und in anderen Ländern ist man da schon weiter. Also Frankreich wird jetzt wahrscheinlich, oder hat jetzt auch 50 Prozent Frauen im Kabinett. Spanien hatte das auch unter Zapatero. In den USA gut Hillary halt und dann noch so ein paar andere Frauen. Da ist es noch ein bisschen Stereotyp auch. Aber es ist schon was durchbrochen. Also es ist nicht mehr so undenkbar, dass Frauen Politik machen, wie es noch für 50 Jahre war. Und das funktioniert wirklich. Also wenn Frauen es dann einfach machen, ist es irgendwann für alle eine Selbstverständlichkeit zu sagen, natürlich kann eine Frau Kanzlerin werden. Hey, warum denn nicht? Und als Angela Merkel gegen Schröder angetreten ist, gab es im ZDF eine Umfrage. Trauen Sie einer Frau genauso zu, wie einem Mann Kanzler oder Kanzlerin in Deutschland zu sein? Und die Umfrage war ziemlich erschreckend mit Nein, ich traue es eigentlich einer Frau nicht so zu, wie einem Mann. Und diese Umfrage, würde man sie jetzt wiederholen, käme ein komplett anderes Ergebnis raus, weil wir hatten jetzt ganz lange eine Frau und die meisten sind relativ doch zufrieden mit ihr. Also, im Vergleich mit Schröder, gibt es da sicherlich gar keine Abstriche zu machen. Und das hat schon einen Effekt.
Heißt das, dass man eigentlich im Prinzip jetzt hier auch schon so dabei ist. Die letzten großen Steine aus dem Weg zu räumen? Und wenn dann sozusagen das in der Politik ausgeglichen ist und es genug Vorbilder gibt, dann ist alles gut?
Für den Bereich Politik könnte man diesen Optimismus vielleicht langsam an den Tag legen. Also, müsste man nochmal genau hingucken, welche Politikbereiche Frauen besetzen. Sind sie Wirtschaftsministerin, sind sie Finanzministerin, sind sie Verteidigungsministerin? Oder Bildungsministerin, genau. Da müsste man nochmal hinschauen. Da bin ich ja auch dafür, dass sich auch die Themen komplett durchmischen, geschlechtlich gesehen. Wir haben Verteidigungsministerinnen. In Spanien ist Verteidigungsministerin 2008 schwanger geworden und dann nach Afghanistan geflogen. Das ist alles existent. Aber in Deutschland ist alles immer ein bisschen später als in anderen Ländern.
Die Alltagssituation scheint aber dann doch noch ein bisschen anders geprägt zu sein. Jenseits der prominenten Leuchttürme und sichtbaren Personen, die ja dann auch vielleicht als Vorbilder sind, aber dann doch eben deswegen Vorbilder sind, weil sie eben herausragen aus der Gesellschaft als solches, weil sie eben wichtige Posten bekleiden oder sonst irgendeinen kulturellen Wert darstellen für alle anderen und deswegen geschätzt werden. Aber so im Alltagsleben sieht es ja dann doch anders aus. Bevor wir vielleicht nochmal so auf die aktuelle Situation kommen, würde ich das ganz gerne nochmal so ein bisschen, habe ja jetzt auch den Feminismus als Thema auch schon genannt haben, mal so ein bisschen zurückgehen in die Vergangenheit, um mal so ein bisschen Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie sich das eigentlich bisher so verhalten hat. Weil viele Leute verbinden das eine oder andere mit dem Begriff. Einiges scheint mir davon auch noch sehr in der Vergangenheit, wenn auch in der näheren Vergangenheit vor Ort zu sein. Wo würdest du denn sagen, dass, wenn man jetzt so auf die Menschheitsgeschichte blickt, dieses Mann-Frau-Thema das erste Mal, ja, was soll ich sagen, ein Problem war es wahrscheinlich schon immer irgendwie. Aber wo es dich auf einer intellektuellen Ebene auch entwickelt und positioniert hat?
Die ersten mir bekannten Quellen sind in der Antike bei Aristoteles, der in seiner Politik ganz klar diese Polles umreißt.
Die Gesellschaft.
Die Gesellschaft, ja. Polles ist ja der athenische Stadtstaat gewesen. Wie soll diese Polles organisiert sein? Er ist ja quasi der Vordenker für Demokratie. Weil er gesagt hat, alle freien Männer treffen sich dort und entscheiden über die Geschicke der Polles. Und da geht es schon los. Also er hat wirklich gesagt, die Männer entscheiden damit. Alle freien Männer und hat damit ausgeschlossen, dass einerseits Sklaven, die halt absolut üblich waren zu der Zeit, und Frauen. Und die Frauen waren die Herrinnen oder die hatten das Sagen im Haus. Also die standen nochmal über den Sklaven natürlich. Aber sie waren zuständig für das Eukos und das Haus. Und das war Aristoteles. Also da kann man das schon sehen, dass diese Trennung schon sehr weit fortgeschritten war in seinem Kopf. Blickt man zurück, gibt es verschiedenste Theorien darüber, wie sich das entwickelt hat. Also die Evolutionsbiologen sind da ja ganz fleißig dabei, das zu rechtfertigen mit, ja, als die Menschen auch in den Höhlen gelebt haben, da sind die Männer halt jagen gegangen und die Frauen waren zu Hause und haben die Kinder behütet und so weiter. Das sind letztendlich natürlich alles Spekulationen ein Stück weit. Aber das hätte sich ja in unsere Gene eingeschrieben und deswegen sei das auch bis heute der natürliche, manche behaupten, das sei bis heute die natürliche Aufteilung, die allen am meisten entgegenkäme. Ob das so ist oder nicht, mag ich nicht bewerten oder beurteilen, aber es hat sicherlich ein bisschen was mit den Aufgaben, Verteilungen zu tun, die sich auch entlang von Kinderpflege und Familien und so weiter irgendwie gestellt hat. Also zum Beispiel, um bei dem Beispiel Athen und Griechenland zu bleiben, wurden ja sehr viele Kriege auch geführt. Und da stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wen schickt man denn in solche Kriege? Also wer führt denn Kriege? Wer sind die Soldaten? Sind das jetzt Frauen? Sind das Männer? Ist das eine gemischte Gruppe? Und es hat sich halt entwickelt, dass Männer in den Krieg ziehen und nicht die Frauen. Und wenn Männer in den Krieg ziehen...
Weil sie stärkere sind.
Ja, das ist ja immer so ein bisschen... Es gibt sehr schwache Männer und sehr starke Frauen. Also das ist eigentlich kein Argument, sondern ich denke, das Argument wird auch da gewesen sein, naja, Frauen sind halt die reproduktiven Kräfte der Gesellschaft. Die müssen Kinder auf die Welt bringen, die schenken Leben. Und die sind nicht dazu da, ihr Leben zu opfern. Also es gibt ja so eine ganz starke Opfermentalität auch bei Männern. Also sie sind halt eher bereit, ihr Leben zu lassen und die Helden zu spielen, als es Frauen sind. Weil es eine sehr lange Geschichte ist, die immer wieder erzählt wird. Udde Soys und ganz viele Kriegsschrecken. Ja, natürlich. Obwohl da bricht es ja auch langsam mal auf. Also so ein bisschen. Und ich denke, da kommen wir her. Also von dieser wirklich tausendealten Aufteilung. Und an der knabbern wir natürlich noch. Weil es ist das, was in allen Geschichten erzählt wird. Es ist das, was die Biologen uns erzählen. Es sei das Natürliche und so weiter. Und weiter ging es dann eigentlich erst so ein bisschen. Naja, in der gesamten darauffolgenden Geschichte trennt es sich immer auf. Weil in den Krieg Männer ziehen. Aber das Thema Geschlecht und die Arbeitsteilung von Geschlechtern im Frieden, sage ich es mal, auf den Plan kommen, ist eigentlich erst im Bürgertum. Also als sich das Bürgertum entwickelt, so 17., 18. Jahrhundert herum.
Aber ich meine, auch so in diesen ganzen monarchischen Strukturen, so gab es ja auch Königinnen. Ist ja nicht so, dass es jetzt nur...
Aber nicht wirklich in Deutschland. Ja. Jein. Also sie waren aber nie, in Deutschland zumindest, in England war das ein bisschen was anderes. Also da gibt es ja die großen Königinnen von Victoria über Elisabeth und so weiter. Aber in Deutschland waren es schon eher die Könige, die die Herrscher waren. Also da waren die Königinnen die Frauen von den Königen, die anhängten. Aber nicht explizit die, die geherrscht haben. Und in England gibt es da irgendwie ein bisschen... Also England hat das ein bisschen durchbrochen, da war das anders, teilweise. Aber selbst da hatten diese...
Russland auch? Schon ein bisschen was zu sagen gehabt, ne? Also ich will da jetzt gar nichts mit herleiten oder so. Ich denke halt nur gerade darüber nach, inwiefern sich sozusagen in einer Gesellschaft so eine ausschließlich männliche Dominanz festmacht. Oder es dann eben doch eher so die Stände sind. Weil klar, da lässt man sich dann lieber, hat man lieber eine Frau als Königin, als dass man das komplette Adelsgeschlecht aufgibt, weil im Wesentlichen zählt natürlich der Unterschied zur Unterschicht etc. Oder wie viele Geschichten es auch immer gibt. Das ist ja dann eh nochmal was, was ja eigentlich auch wiederum erzählt, dass es dann eben jetzt auch nicht immer nur die Spaltung bei Männern und Frauen stattfindet. Ich meine, es ist ja auch in unserer Gesellschaft jetzt nicht sehr viel anders.
Also du hast es auch schon sehr gut begründet gerade, dass es dann eben wichtiger war, das alles Geschlecht weiter intronisiert zu halten und nicht abzugeben. Also dann akzeptiert man auch mal eine Frau. Aber gerade in England war es natürlich ein wahnsinniges Versagen von Königinnen, wenn sie keine männlichen Nachkommen geboren haben. Also dann, so kam das ja dann nur. Das wurde gerade bei Henry VIII, also der 8. Heinrich, ist das sehr großes Thema, dass er dann ja auch seine Frauen gewechselt hat, wie nichts Gutes, und immer scharf darauf war, einen Sohn zu kriegen, was ja irgendwie nicht so richtig geklappt hat bei ihm. Ironie der Geschichte, also das geschieht ihm ja auch ganz recht. Naja, und das Zweite ist, es gibt eine Theorie, das ist wirklich nur eine Theorie und ein Modell, die das auch so ein bisschen darauf zurückführt, dass Frauen überhaupt gebären können. Und dass sie damit so ein bisschen was wie die Verkörperung der Natur sind, und Männer können das halt nicht. Und die Theorie besagt, dass Männer als Ausgleich dafür, dass sie das nicht können und sich dann vielleicht minderwertig gefühlt haben, sowas wie Kultur geschaffen haben. Also die Frauen stehen dann halt für Natur und das sich fortpflanzen. Und es ist ja auch sehr verehrenswert, sehr lange gewesen. Und Männer stehen für Kultur, also alles, was eben erst geschaffen wurde durch den Menschen. Das ist auch eine Theorie, kann man vielleicht hinzuziehen, wenn man über sowas nachdenkt. Ich bin da noch unentschlossen. Aber ich finde es ganz gut für den Hinterkopf, sowas alles zu wissen.
Sicherlich was dran.
Ja, irgendwo schon.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das so automatisch als Mann so unbedingt jetzt in diesen Vergleich zieht. Aber dass die Männer schon irgendwie so ein Schaffensding treibt, denke ich, das ist offensichtlich.
Und Frauen schaffen von Natur aus.
Du wolltest das Bürgertum einbiegen, da habe ich dich nochmal in die Monarchie entführt.
Bürgertum ist für diese ganze Entwicklung sehr wichtig, weil da mehrere Sachen aufgekommen sind im Vergleich zu vorher. Ich bin ja Erziehungswissenschaftlerin und habe mich in dem Zusammenhang damit sehr beschäftigt, weil im Bürgertum das Kind entdeckt wurde. Man spricht von der Entdeckung des Kindes. Man meint damit diesen Geistesblitz. Ach so, wenn man ein Kind ist, ist man anders als Erwachsene. Vorher wurden Kinder als kleine Erwachsene behandelt. Es gab auch nicht wirklich Spielzeug in dem Sinne. Sie wurden nicht groß anders behandelt. Man hat sie halt mit durchgefüttert, aber man hat es nicht als eigenständige Lebensphase wahrgenommen. Es gibt auch Studien, also was heißt Studien, es gibt einfach Überlieferungen aus der Zeit, wo Menschen, die damals gelebt haben, aufgeschrieben haben, wie sie als Kind, als Kinder gelebt haben. Und wir wissen, dass sie schon gespielt haben. Aber sie haben das unter sich getan. Sie sind in den Wald zum Beispiel gegangen und haben da mit Stöckern oder irgendwelchen anderen Sachen, die sie halt gefunden haben, gespielt. Und dass sowas entwickelt wurde wie Spielzeug, was ja heutzutage gar nicht mehr wegzudenken ist. Also es gibt ja... .ommass Spielzeug und ja auch sehr viel Spielzeug, was nur dafür konzipiert wurde, damit die Kinder möglichst viel damit lernen und möglichst intelligent damit werden. Das gab es früher alles überhaupt nicht. Darüber hat man sich gar keine Gedanken gemacht. Und das kam mit dem Bürgertum auf, dass festgestellt wurde, also da kamen die ersten Denker, die festgestellt haben, Kinder sind irgendwie anders. Und man sollte sich vielleicht Gedanken machen über die Erziehung von Kindern, weil das Einfluss darauf hat, wie erfolgreich man im Leben ist. Das kam alles da auf. Das Bürgertum ist ja sozusagen auch eine...
Und bei welchen Zeiträumen reden wir jetzt eigentlich?
So 17. bis 18. Jahrhundert rum. Oder ja, da kam das alles erst auf. Das kann man sich heute auch nicht mehr so richtig vorstellen. Aber davor hat man nicht darüber nachgedacht, dass Kinder irgendwie besonders behandelt werden müssten. Außer Aristoteles, der war auch da schon wieder weiter. Aber wir wissen ja auch, dass mit der Renaissance erst wieder vieles ausgegraben wurde, was in der Antike schon mal gedacht wurde. Also da ist dazwischen ja sehr viel auch wieder verloren gegangen. Ja, das hat sicherlich auch viel mit der Religion zu tun. Und mit dieser Entdeckung der Kindheit kam auch die Verantwortung für Kinder, übernehmen zu müssen, damit sie ein erfolgreiches Leben führen können. Und das kam eben mit dieser Möglichkeit, in so etwas wie das Bürgertum auch aufzusteigen. Also qua Fertigkeiten oder Wissen, so viel Geld verdienen zu können, dass man in eine andere Schicht aufsteigt, bedingt. Also in den Adel ging natürlich trotzdem nicht.
Immerhin in die Burg?
Ja, zum Beispiel. Oder auch nur in der Stadt, aber trotzdem mit einem kleinen Reichtum.
Also beschützt, mein ich. Die Mauer geht drum herum. Die von der Burg beschützt werden, und die Mauer geht nochmal drum herum. Genau.
Und mit dieser Aufgabe, das zu sichern auch, also diesen erarbeiteten Reichtum zu sichern, sind Kinder auf die Welt gekommen. Und das auch zu erhalten für die Familie. Sprich, es war ein Arbeitsauftrag an Eltern da, sich um diese Kinder plötzlich zu kümmern. Auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise als vorher. Und so entstand diese Arbeitsteilung auch zwischen Männern und Frauen, weil man dann halt gesagt hat, ja, das ist die Aufgabe der Mütter. Und gleichzeitig kam man noch so ein bisschen auf, dass es schick war, wenn die Mutter, also die Frau, zu Hause bleiben konnte und nicht arbeiten musste. Und der Mann so viel Geld verdient hat, dass er eine ganze Familie damit unterhalten konnte. Also das war dann auch noch ein Statussymbol.
Stimmt, das muss man ja auch erst mal klar machen, dass das irgendwann mal anders war.
Ja, in den ganzen Bauernfamilien davor, also als es wirklich Adel gab und dann nichts, und dann Unterschicht Bauern.
Ich meine, das kann man ja schon jetzt auch als Unterfortschritt für Frauen deutlich verbuchen, oder?
Naja, in den Bauernfamilien war es halt so, dass Männer und Frauen haben gleichermaßen auf den Äckern gearbeitet. Männer und Frauen waren genau gleich eingespannt. Da gab es keinen Unterschied. Es gab auch niemanden, der sich explizit um Kinder gekümmert hat. Die liefen halt so mit und mussten auch mit auf den Acker. Das war egal, die mussten halt die Arbeit machen können, damit sich die Familie ernähren kann. Mehr mussten Kinder nicht können.
Okay, verstehe. Das heißt, der Unterschied ist jetzt überhaupt erst mal, der Unterschied in der Arbeitsaufteilung, der Gesamtarbeitfamilie ist dadurch quasi erst eingeleitet worden?
Ja, also dieses Männern nach außen außerhalb des Hauses und Frauen innerhalb des Hauses kamen genau dann erst. In dieser kam wieder. Also bei Aristoteles hatten wir es schon mal und dann kam es halt sehr stark wieder. Genauso wie dieses Idealbild der romantischen Liebe ist ja auch erst in der Zeit entstanden. Und spielt ja auch eine wichtige Rolle in den Geschlechterverhältnissen. Nein, nicht. Also es war die Ausnahme. Dass es ein Idealbild wurde, dass ein Mann und eine Frau, die miteinander Kinder haben, sich auch lieben, das kam wirklich erst in dieser Phase der Romantik. Also es heißt ja auch nicht umsonst Romantik. So mit Goethe und, wie heißen sie alle, nur Valis und diese ganzen. Das gab es vorher so nicht. Das waren Zweckbeziehungen vorher, die man halt hatte. Und na gut, dann hatte man sicherlich auch Sex, aber meistens hatten die Menschen, die miteinander verheiratet waren, viel mehr Sex mit anderen Menschen als miteinander. Weil diese Ehe war eine Zweckgemeinschaft. Und wenn man Spaß wollte oder sich irgendwie verliebt hatte, war das häufig dann noch außerhalb der Ehe. Man blieb aber zusammen, weil es hatte ja einen Zweck. Und dass sozusagen die Ehe und dieses Lieben und auch Spaß miteinander haben, zusammengehören sollen, die Idee kam auch erst dann auf. Als relativ zeitgleich mit der Idee, ach so, Kindheit ist vielleicht was, wo man sich mal drum kümmern sollte.
Und das ist sozusagen die Situation, die sich dann bis ins letzte Jahrhundert ja eigentlich auch so fortgesetzt hat und weiterentwickelt hat.
Ja, das hat sich so weiterentwickelt. Mit dem Bürgertum kam noch was, nämlich die Idee, dass man aufsteigen könnte. Und es gab einfach so eine gewisse Öffnung der Gesellschaft dadurch.
Also vorher war es ausgeschlossen, da war man sozusagen in seine Kaste hineingeboren, einmal Bauer, immer Bauer, einmal Adel, immer Adel, und daran ändert sich nichts.
Und das Bürgertum war so ein Zwischending. Also es stellte dann so ein bisschen dieses Mittelding da. Und qua Fähigkeiten und Engagement und Arbeit konnte man eben reich werden jetzt auch. Bildung. Und da mit einhergehen dann natürlich auch, was Bourdieu Habitus nennt, dass man, wenn man denn da ist, auch sich auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise verhalten muss. Also Statussymbole, eine gewisse Sprache. Eine Zeit lang war es modisch, französisch zu reden in Deutschland. Also so diese ganzen, ja, Ausdrucksformen, mit denen man sich dann doch wieder nach unten hin abgrenzt. Auch wenn man vielleicht selber von da unten kam. Aber wenn man aufgestiegen ist, muss man es halt auch schaffen, sich wieder nach unten abzugrenzen. Weil sonst hätte der Aufstieg ja nichts gebracht.
Man muss das auch für sich selber sozusagen sichtbar machen. So wie die Handy-Taschen, die dann irgendwann in den 90er-Jahren aufkamen.
Genau so. Und dazu gehörte es dann eben auch, es sich leisten zu können, dass die Frau zu Hause bleibt. Dass eine Frau arbeitet, stand dafür, dass die Familie so arm war, dass auch die Frauen arbeiten mussten. Das stand also für Armut. Und es sich leisten zu können, dass die Frau zu Hause bleibt, ist ein Status-Symbol geworden.
So mein Auto, meine Frau, mein Haus.
Und das Interessante ist, dass dann nach dem Krieg, vielleicht auch schon ein Stück weit vorher schon kurz, dieses Status-Symbol als gesellschaftliches Normalmodell expandiert ist. Das hat dann plötzlich jeder gemacht. Das kam auch so ein bisschen mit dem Wohlfahrtsstaat, mit der sozialen Absicherung, das ganze Normalarbeiterverhältnis und so weiter. Die 50er-Jahre stehen ja dafür, dass wirklich alle Frauen zu Hause geblieben sind, zumindest in der BRD.
Im Westen?
Genau, in der DDR nicht. Da steht das genau dafür nicht. Aber im Westen sind ja wirklich alle Frauen zu Hause geblieben.
Interessant. Wenn man sich die 50er-, 60er-Jahre Eigenwerbepropaganda anschaut, da wurde ja im Prinzip das geradezu zelebriert. Waschmittelwerbung, die Waschmaschine und so weiter. Eine schon ein bisschen orgasmische, beglückte Hausfrau, die ihre Verzückung überhaupt nicht mehr in den Griff kriegen konnte. Aber dann auch zunehmend so hingetragen wurde, als die Celebrationsmeisterin, MC des Hauses, Master of Ceremony. Ja, die Zigaretten müssen stimmen und alles, das Haus muss gemacht sein und sauber, rein, wohlgeordnet, schick, wenn der Mann dann nach Hause kommt und so mit seinem Auto von der Arbeit in die Garage fährt, dann muss irgendwie alles stimmen. Kann man ja sehr deutlich rauslesen, aber muss man sich hier nun mal so alte Werbung ein bisschen auf YouTube entgegenblättern lassen. Man findet fast gar nichts anderes als das.
Genau, das ist also das Interessante, dass es zum, ja, es wurde normal. Es wurde das, was als normal galt, von allen akzeptiert und das Richtige, obwohl es eigentlich vorher etwas war, was nur der oberen Schicht vorbehalten war. Und ich glaube, es gibt so Theorien, die sagen, das kam damit, dass sich der Wohlstand eben auf alle ausbreiten sollte, mit diesen ganzen Sozialgesetzen und so weiter. Und der Wohlfahrtsstart als solcher auch geschaffen wurde und intronisiert wurde, der für alle sich verantwortlich fühlte. Und dadurch war das dann so ein Stück weit möglich. Also es war das Celebrieren lassen auch, nur eben anhand von Geschlechterrollen.
So Rechte der Frau, mit den 50ern kommen wir schon ein bisschen in die Neuzeit rein, aber jetzt so auch Anfang des Jahrhunderts war es ja, und in der Schweiz bekannterweise hat es noch etwas länger gedauert, zumindest in allen Teilen. So auch das Wahlrecht für Frauen ja noch eine sehr umstrittene Geschichte.
Genau, das kam, man muss sich das vorstellen, ja wirklich erst vor 100 Jahren etwa, dass Frauen auch wählen durften. Und es war ein riesiger Kampf dafür. Also wenn man sich die Schriften von den damaligen Frauen mal so durchliest, ganz schön sind auch immer die Schriften von Hedwig Dom zum Beispiel, ist das eine Welt, in die man eintaucht, die man sich heute eigentlich gar nicht mehr vorstellen kann. Und die ist dann aber auch wieder biologistisch begründet worden damals. Es gab einen Biologie-Professor, war es glaube ich, an der Universität Harvard, hoffe ich. Das steht in dem Geist-Guide drin, müssen wir nachher nochmal nachschlagen, der gesagt hat, Frauen haben ja kleinere Gehirne als Männer und deswegen dürfen sie nicht studieren. Das ist auch so ein Thema, dass Frauen den gleichen Bildungsweg einschlagen dürfen wie Frauen. 1870 oder so hat er das noch gesagt. Und wenn wir Frauen jetzt studieren lassen würden mit ihren kleineren Gehirnen und dann würden diese Gehirne wachsen, dann müsste ja der Uterus schrumpfen. Ich weiß nicht, das gab es sowieso. Das ist diese Verknüpfung bei Frauen von damaligen Biologie-Professoren und Wissenschaftlern, dass man deren Gehirne mit ihrem Uterus immer irgendwie verknüpfen musste, war so eine irre Idee dieser Zeit. Ein anderes Thema, also ich gehe jetzt nochmal zurück hinter das Wahlrecht, aber ich glaube, das hängt damit zusammen. Ein anderes Thema ist das Thema Hysterie. Das war eine Krankheitsdiagnose, die man Frauen gestellt hat, die sich irgendwie komisch verhalten haben, so ein bisschen nicht ganz da waren und so weiter. Heute würde man wahrscheinlich sagen, die Frauen wollten einfach Sex und hatten keinen. Und da hat man die Frauen dann auch zum Arzt geschickt und dann wurden die mit Massagen befriedigt, damit das wieder weggeht, vom Arzt, vom Hausarzt. Der hat sich dann gekümmert. Es wurden dann auch so die ersten Dildos erfunden. Das waren riesengroße Maschinen, auf die man dann die Frauen gesetzt haben, damit diese Hysterie wieder weggeht. Ja, wirklich. Maschinen. Ja, so wurde der Dildo oder der Vibrator erfunden.
So als sich hin und her bewegende Maschinen. Heute im Porno-Business mit Maschinen wieder zu kultureller Größe.
Ja, dampfbetriebene Dildos. Also gib mal die Hysterie-Maschine bei Google ein. Hysterie, so nannte man das dann, oder was? Ja, das war eine Krankheit, die nannte man Hysterie. Das müsste auch in der Wikipedia stehen, denke ich.
In der Englischen steht es unter Female Hysteria.
Und das wurde als behandlungsbedürftig angesehen. Und die Theorie, die dahinter stand, war, dass der Uterus der Frauen vom Gehirn irgendwas absaugte. Und deswegen musste man da unten was behandeln, damit der Uterus das nicht mehr macht. Also wir lachen jetzt heute drüber, aber im Grunde ist es natürlich furchtbar traurig, wie man mit Frauen umgegangen ist. Man hat ja auch erst Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts herausgefunden, dass Frauen auch Orgasmen haben. Das wusste man vorher nicht.
Das wird ja nichts ausgeschieden.
Ja, wie traurig, wenn man sich das vorstellt, wie lange es die Menschen schon gibt. Und wie lange sie vermutlich schon Sex haben miteinander. Und dass dann erst Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts jemand auf die Idee kommt, zu sagen, Huch, Frauen haben ja auch einen Orgasmus. Also dass es erst dann bemerkt wird. Entscheidend auch nicht.
Man hat es nicht so definiert.
Ja, man hat es halt nicht einordnen können. Man hat es hysterische Krise genannt. In Zusammenhang mit dieser ganzen Hysterie-Theorie. War das dann die hysterische Krise, dann haben sie das alles so von sich rausgeschrien und gezappelt und weiß ich nicht, was getan hat, was man halt so tut, wenn man einen Orgasmus hat. Und dann war die Sache wieder gut. Also es ist alles fürchterlich.
Wann wurde das erfunden?
Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts. 1800 noch.
Also kurz vor der Relativitätstheorie sozusagen.
Ja, es ist absurd, wenn man sich schaut, wie viel wussten Menschen da schon, wie viel hatten sie schon entdeckt. Man wusste ja auch, dass die Erde keine Scheibe ist und so weiter. Das wusste man alles schon viel früher, aber dass man sich mal Gedanken darüber gemacht hat, wie das bei Frauen so alles mit der Sexualität ist, das war nicht der Fall. Das war völlig uninteressant.
Die von Winter Hittwig-Dom, die jetzt so mit... Also sie war sozusagen auch Teil dieser Bewegung gegen das nur für Männer gedacht Wahlrecht, also für das Frauenwahlrecht.
Ja, sie war insgesamt eine frühe Feministin. Also sie hat schon die ganze Gesellschaft betrachtet und jetzt nicht nur den politischen Bereich.
Ja, ich wundere mich jetzt gerade sozusagen in so einer Gesellschaft, wo die Frauen so bei Design immer die zweite Geige spielen sozusagen. Und von daher ja auch an keinerlei Machthebeln sind, mit wenigen Ausnahmen wahrscheinlich, die dann wieder die Regel bestätigen. Hast du da einen Einblick, was sozusagen das dann zum Kippen gebracht hat, dass die Männer an der Stelle auch klein beigegeben haben? Weil ich meine, es ist ja sozusagen der Machtverlust in Anführungsstrichen. War das irgendwie eine Einsicht oder war das irgendwie, keine Ahnung?
Das ist eine verdammt gute Frage.
Hat das ein Sexboikott oder was hat die dann dazu gebracht, da Einsicht zu haben? Ich meine, das ist ja Feminismus, das ist auch, sagen wir mal so, einer der Gründe, warum ich jetzt dieses Thema hier auch in die Sendung heben wollte. Es steckt ja auch so ein bisschen im Namen. Es ist immer so, ja, das ist ja so das Thema der Frauen. Sagt ja schon der Name. Und mit Feminismus beschäftigen sich nur Frauen. Und wenn man dann so ins Netz guckt, so wer schreibt denn da drüber, dann gibt es dann feministische Blogs und feministische Podcasts, wo dann Frauen darüber reden. Aber es ist so wie kein Männerthema, weil es geht ja nur um Frauen. Also da beißt sich irgendwie die Katze auch immer so ein bisschen in den Schwanz. Aber auf der anderen Seite, und ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen die Sicht, die du ja auch mit vertrittst, ist es ja eigentlich eher eine generelle Frage des Verhältnisses und der Bedeutung auch des Verhältnisses von den Geschlechtern in der Gesellschaft. Kann man sagen, dass sich das, ich weiß jetzt nicht so sehr, an diesem Wahlrecht festmachen, aber wir hatten ja jetzt sozusagen diese Betrachtung Bürgertum, dadurch kam dann sozusagen überhaupt erst mal diese Rollentrennung stärker auch nach vorne, auch aus vielen guten, nachvollziehbaren Gründen. Und dann gab es quasi die fortschreitende Evolution von Revolution, will ich jetzt gar nicht mal reden, Evolution der Gesellschaft und ihrer Strukturen, wo dann eben die Frauen irgendwann an den Punkt kamen und gesagt haben, hier gibt es eine generelle Ungerechtigkeit, eine generelle Ungleichheit. Das ist ja dann quasi so der, oder ist eher eine Frage, ist das sozusagen der Auslöser, der Beginn einer solchen feministischen Bewegung gewesen?
Na ja, es gab schon ein bisschen früher die ersten Denkermänner, zum Beispiel John Stuart Mill, der mit seiner Frau zusammen so eine Art Liebes- und Denkbeziehung hatte und der auch feministisch schon war. Der hat sich allerdings noch nicht so genannt, aber er hat sich schon sehr für die Rechte der Frau noch stark gemacht. Und lag wahrscheinlich daran, dass er ein Liberaler war. Also es war so ein Liberaler Denker, der sich sehr viel Gedanken gemacht hat über Gerechtigkeit und über Freiheit, also dieses Spannungsverhältnis auch zwischen Gerechtigkeit und Freiheit, und wie man die Gesellschaft eigentlich gestalten müsste. Und was ja die französische Revolution in ihrer Befreiung sozusagen immer vergessen hat, nämlich die Frauen mitzudenken, hat er einfach gemacht, weil ich glaube, er mit einer Frau zusammen war, die ihm ebenbürtig war, ganz klar, wo er das auch nicht wegdiskutieren konnte, dass sie ebenbürtig ist, dass sie genauso intelligent ist, wie er genauso gut denken kann. Und dann sich das eben bei ihm entwickelte zu sagen, ja na klar, müssen die Frauen genauso daran teilhaben an dieser Gesellschaft. Warum denn nicht? Es gibt eigentlich keinen Grund. Und wahrscheinlich ist es dieses immer wieder auch im Persönlichen dann runtergebrochene Miteinander von Frauen und Männern, das an den entscheidenden Punkten das Argument dafür ist. Also gerade bei Männern, die humanistisch argumentieren, also humanistisch im Sinne von Gerechtigkeit als zentralen Wert haben, Gerechtigkeit für alle Menschen, Gerechtigkeit für alle Menschen unabhängig von ihrem Stand und ihrer Herkunft. Dass diese Männer dafür offener sind, die Gerechtigkeit natürlich auch für Frauen mitzudenken, als Männer, die eher konservativ orientiert sind. Oder religiös. Also religiöse Denker tun sich in der Geschichte und auch bis heute viel, viel schwerer damit zu akzeptieren, dass Frauen die gleiche Rolle in der Gesellschaft wahrnehmen können, als es eben die Humanisten tun. Nun denken die meisten Frauen trotzdem nicht automatisch mit, sondern man muss es ihnen halt unter die Nase reiben, dass es da Ungerechtigkeiten gibt und denen man ihnen es aufzeigt. Und ich glaube, die Frauen Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts, die gesagt haben, es ist ungerecht und widerspricht euren ganzen Idealen, die bei der französischen Revolution irgendwie eine Rolle gespielt haben, dass ihr uns ausschließt. Es gibt dafür keine Begründung. Das könnt ihr nicht machen. Und es war dann eben auch in der SPD, dass das so ein bisschen aufgebrochen ist. Es waren immer die linken, progressiveren oder liberalen Bewegungen und politischen Parteien, wo das zuerst aufgebrochen ist. Logischerweise, weil da einfach diese Offenheit oder dieser Grundgedanke der Gerechtigkeit noch mal viel, viel stärker eine zentrale Rolle gespielt hat. Und ich glaube, wir reiben euch das unter die Nase. Wir zeigen euch auf, dass es eben nicht gerecht ist. Hat wahrscheinlich in dem Moment dann irgendwann funktioniert, weil man hatte die besseren Argumente. Der zwanglose Zwang des besseren Arguments, so ein Stück weit. Und das ist das, worauf Feministinnen bis heute eigentlich setzen müssen. Dass sie die Ungerechtigkeiten auf den Tisch bringen und sichtbar ansprechen. Gegebenenfalls auch durch irgendwelche Aktionen. Also damals war es der legendäre Tomatenwurf bei einem SPD-Parteitag, wo nur Männer geredet haben, wo fast nur Männer irgendwie das Wort hatten. Und dann sind die Frauen halt hergegangen und dann flog eben eine Tomate. Ich tue mich immer sehr, sehr schwer mit Jahreszahlen, aber das kann man in unserem feministischen Lexikon bei Frau Lila nachlesen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, wir sind immer noch vor dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Also wir sind noch am Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts. Also feministisches Lexikon bei Frau Lila, da unter T wie Tomatenwurf, da steht es drin. Ja, so ein bisschen. Es ist nicht vollständig von A bis Z, aber wir wollen es auch noch ein bisschen erweitern. Ja, und solche Aktionen sind natürlich aufsehenerregend. Die meisten empören sich dann erstmal, wie können diese Frauen es wagen, eine Tomate zu werfen. Aber sobald man eben eine Debatte über etwas hat, und sei es jetzt nur, wie kann denn da bitte nur eine Tomate fliegen, hat man eben eine Debatte. Die größte Waffe gegen die Emanzipation der Frau ist ja, sie unsichtbar zu machen und sie nicht zu Wort kommen zu lassen. Und in dem eben die Debatte dann da ist, durchbricht diese Unsichtbarkeit auch.
Was hat sich denn in der Zeit Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts getan? Gab es dann schon eine Bewegung, die sich selbst auch feministische Bewegungen genannt hat?
Es nannte sich, glaube ich, eher einfach Frauenbewegung. Also Feminismus, weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, wann der Begriff zum ersten Mal aufkam. Das ist mir jetzt ein bisschen peinlich. Ich meine, dass es damals noch unter Frauenbewegung lief. Es wird auch die erste Frauenbewegung genannt. Und es wurde damals ja auch der Frauentag, der jetzt 2011 das 100. Jubiläum hatte. Also 1911 wurde er das erste Mal gefeiert, der internationale Frauentag. 1911 war ja auch ein Frauentag. Also es war schon sehr lange so ein Label Frauenbewegung. Es war auch wirklich eine Bewegung. Feminismus wird ja gerne vorgeworfen. Das klingt schon so nach Ideologie. Also mit dem Keine-ismen. Ich mag keine-ismen, die finde ich alle scheiße. Also ein sehr häufig an mich gerichtetes Argument, wo ich denke, ach so, bist du gegen Humanismus? Interessant.
Ich glaube, auch Emanzipation war lange Zeit so ein dominanterer Begriff.
Ja, auch das. Wobei Emanzipation natürlich ein viel weiterer Begriff ist und nicht nur die Frau abdeckt, wird sehr häufig nur mit der Frau in Verbindung gebracht. Emanze, das geflügelte Wort daraus. Emanzipation, Frauenbewegung, Feminismus. Weiß ich gar nicht, wann das Wort aufkam. Ist auch...
Wichtig ist, wann der Feminismus aufkam.
Ja, naja, ziemlich zu dieser ersten Frauenbewegungszeit, würde ich sagen. Also das ist dann schon wirklich Feminismus, weil die Frauen angetreten sind, die Gesellschaft umzuwälzen.
Also im Prinzip ist das erstmal so ein intellektueller Aufbruch gewesen.
Ganz klar. Die wollten wählen können, die wollten genauso in die Universitäten und in die Schulen.
In die Politik.
In die Politik. Die wollten einfach diese ganzen Bereiche, wo sie ausgeschlossen waren, erobern.
Dabei stand jetzt, sagen wir mal, so dieses... Die Bekämpfung des Frau-Macht-Kindes- Erziehung-Fraues-Zuhause noch gar nicht so im Vordergrund.
Genau. Nein, nein, das stand noch nicht im Vordergrund. Das war eher so, dass die damals noch ganz stark versucht haben, das auch unter einen Hut zu bringen. Also, dass sie gesagt haben, na ja, Frauen sind einfach Mütter. Es ist ganz wichtig, dass wir Mütter sind. Also, viele von denen haben das so gesagt und auch argumentiert. Das hat sich bis in die zweite Frauenbewegung auch noch ganz stark mit hineingezogen. Das ist der sogenannte Differenzfeminismus. Also, wo man schon akzeptiert hat, Männer und Frauen sind sehr unterschiedlich. Das ist auch ganz klar, weil von Natur aus, und die einen kriegen Kinder, und die anderen nicht. Das ist doch logisch. Und die einen können sich auch besser um die Kinder kümmern. Das wurde alles noch nicht in Frage gestellt. Also noch nicht so vehement in Frage gestellt, wie in der zweiten Frauenbewegung dann schon mehr. Sondern es ging wirklich um die ganz fundamentalen Rechte. Also es ging um Rechte der Frauen. Frauenrechte, die ja nicht gegeben waren.
Also eher Menschenrechte sozusagen.
Ja, genau. Jetzt auch neu für Frauen. Darum ging es. Ist auch, glaube ich, verständlich. Also wenn man sich selber versucht, da hineinzuversetzen, gerade wenn ich als Frau mich versuche, da hineinzuversetzen, ich wäre in dieser Zeit gewesen, dass man zuerst mal die ganz offensichtlichen Probleme, die ja auch schwarz auf weiß in Gesetzen niedergeschrieben sind, anpackt, um dann vielleicht weiterzudenken, erscheint ja logisch. Deswegen gibt es, glaube ich, auch immer so verschiedene Wellen des Feminismus, weil dann, wenn das eine geschafft ist, also Wahlrecht für Frauen, sie dürfen studieren, sie dürfen in die Schulen genau so gehen wie die Männer, wenn das eine geschafft ist, gibt es immer erst mal so eine etwas Beruhigungsphase, also so eine Phase, wo man denkt, wir haben es geschafft. Wir haben es ja geschafft. Und dann ist erst mal so ein bisschen Ruhe, dann kommen vielleicht noch die 50er Jahre, wo alle ganz happy sind und keiner irgendwas in Frage stellt. Nicht so wirklich. Und dann kommt so die nächste Welle, wo man merkt, na Moment, es gibt ja noch massiv Ungerechtigkeiten. Die sind vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so klar, weil sie nicht mehr ganz so klar schwarz auf weiß stehen wie noch Anfang des Jahrhunderts. Aber teilweise stehen sie auch schwarz auf weiß. Also es gab ja diese Regel, dass Frauen nur arbeiten dürfen, wenn ihre Männer dazu zustimmen.
In Deutschland?
In Deutschland.
In 60er Jahren?
Bis in die 60er Jahre rein. Ja, wirklich. Das war ein Gesetz. Verheiratete Frauen. Auch es gab sehr viel zwischen, also um die Institution Ehe herum, sehr viele Gesetze und Regelungen. Also wie auch Frauen sich zu verhalten haben, die nicht verheiratet sind. Also ob die auch eine Wohnung alleine bewohnen dürfen und so weiter. Ich kenne da Geschichten, dass unverheiratete Frauen, die irgendwie schon 30, 40 waren, vielleicht auch ein Kind hatten, aber sie waren halt unverheiratet, wurden dann sehr stark von den Hauswartinnen oder von den Besitzerinnen der Wohnung ja fast schon observiert. Also die durften dann auch keinen Männerbesuch nach Hause bringen oder solche Sachen. Bei Männerbesuch durfte man ja nur nach Hause bringen, wenn man verheiratet war, nämlich den Mann. Das war ja alles noch vor der sexuellen Revolution. Also das darf man ja auch nie vergessen. Die sexuelle Revolution und die zweite Welt des Feminismus waren im Grunde fast zeitgleich. Also dass diese ganzen sehr prüden Denkstrukturen aufgebrochen sind, war fast zeitgleich und die Männer haben das eben auf ihre Art und Weise gemacht damals. Und in 68 ging das ja los, 70er Jahre, mit ihren Kommunen und war zweimal mit der gleichen Pent. Gehört schon zum Establishment. Genau. Und die Frauen haben das dann auch gemacht. Also die hatten auch eine sexuelle Befreiung. Das weiß man allerdings, kennt man allerdings nicht so sehr wie bei den Männern.
Naja, ich meine, woran ich mich noch stark erinnere, jetzt nippen wir dann aber auch schon so langsam in die 70er rein, war ja dann auch so der starke Protest gegen die Abtreibungsregeln in Deutschland. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie das so in Österreich etc. aussah. Wahrscheinlich wieder mal ähnlich, aber anders. Das spielte ja dann auch mit rein.
Genau, die Macht über den eigenen Körper, würde ich das mal zusammenfassend nennen, war dann ein großes Thema für bewegte Frauen, für Frauen. Und das kam aus Frankreich herüber geschwappt. Also es war ja tatsächlich ein Stück weit Alice Schwarzer, die diese ganze Pro-Abtreibungsbewegung, diese ganze Aktion, wie sie hier gemacht hat, ich habe abgetrieben, gab es davor schon in Frankreich. Und sie hat das halt nach Deutschland getragen, hat es dann dem Sternen angeboten. Die haben gesagt, können wir machen, ob das so interessant wird oder so. Ich weiß nicht.
Wahrscheinlich das berühmteste Titelbild, das die Sternen je hatte.
Es hat natürlich wieder niemand so richtig ernst genommen, was das für eine Welle schlagen würde. Und Alice Schwarzer hat irgendwann mal gesagt, sie hat es selber auch nicht gedacht und ist auch froh, dass sie sich doch vorher drüber nicht so viel Gedanken gemacht hat.
Muss man vielleicht auch noch mal sagen, was es denn für Wellen geschlagen hat, weil ich weiß nicht, wann war das, das muss irgendwie 70 gewesen sein. Dieses Sternen-Cover, ganz viele Fotos von Frauen, darüber halt groß der Titel, so ich habe abgetrieben und damit sozusagen dieses nach außen gehen, so ich habe auch, sagen wir mal, Illegales getan. Das war ja sozusagen das, was dahintersteht, weil es eben verboten war.
Und es waren auch prominente Frauen, das muss man halt ganz richtig sagen.
Genau, und das hat die Gesellschaft dann doch schon ziemlich erwischt, also es war dann ein heißes Thema und hat die Debatte sozusagen aus dem Nichts entfacht.
Ja, es war, bis dahin hat niemand darüber gesprochen.
Weil es halt auch so ein Tabuthema war.
Es war ein absolutes Tabuthema, es war verboten. Es ist auch etwas, wofür sich Frauen sicherlich bis heute schämen. Also wenn man, also ich kenne ein paar Frauen, die abgetrieben haben, ich kenne eigentlich keine, die sich nicht dafür auf irgendeine Art und Weise schämt. Das ist ganz, ganz schwierig, weil man hat ja so einen Auftrag. Ja, dieser unbewusste Auftrag, der von der Gesellschaft mitschwingt, an Frauen herangetragen. Und dann gibt es ja noch die ganz krassen Abtreibungsgegner, die auch sagen, dass es Mord ist. Das nimmt im Leben sicherlich die meisten Frauen nicht für sich an, die sowas tun, dass sie sagen, ich ermorde da gerade einen Menschen. Aber ich glaube, es steht einfach im Raum. Naja, und dieses Ich habe Macht über meinen eigenen Körper steht halt nicht im Raum. Es ist nicht gleichwertig. Es ist nach wie vor und zwar bis heute der Kampf. Ist dieses Kind, was da in dem Bauch der Frau ist, ist das noch Teil der Frau? Also ist es ihr eigener Körper? Oder ist es schon ein neues, eigenes Leben? Und wenn nicht, wo beginnt das dann? Wann beginnt es, das zu sein? Also da gibt es auch wahnsinnige philosophische Debatten drüber. Weil, ab wann ist ein Mensch ein Mensch? Es gibt die einen, die sagen halt, naja, es ist halt ein Mensch, ab dem Moment, wo es auch ohne jegliche Hilfe außerhalb des Körpers der Frau überleben würde. Andere sagen, es ist ein Mensch, ab dem Moment, wo die Samenzelle die Eizelle befruchtet.
Das ist im Wesentlichen eine Ansichtssache, denke ich, an der Stelle. Und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob man da jemals so Einigkeit erzielen wird.
Ist es vielleicht auch gar nicht nötig. Ich finde eigentlich nicht, dass es nötig ist, da 100% eins zu sein. Das einzige Problem ist, dass man immer Grenzen festlegen muss. Im Moment sind wir bei der 12. Schwangerschaftswoche. Bis dahin darf man es in Deutschland legal irgendwie tun. Es ist ja immer noch verboten, aber straffrei. Und dadurch kann es getan werden. Keine Ahnung, es ist eine ganz, ganz, ganz schwierige ethische, philosophische Debatte. Aber der Punkt, dass Frauen selber darüber entscheiden können müssen, ob sie Mütter werden, gerade in einer Gesellschaft, wo Mutter sein so einen Rattenschwanz an Verpflichtungen und Verantwortung und Erwartungen mit sich bringt.
Und einschneidende Lebensveränderungen vor allem.
Einschneidende Lebensveränderungen. Wenn man alleinerziehend ist, dann auch noch potenzielle Armut. Find ich, ist eigentlich nicht diskutabel. Also solange das so ist, kann man Frauen nicht das Recht nehmen, über ihr eigenes Leben zu bestimmen und wie es weitergeht. Und das war, glaube ich, der Punkt, den die Frauen damals im Stern haben ja auch begründet, warum sie es getan haben. Sie haben ein kurzes Statement dazu gehabt, ich habe abgetrieben. Und dann ist natürlich die Debatte erst mal so boom mitten in Deutschland drin. Und keiner hat eigentlich damit gerechnet und keiner wollte sie führen. Es gibt ja immer Debatten, die sind unterm Teppich. Und es sind sich auch alle eigentlich, dass sie unter dem Teppich gehören. Ich glaube, das gibt es heute auch noch. Wir können nachher noch drüber reden. Und dann war es da. Und das gleichzeitig überhaupt drüber nachdenken, was für ein Recht hat eine Frau an ihrem Körper. Also in den 50er Jahren war es sehr, sehr klar, dass Frauen an ihrem Körper eigentlich nicht sehr viele Rechte hatten. Es gab diese unausgesprochene Verpflichtung von Frauen, wenn sie verheiratet sind, dann haben sie Gefährlichst mit dem Mann auch Sex zu haben. Und zu gebären. Also wer verheiratet ist, der soll bitte auch Kinder kriegen und so weiter. Es gibt ja bis heute sehr viele Erwartungshaltungen.
Es ist ja ohnehin diese herausragende Stellung der Heirat. Oder die Ehe, die ist auch immer so schön leicht überhöht, das Wort schon verstörend. Ich will jetzt gar nicht so über Ehegattensplitting und sonstige Sonderrechte reden, aber es ist ja generell klar, dass immer ein unglaublicher Popanz aufgeführt wird um diese Konstellation. Wenn man dann den Schritt in die Kirche gemacht hat, die Orgel tönt, etc., großes Brimborium, auf einmal ist alles anders. Dann hat man diesen Normalzustand hergestellt, der wir hergeleitet haben, diese Rollenverteilung impliziert. Nicht in allen Fällen. Natürlich hat so ein Paar weitgehend die Möglichkeit, das selber zu machen. Aber lange Zeit gab es auch Begleitregelungen, mit dem Man über die Rechte der Frau. Viele Dinge, die die Frau betreffen, sind auf einmal anders. Das ist etwas, was heute noch da ist. Auch heute haben wir in der Steuer und anderen Stellen auf einmal alles anders, wenn man in dieser Konstellation angekommen ist.
Es gibt Langzeitstudien darüber, wie sich Männer und Frauen in ihren Ehen verhalten. Die haben abgefragt, wie sie zu Beginn der Ehe leben wollen. Da die Mehrheit gesagt hat, dass sie gleichberechtigt sind, arbeiten sie beide und kümmern sich, wenn sie Kinder bekommen. Das Ideal der gleichberechtigten Partnerschaft, die meisten glauben eigentlich schon daran. Die gehen in die Ehe ein und zu Beginn glauben sie immer noch daran. Diese Langzeitstudie hat verfolgt, wie sich die Realität ausgestaltet. Über die Jahre hinweg, das waren 10, 15 Jahre. Der Prozentsatz derer, die tatsächlich gleichberechtigt leben, schwand immer weiter. Und irgendwann war es die Mehrheit der Paare, die nicht gleichberechtigt gelebt haben, sondern in der klassischen Rollenaufteilung. Er arbeitet ganz viel und ist der Hauptverdiener und ist dafür verantwortlich, dass die Familie zu essen hat und genug Geld verdient für Urlaub und weiß nicht was. Sie ist zu Hause vor allem, wenn überhaupt, dann Zuverdienerin, ist verantwortlich für den Haushalt, ist verantwortlich für die Kinder und so weiter. Und nicht etwa, dass sich das dann aufgelöst hätte, wenn die Kinder aus dem Gröbsten raus sind. Das war noch das Erschreckendste an der Studie, sondern auch bei Schulkindern im Alter von 10, 15 Jahren ist es nicht wieder zurückgegangen. Es ist eine Arbeitsaufteilung, die sich wirklich eingeschliffen hat. Und da steht man als Feministin natürlich auch etwas zerknirscht davor. Weil man denkt, naja, in der Theorie hatten die das mal ganz gut verinnerlicht. Das war ihr Ideal. In der Praxis handeln sie plötzlich komplett anders. Da guckt dann eben so eine Feministin dann auch hin, warum.
Ich habe so den Eindruck, ich weiß nicht, wie du das so lebst und erfährst, dass der Begriff Feminismus dann doch eher unpopulärer Begriff ist, für manche auch so ein rotes Tuch zu sein scheint. Viel, aber nicht alles macht sich da auch häufig ganz konkret immer so an Alice Schwarzer und was sie denn so getan hat, oder was Leute meinen, was sie getan hätte, fest. Wie siehst du das? Vielleicht kannst du auch noch mal so ein bisschen auf ihre Rolle eingehen.
Ich habe sie ja letztes Jahr mal kennengelernt. Ich hatte unter irgendeinem Blogbeitrag von ihr, wo sie wieder mal das Thema Alfa-Mädchen kurz angeschnitten hatte. Also als das Buch Wir Alfa-Mädchen von Susanne Klingner und Barbara Streit und Meryl Deshav rauskam im Jahr 2008, hat Alice Schwarzer sich ziemlich dagegen gewehrt und hat sich angegriffen gefühlt, hat dagegen ausgeschlagen. Es hat nicht unbedingt nur was mit dem Buch zu tun, sondern es kam gleichzeitig ein anderes Buch auf den Markt. Das hieß Neue Deutsche Mädchen. Und in dem Buch wurde gleich im ersten Kapitel gesagt, Feminismus ist ja irgendwie all und Alice Schwarzer will ja keiner mehr. Sinngemäß. Und diese beiden Bücher, weil sie zeitgleich rauskamen, wurden in den Medien immer behandelt als der neue junge Feminismus ist da. Und zitiert wurde oft aus Neue Deutsche Mädchen genau dieses Feminismus ist all oder Alice Schwarzer ist all. Könnte auch sein, dass es Alice Schwarzer als all war. Ich habe das Buch nie gelesen, muss ich sagen. Und es wurde eben transportiert, es stünde auch so in vier Alpha Mädchen. Steht es aber nicht. Das ist auch bei dem Gespräch mit Alice Schwarzer in der EMMA Redaktion wurde dieser Vorwurf wieder an mich oder an uns junge Feministinnen herangetragen und es war ziemlich schwer, ihnen zu vermitteln. Nein, es steht nicht schon in der Einladung drin, dass Alice Schwarzer all ist. Das ist nicht wahr. Weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Vielleicht tatsächlich nicht. Also das kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Wenn über Bücher diskutiert wird, immer das Gefühl, dass sich vor allem die Leute in die Medien zerren lassen, die es eigentlich alle nicht gelesen haben.
Oder die nur Sekundärquellen rezitieren oder so. Das ist auch wirklich ein Unding. Das machen aber auch viele Journalisten. Also dass Primärquellen behandelt werden, naja, ist leider die Ausnahme. Und in dem Zusammenhang fühlte sie sich halt sehr angegriffen, hat damals den Burne-Preisverdienen bekommen, hat dazu eine Rede gehalten und hat halt sehr gewettert gegen diesen Lifestyle-Feminismus und Wellnessfeminismus, den die selbsternannten Alpha-Mädchen fahren würden und ihre Persönlichkeit missbrauchen würden, um in die Medien zu kommen und so.
Wellnessfeminismus.
Wellnessfeminismus wurde es genannt. Ja, weil es ging dem Wellnessfeminismus ja nur darum, Latte-Makiato schlürfen zu können und ein angenehmes Leben zu führen. So war tatsächlich anscheinend, also ich hab's nicht gelesen, deswegen kann ich nicht so viel darüber sagen, aber nach allem, was ich hörte, aus Sekundärquellen, war Neue Deutsche Mädchen so ein bisschen so. Hat sich aber auch nicht feministisch genannt, weil Feminismus ist ja out. Ja, war eigentlich der Thema.
Was bei dem anderen Buch Alfa Mädchen nicht so ist.
Überhaupt nicht. Ja genau, Alfa Mädchen ist eigentlich das genaue Gegenteil. Es sagt Feminismus ist ein Begriff, der hat eine ganz lange Geschichte, der hat eine Tradition, die wir nicht einfach wegschmeißen dürfen, sondern die wir einfach packen sollten und da wieder ansetzen und zeigen sollten. Das ist für das, nachdem wir uns sehen als Frauen, die gleichberechtigt leben wollen in dieser Gesellschaft, egal in welchem Bereich, in den Medien, in der Politik, in der Familie zu Hause. Für diese ganzen Ziele ist Feminismus immer schon eingetreten. Und wir würden sehr viel wegschmeißen, wenn wir sagen würden, Feminismus ist aber eigentlich total doof. Na ja, und Alice Schwarzer hat diesen Begriff so ein Stück weit mit geprägt, klar.
Also im Prinzip, diese Generation Mädchen beruft sich explizit auf das Erbe dieser Zeit.
Auch dieser Zeit, auch dieser Zeit. Und auch Alice Schwarzer kommt in dem Buch schon drin vor. Und sicherlich wird an einigen Stellen auch gesagt, ne, also, Alice Schwarzer hat vielleicht das und das gesagt, heute würden wir eher so und so sehen. Zum Beispiel in der ganzen Pornografie-Debatte gibt es da ja schon Unterschiede. Aber es wird auch häufig positiv darauf rekurriert. Also eben, wie man das mit einem Buch macht, wo man irgendeinen Begriff behandelt oder irgendeine Bewegung starten will, die sich auf einen Begriff beruft, der schon ne Geschichte hat, würde man natürlich in diese Geschichte gucken und sagen, ja, was haben denn Feministinnen dazu bisher gemacht? Und das wird eben versucht, nochmal in einem breiten Publikum, in einer möglichst einfachen Sprache, also es war auch darauf ausgelegt, es gab mal so eine Aktion Alfa-Mädchen in die Schule, dass Schulkinder das lesen, dass sie einfach so einen kleinen Rundumschlag kriegen.
Bevor wir vielleicht hier auf die dritte Generation kommen, würde mich erstmal die zweite Generation nochmal interessieren, weil ich denke, dass das eben auch viele gar nicht so... Alice Schwarzer ist jetzt eine Persönlichkeit, an der man sich halt sehr leicht abarbeiten kann. Also sie ist sehr streitwürdig und auch sehr streitfähig. Und andererseits aber auch so omnipräsent in den Medien. Man hat immer das Gefühl, wenn auch immer irgendwie irgendein Thema aus einer Geschlechtsperspektive auch behandelt werden könnte, unter Umständen vielleicht so, dann wird sie halt gleich eingeladen. Das ist auch nur so eine Wahrnehmung, aber ich denke, die ist verbreitet. Von daher, was siehst du denn, was sich jetzt in dieser, von ihr und ihrer Zeitschrift immer natürlich auch und den anderen Leuten, die da mitgezogen haben, an dem Strang bewegt und erreicht worden in den 70er-Jahren? Wogegen hat sich das jetzt primär gerichtet?
Na ja, in erster Linie wirklich gegen diese sexuelle Fremdbestimmung von Frauen. Ich glaube, das war eines der zentralen Themen in den 70ern. Alice Schwarzer hat ja dann auch der kleine Unterschied und seine große Folgen rausgegeben. Das war ein Buch, was in Deutschland extremst eingeschlagen ist. Also was auch, es kam nach der Sternkampagne, soweit ich weiß, und das hat noch mal krasse an allen möglichen Tabus geredet. Was hat sie da gemacht? Sie ist eigentlich nur hingegangen, sie war ja Journalistin und hatte für verschiedenste Blätter schon geschrieben. Und es war auch ihre Leidenschaft, und sie ist hingegangen zu ganz normalen Frauen, die in ganz normalen Ehen lebten und hat mit denen gesprochen. Und zwar über Sex. Über Sex und über die Beziehung und wie Sex in diese Beziehung eingebettet ist, was für eine Rolle das spielt. Und es kam auf eine ziemlich erschreckende Art und Weise immer ein ähnliches Bild raus. Und dieses Bild war, dass Frauen sich mit Sex die Liebe des Mannes ein Stück weit erkauft haben. Und dass sie sich als sexuelles Objekt in der Ehe zur Verfügung gestellt haben und dafür einerseits Liebe bekamen, andererseits natürlich auch finanzielle Sicherheit und so weiter. Und das es aber um die eigene Sexualität der Frau in diesen Beziehungen nie ging. Also sie waren eigentlich kein sexuelles Subjekt, das aktiv irgendwas tat, sondern sie waren sexuelle Objekte, was sich darin gezeigt hat, dass nahezu alle berichtet haben, sie hätten keine Orgasmen, sie hätten häufig Schmerzen, sie hätten auch nicht so wirklich Spaß dabei. Darum ging es halt nicht. Es ging um die Befriedigung des Mannes. Und ich sagte vorhin schon sexuelle Befreiung. Die Feministinnen damals sind angetreten für die sexuelle Befreiung der Frau. In allererster Linie. Und Alice Schwarzer hat eine lange Tradition gehasst zu werden, weil, wie du dir vielleicht vorstellen kannst, die Männer in dieser Gesellschaft über so ein Buch nicht gerade amüsiert waren. Also sie hat es einmal so ausgedrückt, dass sie meinte, plötzlich lag sie rhetorisch, also sie lag quasi in den deutschen Betten zwischen den Männern und den Frauen. Weil natürlich das Buch war ein Bestseller. Und die Frauen haben das gelesen. Also nicht nur die Frauen, die darin interviewt wurden, sondern Frauen haben das gelesen und auch dann teilweise unter der Hand einander gereicht. Und ich glaube, es war für viele Frauen so ein richtiger Augenöffner. Ich meine, das ist ja auch, wenn du sowas vorher nie hinterfragt hast und du das als normal erlebt hast. Und ja, dann denkst du, ich muss mich halt anpassen. Das redest vielleicht mit deinen Freundinnen, denen geht es genauso. Und wenn dann jemand etwas mal problematisiert, was noch nie problematisiert wurde, ist es natürlich ein ganz großer Schock auch. Also es war für die Frauen, für viele Frauen damals auch ein Schock. Es gab auch bei den Frauen extrem große Abwehrmechanismen dagegen. Zu sagen, nein, das kann nicht sein, dass jetzt diese Frau hier herkommt und meine Ehe zerstört.
Ja, also der Illusionsdeckel hat ganz gut funktioniert bisher. Was fällt dir ein, den beiseite zu ziehen?
Und wenn man es so betrachtet, ist die Tradition, Alice Schwarzer zu hassen, schon sehr alt. Also natürlich wurde sie gehasst. Sie hat so ein bisschen mal erzählt, was für Reaktionen darauf kamen, wie sie angefeindet wurde. Das kann man sich heute teilweise gar nicht mehr vorstellen. Eigentlich hat sie das Unmögliche getan. Eigentlich hat sie etwas getan, was niemals jemand hätte tun dürfen. Sie hat aber ganz viel Geld damit verdient. Und das eben da reingesteckt zu sagen, gut, jetzt gründe ich noch mal eine eigene Zeitschrift.
Also mit dem Buch hat sie viel Geld verdient.
Ja, mit dem Buch. Sie hat so ziemlich das gesamte Geld in die Gründung der Emma investiert. Weil sie so viel Geld hatte, und weil sie dann mit dem Buch eine wahnsinnige Aufmerksamkeit hatte, war sie wahrscheinlich von Anfang an dafür prädestiniert, als die Vorreiterin zu gelten. Und das hat damals schon ganz viele Frauen tief unglücklich gemacht, die einfach in ihrem Schatten standen, die einfach gar nicht wirklich wahrgenommen wurden, obwohl sie genauso gekämpft haben. Ich hab zu Hause ein Buch stehen, das heißt die neue Frauenbewegung, und das ist von Ilse Lenz. Ist ein sehr dicker Schinken, also da steht ziemlich viel drin. Es deckt alle möglichen Themenbereiche ab, von Familie über Frieden und Krieg und Politik und Wirtschaft. Also es ist wirklich zu allen möglichen Themen aus verschiedensten Zeitabschnitten auch nochmal Texte von Frauen drin. Und ich war beschämt, als ich feststellte, die meisten Namen kenne ich überhaupt nicht. Habe ich noch nie gehört. Also die Schwarzer taucht auch immer wieder drin auf, aber es ist schon, also die Ilse Lenz hat sich schon die Mühe gemacht, viele andere zu suchen und zu nennen, die damals auch prominent waren, die auch in Zeitungen geschrieben haben und die Debatten mitbestimmt haben. Aber ihre Geschichte wurde nicht weitergetragen. Da musste jetzt erst so eine Frau wie Ilse Lenz kommen und diese Geschichte aufschreiben. Weil das Buch wird natürlich auch wieder nicht sehr breit wahrgenommen, sondern nur innerhalb einer gewissen Szene. Aber ich schaue da ganz oft auch nach, wenn ich irgendein Thema beackere, gucke ich auf der Reihen. Was haben die damals dazu gesagt? Was hatten die damals für einen Streit vielleicht auch darüber? Es gab sehr viel Streit innerhalb der Frauenbewegung, sehr viel in der feministischen Streit. Und das ist alles nicht in unserer Wahrnehmung heutzutage, dass es das gab, dass das vielfältig war, dass das bunt war, dass es von Konservativ, also Differenz feministisch, Mütterfeminismus gab es sogar, die argumentiert haben, Frauen seien dazu bestimmt Mütter zu sein. Und deswegen müsste der Staat ihnen das bezahlen, wenn sie Kinder aufziehen. Ein bisschen Betreuungsgeld, nur radikaler. Also, dass es wirklich als Arbeit entlohnt werden soll.
Auch eine Argumentation bei der Debatte ums Grundeinkommen?
Also, da war alles drin. Und das wird nicht wahrgenommen. Das ist ganz schade. Das ist aber nicht unbedingt Alice Schwarzers Schuld. Also, Alice Schwarzer hat halt gemacht, was ich jetzt, wenn ich mich selber betrachte, wahrscheinlich genauso gemacht hätte. Wir hatten Überzeugung. Und die hat sie von Herzen. Also, sie ist auch sehr politisch aufgewachsen, in einer sehr politischen Familie, in der Nachkriegszeit Kind gewesen, aber hat noch so dunkle Erinnerungen auch an diese ganze Nazizeit, wo sie, also ich glaube, 42 ist sie geboren. Sie war da drei oder so, als das Ganze auslief, aber sie hat das schon noch miterlebt auch. Und ist ein unglaublich politisierter Mensch und sagt von sich selber, ihr geht zum Gerechtigkeit. Und na klar, wenn man für eine gute Sache zu kämpfen glaubt, und ich würde auch sagen, sie kämpft für eine gute Sache und kriegt die Chance geboten, das ganz prominent und laut und sichtbar zu sagen und die Gesellschaft wachzurütteln, dann nimmt man die natürlich wahr. Das Problem ist auch, dass die Gesellschaft andere nicht wahrgenommen hat, sondern wirklich nur die, die das so radikal und so unübersehbar gestört haben. Die leiseren Töne eben nicht wahrgenommen wurden. Das ist meiner Meinung nach auch ein Ausdruck von Sexismus einfach. Da können wir später nochmal zu kommen zum Thema Sexismus. Und dann bei Alice Schwarzer, um das noch zu Ende zu führen, glaube ich aber schon auch die Prägung, nenne ich es mal, diese Macht ungern aus der Hand geben zu wollen, aus Angst davor, dass dann das, wie sie es machen will oder die Ziele, die sie hat, nicht mehr weiterverfolgt werden. Also ein bisschen Kontrollverlust, sagst du.
So ein bisschen Eifermädchen ist sie ja auch. Ich kann ja nicht auf den Apprede stellen. Gut, das ist ja jetzt, sagen wir mal, eine sehr wohlwollende Sichtweise. Trotzdem gibt es auch Differenzen. Du hast es schon angesprochen, so im Bereich Pornografie. Das war natürlich auch ein Dorn im Auge der Bewegung. Das hatte ich auch nachvollziehbar, weil jetzt Pornografie gibt es in allen möglichen Ausprägungen. Und wenn ich jetzt mal wieder so ein bisschen zurückdenke, 70er, 60er. Ich meine, das ging natürlich auf einer Seite auch einher mit so einer Aufklärungswelle. Das war ja dann geradezu ein Hype, ja. Da freuten sich auch viele darüber, dass das jetzt ein Thema war, weil dann kamen dann auf einmal so Filme raus wie Schulmädchenreport und so weiter, was so ein bisschen Schlüssellochaufklärung war. Die sind da auch teilweise mehr so den Voyeurismus bediente, als jetzt tatsächlich da eine soziologische Aufgabe zu erfüllen. Wie siehst du das?
Würde die These aufstellen, dass Alice Schwarzer gegen den Schulmädchenreport wahrscheinlich nicht sehr viel hatte? Und zwar aus folgendem Grund. Ich habe auch immer gedacht, Pornografie, wie kann man da dagegen sein? Das ist ja völliger Schwachsinn. Weil Pornografie ist ja nicht gleich Pornografie. Und es gibt Pornos, in denen ist die Rolle der Frau auch sehr stark. Es gibt ja sowas wie feministische Pornos. Es gibt den Feministischen Porno Award sogar mittlerweile. Ja, Feminist Porn Award. Da tut sich schon was. Und in den 70ern war eigentlich auch diese Erotik-Filmchen, nenne ich sie mal, waren ja, wenn man das vergleicht mit dem, was man heute so im Netz findet, eigentlich total cool. Also es gibt auch eine Bewegung von Frauen aus der Schweiz, deren Namen mir jetzt natürlich entfallen ist. Das ist nicht nachtragend. Die suchen aus den 70er Jahren, stellen die so Madlays zusammen aus den 70er Jahre Pornos und verkaufen die wieder neu. Und das ist ein super Projekt, das ist, finde ich sehr spannend. Nee, Alice Schwarzer hat bei dem Treffen letztes Jahr mit uns jungen Feministinnen ein bisschen so ein Augenöffner dabei gehabt zum Thema Pornografie, weil sie gesagt hat, naja, aber Pornografie ist doch gar nicht das, was ihr immer alle denkt, was Pornografie sei. Pornografie ist doch qua Definition nur das, wo Frauen von Männern unterdrückt werden oder wo Gewalt von Männern gegenüber Frauen geübt wird. Alles andere ist doch gar keine Pornografie. Nicht so, hä, was ist denn das für eine Definition von Pornografie? Also so steht es weder in der Wikipedia noch in sonst irgendeiner Enzyklopädie. Und da ist es halt wieder wichtig, die Geschichte zu betrachten. Die Geschichte von Pornografie ist, dass in den 70er Jahren, als Alice Schwarzer angefangen hat, sich dagegen zu wehren, definiert war, als alles, was gegen die guten Sitten und gegen den Anstand für stieß. Also sehr schwammig und breit definiert. Gesetzlich. Ach so. War gesetzlich Pornografie, war gesetzlich verboten. Es gab einen Pornografie-Paragrafen. Und in dem Stand verboten ist, also alles, was pornografisch ist, ist verboten. Und pornografisch ist, was gegen die Sitten und den guten Anstand verstößt.
Das ist alles pornografisch.
Das ist pornografisch. Dann sind die Feministinnen hergekommen. Und da fiel dann zum Beispiel auch drunter, wenn zwei Frauen oder zwei Männer irgendwie Sex oder nur Küssen oder irgendwie Erotik austauschen, das ist schon gegen die Sitten und den guten Anstand. Es war also für die Feministinnen eine Frage der sexuellen Befreiung zu sagen, das kann ja alles sein. Also das schränkt uns ja völlig ein. Wir wollen diesen Pornografiebegriff umdefinieren. Und unsere Definition soll sein für das Gesetz, Pornografie ist die Unterdrückung und Gewalt an Frauen.
Verstehe, sie haben versucht, das Wort neu zu definieren.
Genau. Es geht bis in die 80er Jahre rein, dieser Streit. Da waren noch einige SPD-Politikerinnen dabei und haben sich dafür eingesetzt, dass das so undefiniert wird.
Das war dann taktisch doch eher unklug, einen bereits etablierten Begriff zu nehmen, anstatt einen neuen einzigartigen.
Nein, der Begriff war damals noch nicht so etabliert, wie er jetzt ist. Was taktisch unklug war, ist, dass sich diese Position nicht geändert hat. Von zum Beispiel Alice Schwarzer, aber auch von der Emma. Dass sie nicht gesagt haben, jetzt in den 90ern ist Pornografie plötzlich jede Darstellung von Erotik und Sex. Egal wie, ob im Film, ob im Foto, ob in einem Buch geschildert. Das haben sie nicht akzeptiert, sondern sie haben darauf beharrt, zu sagen, nein, Pornografie soll nur das sein, was Frauen unterdrückt oder was Gewalt gegenüber Frauen ist. Das ist das Missverständnis. Und da sind sie heute noch. Also Alice Schwarzer war bei dem Gespräch auch ganz stur, hat gesagt, wie könnt ihr nur das nicht wissen, ist doch völlig klar, das weiß doch jeder, das ist in Frankreich bekannt und in den USA. Und wir saßen da so da, wir waren ja zu dritt, die zwei Missy-Chefredakteurinnen und ich saßen erstmal so total verdutzt da. Dann hat jeder von uns langsam wieder das Wort ergriffen und versucht ihr zu erklären, was daran das Problem ist. Und das ist eben die meisten Menschen nicht so verstehen. Das hat sie aber alles abgebügelt und hat gesagt, nö, im Grunde hat sie uns vermittelt, warum sollte ich von dieser Positone abrücken, die ist doch total logisch. Und wir erklären es ja auch immer in der EMA, wenn wir wieder was zu Porno machen. Ich versuche auch seitdem immer, wenn ich mit Leuten darüber rede, ihnen das zu vermitteln. Was ein Problem ist, wo ich Differenz sehe, ist dieser ganze Bereich BDSM. Weil sie da, glaube ich, schon so ein bisschen sagt, naja, die Frauen, die sich als masochistisch einsortieren in ihren sexuellen Praktiken, das ist ja bloß wieder die Macht des Patriarchats oder so ungefähr. Also das tun die ja nicht freiwillig. Das kann man ja nicht freiwillig tun. Also ich glaube, das ist schon ihre Position. Das kann sie, glaube ich, nicht wirklich nachvollziehen, dass es so etwas gibt, dass Frauen das gerne tun und lustvoll tun und emanzipiert tun. Also für sie schließt sich das, glaube ich, miteinander aus. Diese freiwillige Gewalt.
Das ist so eine neue Entwicklung auch, glaube ich, in der Sexualität an sich, dass da anders mit umgegangen wird. Woran auch sicherlich Porno, so wie wir das jetzt, glaube ich, ganz automatisch verstehen, auch nicht ganz unschuldig ist. Was dann wiederum ja auch eine Normalisierung ist. Ich meine, was ich jetzt interessant finde, jetzt hast du es ja auch schon partiell mit aufgebracht und die ganze Debatte des Feminismus drehte sich und dreht sich auch immer noch um Gleichberechtigung und natürlich auch um das Vermeiden und Verhindern von Unterdrückung im Gesamtbrei Geschlechterverhältnisse, Sexualität und wie wir es eben so schön hatten, alles, was so gegen die Sitten verstößt. Also es ist eigentlich immer so dieses Normale, was die Gesellschaft ausruft, was aber in irgendeiner Form mit Rollen und Geschlechtern zu tun hat und dann eben natürlich auch zwangsläufig mit Sex. Da spielt natürlich dann auch wieder Rum und Mit rein, zumindest heute, Schwulenbewegung, Lesbenbewegung bzw. alle sonstigen Formen von Intergeschlechtlichkeit etc., wo ich mittlerweile auch immer ein bisschen daran versage, das dann irgendwie auch alles vollständig aufzuzählen, weil es scheint mir dann im Zweifelsfall immer noch eine weitere Definition zu geben, die ich jetzt nicht auf dem Zeiger habe.
Du hast bestimmt die A-Sexuellen vergessen.
Die wollen jetzt auch Rechte?
Was heißt Rechte? Nein, es geht ja auch oft darum, dass man nicht unsichtbar gemacht wird in Debatten. Also das ist ja immer auch ein Kampf der Frauen gewesen. Wir wollen nicht unsichtbar sein. Wir wollen, dass man einfach aussieht, ja, es gibt sie. Und es gibt auch A-Sexuelle. Man muss ja gar nicht alles aufzählen, das glaube ich nämlich nicht. Ich glaube einfach, dass man offen sein muss für alles. Und wenn es einem dann über den Weg läuft, vielleicht wenn man zum Beispiel Tim Pritlove ist, und ganz viele Menschen hören einem zu, und dir läuft jetzt jemand über den Weg, dieser Mensch ist asexuell, dass du dann denkst, wow, das ist ja spannend. Was bedeutet denn das? Und wie fühlt man sich da? Und wie lebt man da? Und vielleicht dann einlädst du zu einem CRE und dann spreche dir mal darüber.
Das tue ich ja auch. Die Fragestellung ist für mich jetzt eher, Alice Schwarzer definiert Porno als Gewalt gegen Frauen. Und jetzt würde ich fast schon der neuen feministischen Bewegung eher nahelegen, dass sie wahrscheinlich das so sieht, so falsch ist. Oder Pornografie würden wir es nicht mehr nennen. Wir würden jetzt ein anderes Wort dafür nehmen. Unterdrückung, was weiß ich, ist Unterdrückung von, nicht nur Frauen, sondern auch von Männern oder Schwulen, oder wer sich in dem jeweiligen Kontext unterdrückt fühlt. Das ist so eine Bewegung, die sich da jetzt aufgemacht hat. Während Alice Schwarzer noch sehr in dem alten Männerfrauenkampf. Gestartet ist, geht das jetzt mehr in die Breite?
Ja, genau, das geht mehr in die Breite, was auch logisch ist. Das war das, was ich vorhin meinte, immer wenn neue Wellen kommen, ist es ja auch etwas zu merken, dass an vielen Ecken und Enden es immer noch hakt. Und bei Feminismus sind das immer die Ecken und Enden, die sich in irgendeiner Weise um Geschlecht herumordnen sollen.
Genau, die Wellen, die du vorhin erwähnt hast. Das heißt, wenn jetzt die 70er Jahre, so die Emmerwelle, die ist dann irgendwie verappt und das Gefühl hat man glaube ich auch, so dass es zumindest so in den 90er Jahren erstmal, da ging es jetzt erstmal um Techno und Ecstasy und so und Internet, davon haben jetzt auch alle irgendwie genug gehabt, jetzt kommt wieder was auf. Was kommt auf? Was ist sozusagen jetzt der, wo juckt es, was treibt die nächste Welle? Was ist sozusagen da der Juckreiz, der bedient werden möchte?
Das hast du irgendwie jetzt so lustig ausgedrückt. Nein, der Reiz war das Übliche. Also, dass man gemerkt hat, alle erzählen mir als Frau, ich hätte alle Möglichkeiten und kann machen, was ich will.
Du hast den Motto, es gibt doch jetzt eine Frau in Zeit, was wollt ihr denn noch?
Genau, aber wenn ich wirklich versuche zu machen, was ich will, stoße ich an Grenzen, die mir gesetzt werden. Wo mir gesagt wird, das macht man nicht als Frau, oder wo vielleicht ganz subtil mit mir gar nicht geredet wird, weil ich eine Frau bin, wo ich vielleicht nicht ernst genommen werde, weil ich eine Frau bin, eventuell auch, es mir selber auch schon häufig genug passiert, dass ich, weil ich eine Frau bin, irgendwie sexualisiert begriffen werde, also als Sexobjekt wahrgenommen werde, man klatscht mir einfach auf den Po oder so, solche Dinge. Und was die meisten Frauen, die ich kenne, dann sehr politisiert, ist, Kinder zu kriegen, weil sie dann merken, okay, ich habe jetzt Kinder, mein Leben ist aber gar nicht so unkompliziert, wie ich immer dachte, dass es sein würde, wenn ich mal Kinder habe, sondern an einen Ecken und Enden schmeißt man mir Steine in den Weg, weil ich die Mutter bin. Bei dem Vater tut man das nicht, ironischerweise. Karriere-Steine zum Beispiel. Oder auch, naja, diese ganze Erwartungshaltung, die dann mitkommt. Als Mutter, als gute Mutter muss man für das Kind ganz viel da sein und dafür sorgen, dass es sich psychisch gut entwickelt. Also diese ganze psychische Entwicklung steht ja in Elternschaft momentan wahnsinnig im Vordergrund. Wenn Kinder irgendeine psychische Macke haben, und den meisten Kindern wird im Laufe ihres Lebens heutzutage eine psychische Macke attestiert, weil es gibt ja auch immer mehr psychische Macke, die man irgendwie diagnostizieren kann. Wenn es sie noch nicht gibt, wird sie halt erfunden. Wird zurückgeworfen auf die Mutter. Und Mütter fühlen sich viel stärker dafür verantwortlich dann. Und auch schuldig, als das Männer tun. Und werden auch von der Gesellschaft viel stärker als verantwortlich gesehen. Das heißt, diese ganze Last auf der Schulter von Müttern hat zum Beispiel überhaupt noch gar nicht abgenommen. Und dann auf der anderen Seite auf der Arbeit, wenn man jetzt Karriere, wenn Frau jetzt Karriere machen will, dieses Unverständnis auch dafür oder diese Selbstverständlichkeit, mit der ganz viele Chefs zum Beispiel Stellen dann nicht mit Müttern besetzen, weil sie davon ausgehen, das ist eine Stelle, da muss man 60 Stunden arbeiten, das schafft die nicht. Zwei Fragen, die dabei aufkommen. Warum ist es angeblich naturgesetzt, dass man auf dieser Stelle 60 Stunden arbeiten muss? Und warum ist es angeblich naturgesetzt, dass eine Mutter das nicht kann? Also das sind die zwei Fragen, die sich dann da stellen, die sich bei Männern anscheinend, wenn sie Väter sind, überhaupt nicht stellen, komischerweise. Was für Männer aber ein Problem ist. Da sind wir genau an dem Punkt, dass glaube ich der dritte Juckreiz gerade ist, dass viele Frauen, gerade heterosexuelle Frauen, aber auch Frauen, die vielleicht gar nicht in heterosexuellen Beziehungen sind, merken, die Männer haben sich nicht mit uns oder nicht mit emanzipiert in den vergangenen 30 Jahren. Die machen noch ihr altes Spielchen. Die teilen die Macht in der Gesellschaft weiterhin unter sich auf. Es gibt genügend Studien, die zeigen Männer an entscheidenden Machtpositionen und Frauen holen Männer nach oben, weil sie halt, und zwar weiße Männer, wenn sie weiß sind, meistens sind sie weiß, weil es einfach so ein Gesetz ist, so ein unbewusster Drang, die zu sich hochzuholen, die einem ähnlich sind, möglichst ähnlich. Und Frauen sind Männern immer noch nicht sehr ähnlich. Das wird vielleicht noch 100 Jahre brauchen, bis das auch aufgebrochen ist. Und das ist ein Polygramm. In der Politik der Fall, in der Wirtschaft der Fall und das Verhalten von Männern im ganzen Sozialbereich bzw. überhaupt dort eingebunden zu werden, ist dann das nächste klassische Problem. Also da kommen sogar von der Männerbewegung jetzt Problematisierungen, die halt sagen, es kann doch nicht sein, dass in den Grundschulen vor allem Frauen Lehrerinnen sind und irgendwie auch in den Kindergärten Frauen Erzieherinnen sind und jetzt am Ende Jungs rauskommen, die schlechtere Bildungschancen haben als Mädchen. Also jetzt mal völlig unabhängig, ob ich diese Positionierung teile. Ich teile sie nämlich nicht. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es die Schuld der Frauen ist, dass die Jungs in der Schule schlecht sind. Aber es wird halt gesehen, es gibt ein Ungleichgewicht. Und das sehen die Männer auch. Und es ist wichtig für Jungs, also da bin ich selber auch felsenfest von überzeugt, dass sie in ihren Bildungseinrichtungen oder in ihren Kitas Männer haben, an die sie sich auch wenden können. Ich finde das eigentlich ganz klar, weil das spielt eine Rolle. Männer transportieren nochmal ein ganz anderes Bild von Leben, einfach aufgrund ihrer Sozialisation und so weiter. Also da kommt jetzt halt eben von der anderen Seite auch nochmal so ein bisschen der Druck. Und man könnte vielleicht auch sagen, dass der jetzige Feminismus auch ganz stark mit daran arbeitet, dass es keinen Backlash gibt. Also keine Rückentwicklung hinter das, was bisher schon erreicht wurde, was auch schon mal diagnostiziert wurde. Also dass Frauen sich nicht wieder mehr in die alten klassischen Rollen reindrängen lassen sollen. Zum Beispiel in Schönheitsrollen oder in Mutterrollen oder für das Haus zuständig und so weiter und so fort. Was gleichzeitig gerade schon sehr stark idealisiert wird auch von vielen Konservativen. Oder es ist auch sozial gegliedert. In vielen sozialen Schichten gilt es weiterhin als normal, dass Frauen nicht die gleichen Karrierechancen wahrnehmen, wie es Männer tun. Und das gilt als okay.
Es ist ja eigentlich nach wie vor dasselbe Problem, dass die Old-Boys-Networks vor sich hin arbeiten und dass sich das jetzt nach wie vor als Problem zeigt.
Richtig. Ja, gerade auch in den Bereichen, wo man denken würde, da ist es nicht so. Ich kenne es jetzt nur von den Grünen, aber die grünen Frauen haben schon auch immer damit zu kämpfen, dass als gutes Politikmachen die Art und Weise gilt, wie Männer Politik machen. Also wenn man da ein bisschen, wenn man nicht so, wie soll ich denn das nennen, schon allein die Art zu reden zum Beispiel. Frauen haben eine andere Stimme. Es gibt Sprechtrainerinnen oder Trainer für Frauen, die versuchen, ihnen bald springend tiefer zu reden, damit man sie ernster nimmt. Warum? Also warum ist es ein Automatismus, dass ich einen Menschen nicht ernst nehme, wenn er nicht tief genug redet? Ist aber so. Also es ist bei Männern und Frauen der Effekt, dass sie gerade in der Politik jemanden ernster nehmen, wenn er nicht so hoch spricht, sondern ganz tief. Das ist nur so ein Beispiel oder diese Ausstrahlung auch von Männern. Ich denke dann immer an Joschka Fischer versus Claudia Roth zum Beispiel, wenn die Reden halten. Das ist komplett unterschiedlich. Und gerade in den Medien wird Joschka Fischer, aber auch innerhalb der eigenen Partei, wurde Joschka Fischer immer wahnsinnig ernst genommen. Und der hat auch immer eine sehr pathetische Art und Weise gehabt, seine Themen und seine Anliegen als extrem wichtig und alternativlos darzustellen, während Claudia Roth dann gerne mal als die weinerliche dargestellt wird oder als lächerlich. Also sie wird, ich finde an der Person Claudia Roth zum Beispiel kann man sehr gut nachvollziehen, wie das abgewertet wird, wie Frauen agieren. Anstelle auf die Inhalte zu schauen, nur auf die Art und Weise zu gucken, wie sie sich kleidet oder sich darüber zu beschweren, dass sie dann Tränen in die Augen bekommt, wenn sie über Menschenrechte in einem anderen Land spricht, was tatsächlich bei ihr vorkommen kann, weil sie halt ein sehr emotionaler Mensch ist. Das wird alles automatisch abgewertet. Das ist ein Fakt in dieser Gesellschaft. Und wenn Angela Merkel zum Beispiel wird auch viel stärker nach ihrem Outfit, was trägt sie denn heute wieder für ein Kostüm, in den Medien bewertet als jeder andere Politiker. Also da gibt es mittlerweile auch Auswertungen darüber, die gucken, wie behandeln die Medien Politikerinnen und Politiker? Worauf achten die bei denen? Wie stellen die die da? An einer Seite werden Politikerinnen sehr viel seltener thematisiert. Man zitiert sie seltener. Sie kommen seltener zu Wort in den Medien. Und wenn sie dann mal thematisiert werden, ist es ganz, ganz häufig, signifikant häufiger als bei Männern, dass es um ihr Äußeres geht und ihre Art und Weise und nicht die Inhalte. Und das ist ein klar feministisches Thema, weil hier wird überall mit Doppelstandards gemessen wird, wo ein Mensch aufgrund irgendeines Merkmals anders behandelt wird als andere Menschen. Sei das jetzt das Geschlecht, sei das die sexuelle Orientierung, also die Klischees gegenüber sogenannten Schwuchteln, das ja immer noch als Schimpfwort gilt, sind ja riesig oder Herkunft. Deswegen spielt Resistans mittlerweile auch eine große Rolle. Und dann wieder soziale Schichtung, was wir so ein bisschen von Bourdieu mitgenommen haben. Dass Menschen sich entlang von sozialen Klassen anders verhalten und gegen andere abgrenzen. Dieses Habitus-Modell auch. Das spielt mittlerweile alles in den Feminismus mit rein, weil wir festgestellt haben, dass die Mechanismen ein Stück weit immer die gleichen sind. Es hängt immer mit Stereotypen zusammen. Und es hängt immer mit Abgrenzung zusammen. Also diejenigen, die Macht haben, die sich nach unten hin abgrenzen und das auf verschiedensten Art und Weise tun.
Das heißt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, das neuere Verständnis von Feminismus, was primär geprägt war von der unmittelbaren Benachteiligung von Frauen gegenüber Männern, die sich ja nicht von der Hand weisen lässt, geht eigentlich über in eine generelle Gleichberechtigungsdiskussion? Oder ist das schon zu soft formuliert?
Eigentlich ist es nicht zu soft formuliert. Nein, nein, finde ich nicht. Ja, weil man kann es nicht aussparen.
Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen krasser rangehe und sage, okay, alles klar, wir haben so Gesellschaften und die Gesellschaften sind natürlich auch dynamische Elemente und niemand mag jeden so. Es wird immer genug und wahrscheinlich sind sogar die meisten Menschen für mich irgendwie unaustehlich, wenn ich sie alle persönlich kennen würde. Vielleicht sind es auch nicht die meisten, aber auf jeden Fall genug, als dass ich mich mit all denen beschäftigen möchte und vieles blende ich auch aus. Ausblenden ist immer sehr einfach, wenn man sich das leisten kann. Umso schlechter man dann auch gestellt ist, sind dann die Leute, die einem eben nicht passen oder sagen wir mal, die einem auch nicht wohlgesonnen sind, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, weil ich ihnen Macht wegnehme, weil ich ihnen potenziell Geld wegnehme oder weil sie mich eben aus anderen Gründen irgendwie nicht leiden können, wird das eben für mich in zunehmendem Maße ein Problem. Und dann, wenn es halt irgendwie ans liebe Geld kommt, auf die Basis meiner Überlebensexistenz und meines Wohlbefindens und auch meiner Menschenrechte, an der Stelle wird es halt irgendwie schwierig und kritisch. So, aber das ist halt nur mal der Ist-Zustand. Also wir wissen, dass diese Gesellschaft so ist. Wir können uns natürlich jetzt hier mit Gänseblümchen in die Hand hinstellen und sagen, wäre es nicht schön, wenn wir alle uns lieb hätten, und pippi und so. Ja, ist ja einfach ein Fakt, dass das jetzt kein Zuckerschlecken ist, dieses Miteinander mit so vielen Menschen auf so einem Planeten und alle kämpfen um die Ressourcen etc. Trotz alledem kann man ja auch da herangehen. Und ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck gewonnen aus der Beobachtung, aus der Ferne, ja, dieses feministischen, netzfeministischen Treibens vor allem. Also was sich quasi so im Netz so abbildet, dass man sich sehr viel mehr bemüht auch zu argumentieren, nicht nur so an dieser Kante mit, dass es ungerecht ist, muss sich ändern, sondern hey, wäre es nicht für alle besser, da mal anders ranzugehen. So und wenn du sagst, die Männer sind jetzt, haben sich nicht so mitemanzipiert, weil sie das jetzt gar nicht für notwendig erachtet hatten, so Emanzipation ist Frauensache. Das ist eigentlich auch ein schöner Dreher der ganzen Debatte. So ja, ich muss mich ja nicht emanzipieren, das müssen die Frauen machen so. Die haben da ja sozusagen was zu leisten, was irgendwie alles total auf den Kopf stellt. Und dass eigentlich so dieses Thema, sozusagen na ja, jetzt haben wir ja schon so viele Rechte eingeräumt, so ja, erst durfte der wählen, jetzt könnte er auch. Das ist jetzt mal so ein bisschen schäbig dahergesagt, aber ich denke, so kommt es einem auch teilweise entgegen, oder? Ja, was ist jetzt die Argumentation? Was sollte die Unveränderten und Nicht-Veränderungswilligen dazu bringen, sich zu verändern, wenn sie doch ja eigentlich nur Macht aufgeben sollen?
Ja, das ist in einer kapitalistischen Gesellschaft sehr schwer zu argumentieren, weil es natürlich immer auch sofort um Kohle geht. Wir wollen genauso viel verdienen wie ihr. Es ist einer der klarsten...
Heißt so viel wie, wir möchten, dass ihr weniger verdient.
Ja, das ist leider die Konsequenz davon, weil wir wollen genauso viel arbeiten wie ihr, wir wollen in unseren Jobs bitte die gleichen Fortbildungen erlangen wie ihr. Wir wollen nicht überproportional in dem scheiß Niedriglohnsektor sein, wobei natürlich die einzelnen Frauen sich das teilweise auch noch aussuchen, aufgrund verschiedenster, also nicht aussuchen, aber sich da rein gedrängt fühlen aufgrund verschiedenster Zwänge an sie. Aber das ist natürlich eine klare Ansage. Und wenn man diesen Gender-Gap, Gender-Pay-Gap thematisiert im Internet oder sonst wo, diese 23% im Unterschied des durchschnittlichen Gehalts pro Monat, der ja zwischen Männern und Frauen noch liegt, also Männer verdienen im Durchschnitt 23% mehr als Frauen, bei gleicher Qualifikation ist übrigens die Zahl. Also man betrachtet die Qualifikation und dann wie sind die Gehaltsunterschiede. Dann kommt sofort, ja aber ihr seid ja selber schuld, wenn ihr euch immer die Berufe raussucht, die so schlecht bezahlt werden. Und außerdem seid ihr ja selber schuld, weil die meisten Überstunden werden ja von Männern gemacht und nicht gerade von Frauen. Also strengt euch doch mal mehr an. Und dann seid ihr auch noch selbst schuld, weil es geht ja nicht immer um die gleiche Arbeit, sondern es geht ja um die gleiche Qualifikation. Warum macht ihr denn nicht mehr aus eurer Qualifikation? Da können wir doch nichts dafür. Und was nicht gesehen wird, ist, dass dahinter ganz viele gesellschaftliche Mechanismen stecken. Nämlich, warum wird denn Arbeit, die klassischerweise von Frauen getan wird, so viel weniger bezahlt? Warum ist der Erzieherinnenberuf weniger geldwert als die Müllabfuhr? Nur zum Beispiel, in Berlin ist es so, dass die Müllabfuhr, also wenn man bei der Müllabfuhr arbeitet, verdient man mehr Geld, als wenn man Erzieherin oder Erzieher ist.
Ich glaube sogar deutlich mehr, weil die Müllabfuhr ist jetzt ein relativ gut entlohnter Bereich.
Ja, sehr schöner Bereich. Ist ja ein typisch männlicher Bereich auch. Da würden dann wieder die Gegner sagen, werdet doch nicht Erzieherinnen, sondern macht halt Müllabfuhr. Ist doch schön, wenn auch mal Frauen den Dreck wegmachen. Die Müllabfuhr ist ein sehr beliebtes Thema von Maskulisten. Und neben der Bundeswehr, weil Männer ja auch ihr Leben lassen für uns, Frauen, ist auch noch so ein Klischee.
Das ist Quatsch, das war, es gibt ja auch Frauen in der Bundeswehr.
Ja, das sind jetzt zehn Prozent, glaube ich. Das ist so ein bisschen wie in der Wikipedia.
Na gut, aber die lassen ja auch potenziell genauso ihr Leben.
Nein, das sind Sanitäterinnen vor allem.
Weil ja, die werden auch erschossen im Krieg.
Ja, aber nicht so häufig wie die anderen. Hab ich gerade einen Artikel drüber oder werde ich demnächst einen Artikel drüber rausbringen, wenn alles gut geht, über genau das Thema, weil ich nämlich auch der Meinung bin, ja genau, also dass Frauen so wenig in der Bundeswehr vertreten sind oder in allen Armeen weltweit, in den Truppen der UNO sind 2,1 Prozent Frauen, ist eigentlich auch genauso wenig gut. Also das ist eigentlich was, was ich auch ändern will. Großer Streitpunkt innerhalb des Feminismus. Großer, großer, schlimmer, schlimmer Streitpunkt. Da hatte ich schon ganz, ganz heftige Debatten drüber und war dann für, weil ich sowas ähnliches schon mal geäußert habe im Jahr 2010, für viele dann komplett unten durch, weil ich das angesprochen habe und gesagt habe, hey Frauen, ihr müsst auch ins Militär gehen. Das ist total wichtig. Das ist ein Bereich, wo Macht ausgeübt wird. Ein ganz wesentlicher Wachtbereich in dieser Welt. Gleichzeitig wird wahnsinnig viel Verantwortung für Menschenleben übernommen. Das überlassen wir Männern. Und dann ist es ja auch so, dass in den ganzen Krisengebieten vor Ort, wo Truppen stationiert sind, was auch immer die da genau tun, es ist ja kein Krieg häufig, sondern die sind da stationiert, um irgendwie aufzupassen. Ja genau, das ist nicht eskaliert und so weiter. Werden halt viele Frauen vergewaltigt auch oder zur Prostitution gezwungen. Je mehr Frauen aber vor Ort sind auch, desto weniger passiert sowas. Also es ist ein ganz anderer Ton herrscht anscheinend auch sofort, sobald Frauen mit vor Ort sind und so weiter und so fort.
Ich meine nur vor Ort. Also ich meine überhaupt so diese Ausbildung in der Bundeswehr bedeutet immer gut. Mittlerweile ist der Zeitraum sehr überschaubar geworden. Das war ja mal sehr, sehr lang. Aber so Orte, wo nur Männer sind, sind auch nicht gut für Männer.
Eben, das ist eigentlich, Diversity ist halt generell ein Wert. Das wäre so einer meiner Grundprinzipien. Nicht, weil irgendwas dadurch besser wird. Also nicht, weil Frauen besser sind als Männer. Das ist überhaupt nicht die Argumentation, sondern weil es ein Wert ist, durchmischt zu sein und anderen Input zu bekommen und eine andere Sichtweise und die miteinander zu teilen.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie Kiefernwald und Sturm. Wenn da nur Kiefern stehen, dann kommt der Sturm und dann war's das. Und der Mischwald hält das besser aus. Ich weiß, das ist ein sehr lyrisches Argument. Ich erlebe das halt in sozialen Strukturen auch ähnlich. Weil natürlich ein zu homogener Bereich von seinen Marotten geprägt ist und dann auch sehr schnell angreifbar wird. Gerade auch in der Nerd- und Computerszene, mit der ich jetzt so groß geworden bin, ist das natürlich auch extrem männlich geprägt, in vielerlei Hinsicht. Und man merkt dann eben so tolle Karrieren und Einzelkämpfer und großartige Ideen und verrückte Sachen sich da herausbilden. Und wie anerkennenswürdig und auch spaßig das Ganze ist, gibt es dann einfach schnell auch mal so politische Diskussionen oder vor allem gesellschaftspolitische Diskussionen, wo man dann einfach merkt, da fehlt einfach die Durchmischung. Da fehlt die Erfahrung, da fehlt damit auch einhergehend eine Vernetzung mit dieser Gesellschaft, die einfach zwangsläufig dadurch eben nicht passiert, weil einfach zu wenig Themen durch Frauen hereingetragen werden, die bei Männern eben unpopulär sind. Und deswegen das schwächt dann auch so eine Szene.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich habe ja auch immer gesagt, oder immer vor einem Jahr irgendwann gesagt, Leute, Netzpolitik kann man eigentlich nicht denken und nicht machen, ohne dass man die ganze Frauenfrage und Beteiligungsfrage da mitdenkt. Also wie will man denn ernst nehmen oder ernst genommen werden als Netzpolitik, was ja eine sehr humanistische Politik ist und wo es ja darum geht, das Netz soll frei sein und alle sollen sich beteiligen können, es soll keine Einschränkungen geben. Das ist ja so ein grundhumanistischer Grundgedanke, der dieser gesamten Netzpolitik zugrunde liegt, aber Frauen werden nicht thematisiert.
Das war wieder bei den Mils, den du anfangs erwähnt hast.
Ja, also interessanterweise diese Revolution, die digitale Revolution, die wir gerade erlebt haben, also ich würde mal sagen, wir sind jetzt schon eher so in der Nachbereitungsphase des Ganzen, hat wieder ohne Frauen stattgefunden. Weitestgehend. Also es waren sicherlich einige wenige Frauen noch schon so ein bisschen daran beteiligt, aber diejenigen, die, ich sag mal, die Avantgarde dessen sind, sind dann doch wieder die Männer. Und sie denken meistens die Frauen auch nicht sonderlich mit. Also die größten Abwehrmechanismen gegen Feminismus sind mir bisher unter Nerds begegnet in der Tat. Die sind da, glaube ich, irgendwie gebrannte Kinder, warum auch immer. Ich versuche dann immer mit denen zu reden. Meistens klappt es dann auch ganz gut, dass ich für ihnen einfach zu erklären versuche, warum Feminismus noch wichtig ist. Das haben wir jetzt ja hier auch gerade schon alles ausgeführt mit Gender Pay Gap und Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten. Also Männer haben immer noch ganz andere Möglichkeiten als Frauen.
Aber was ist denn so primär als Grund dafür, dass die Digitale Revolution ohne die Frauen gelaufen ist?
Ich vermute, dass es so ein bisschen mit dem Stereotyp zu tun hat, dass Männer sich tendenziell eher zu technischen Sachen hingezogen fühlen und auch ihnen das zugeschrieben wird. Männer sind technikaffin. Und dass bei Frauen und Mädchen sehr lange Zeit noch bis in dieses Jahrtausend hinein gesagt wurde, die können das nicht so. Und Jungs auch eher, ich meine, du bist ja auch ein Beispiel davon, dass sie ein Kind von Computer hatten und in diesen einfach irgendwie rumgebastelt und programmiert haben, wie sie gerade lustig waren.
Ich wollte auch einfach einen haben. Ich habe ihn mir dann auch organisiert und habe mich nicht beirren lassen und habe nicht darauf gewartet, dass mir jetzt einer einen schenkt.
Aber wie bist du auf die Idee gekommen? Du hattest ja schon irgendwie als dieses Kind, dass du warst, eine Prägung, dass du dir gesagt hast, ich muss das Ding haben.
Ich weiß ganz genau, was der ursprüngliche Auslöser waren. Das bestätige ich vielleicht auch das eine oder andere, was du schon gesagt hast. Ich kann jetzt nicht wirklich verlässlich, vollständig alles damit erklären, was in mir war. Ich hatte ohnehin immer schon einen Hang zum Logischen. Ich habe mich irgendwann in einem Schachclub wiedergefunden, hatte eigentlich an Schach gar kein Interesse. Ich merkte dann irgendwann, dass ich deshalb da war, weil Leute waren, die logische Schritte durchdachten. Das fand ich irgendwie sexy. Schach hat mich an dich überhaupt nicht interessiert. Aber ich befand mich auf einmal unter Leuten, die sozusagen das Denken geil fanden. Noch viel früher als junger Mensch, der im britischen Pass groß geworden ist, was dann auch immer ein bisschen so ein, wie soll ich sagen, ein Gedankenanker ist, wo man denkt, was bin ich denn eigentlich? Unter anderem bin ich ja auch das. Ich habe dann irgendwann im Fernsehen jemanden gesehen, einen Mann, der halt als Britte und Programmierer vorgestellt wurde. Und dann weiß ich noch, wie ich da saß und dachte mir so, okay, alles klar. Ein Britte Programmierer, genau. Es war sicherlich nur ein Auslöser, keine Ahnung, inwiefern das dann wirklich das Ding war. Sicherlich an Vorbildern mangelte es nicht.
Und wie viele weibliche Vorbilder hättest du damals gekannt?
Ja, keine wahrscheinlich. Wobei die Informatik ja durchaus ein paar auch hervorgebracht hat, die dann natürlich dann auch immer wieder schnell durchgefeiert werden, wenn man das Thema dann aufbringt. Aber es ist natürlich schon klar, dass diese Computer-Internetszene besonders einfach sehr frauenarm war. Ich meine, ich hab das immer beklagt und fand das auch nicht toll, weil wer findet es schon toll, wenn das potenziell interessante Geschlecht auf einmal überhaupt nicht vertreten ist in dem, was man sich bemüht. Man nimmt es dann aber trotzdem in Kauf, weil es ja so interessant ist. Gut, es gibt auch viele Gegenbeispiele, wo ich auch immer wieder schnell gesehen habe, es gibt auch überhaupt keine Notwendigkeit, warum es so ist. Es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund. Ein paar der pfiffigsten Hackerinnen, die stehen jetzt in Gedanken, Blitzhumor, Finesse und technischen Fähigkeiten. Den Männern da auch wirklich in nichts nach. Ganz im Gegenteil, sie sind auch innerhalb der Szene eigene Rollmodels, weil sie das Ding, was sie da machen, so gut machen, wie es halt viele andere eben einfach auch nicht können. Trotzdem ist es so. Nun hat die digitale Revolution da wieder die ZJ Brins und so weiter hervorgebracht, die ganzen Männer, die halt die Firmen gegründet haben, die Steve Jobs und so weiter. Gut, ist so.
Ja, es ist generell noch ein Problem, dass in der Phase der Gesellschaft sicherlich auch Gründerinnen selten waren. Also Geschäftsfrauen sind immer schon die gewesen, die hervorgestochen sind. Also wenn sie wirklich Unternehmen geleitet haben oder Unternehmen gegründet haben, waren immer schon Ausnahmen. Also wirklich, das zieht sich noch sehr, sehr lange durch. Ist nicht so das, was Frauen typischerweise tun, sondern Frauen sind in Unternehmen ja eher die Angestellten, die Ausführenden. Und die Männer sind halt die, die es gründen, die es leiten, die die Vision haben. Ist wieder so ein Machtding einfach. Oder Wettkampfding vielleicht auch. Ich mein, wer etwas gründet, muss sich ja auch behaupten erst mal. Ich kann nicht ein Geschäft gründen und dann nicht den Ehrgeiz haben, dieses Geschäft wirklich gegen alle Wiedrigkeiten durchzusetzen, aufzuziehen. Und das ist ein Wettkampf, eine Wettkampffrage. Und wir hatten ja vorhin schon diese Studie zur Wettkampf. Frauen lieben Wettkampf jetzt nicht gerade.
Ist das vielleicht der entscheidende Faktor?
Das ist sicherlich einer der Faktoren. Ich weiß nicht, welcher der entscheidende ist. Es ist mit den Stereotypen, dass Frauen die Technik jetzt nicht so lieben. Und deswegen nicht immer am Anfang des Internets war das Internet ja noch, oder war nicht nur das Internet, aber mit Computern und allem Drum und Dran, war ja eine sehr technische Sache. Dass man so Clicky-Bunti hatte wie heute, wo das dann für jeden zugänglich ist, ist ja nicht von Anfang an so gewesen. Sondern das kam ja erst im Laufe der Zeit. Und Clicky-Bunti und leichte Interfaces, die irgendwie einfach zur Hand haben sind, wo man kein technisches Know-how für haben muss, werden von Frauen ja sehr gerne genommen. Wenn man allerdings zum Beispiel so etwas wie Wikipedia hat und man muss dann diese Syntax anwenden, ist es für Frauen schon vielleicht wieder ein bisschen abschreckender als für Männer. Also das teilt sich irgendwie so da entlang. Und es wird Männern ja bis heute auch zugeschrieben, dass sie die sein, die logischer denken, die mehr mit Mathematik befreundet sind, denen das natürlicherweise mehr liegt. Halt dich alles für Quatsch. Aber wenn du in diesem Glauben groß wirst als Mädchen und man dir sagt, weil du ein Mädchen bist, bist du schlechter in Mathe, dann bist du schlechter in Mathe. Das haben Neurobiologen untersucht, haben vier verschiedene Arten von Texten Mädchen und Jungen, oder nee, nur Mädchen zu lesen gegeben. In einem Text stand quasi irgendwie so pseudo-wissenschaftlicher Text, Mädchen sind schlechter in Mathe, weil die Gene und so. Im nächsten Text stand Mädchen sind genauso gut in Mathe wie Jungen. In einem anderen Mädchen sind in Mathe besser als Jungen, weil die Gene und so weiter. Und je nachdem, welchen Text diese Mädchen gelesen hatten, hat man sie dann hinterher die gleichen Matheaufgaben lösen lassen. Und der Einfluss des Textes auf den Erfolg in den Matheaufgaben war hochsignifikant. Also das, was ich über mich selber glaube, aufgrund etwas, was man mir sagt, und was man sagt, das ist wissenschaftlich erwiesen, bin ich hinterher gut oder schlecht in dem?
Also meinst du, es ist nahezu ausschließlich Prägung?
Ja, und das, was ich über mich selber glaube.
Ich meine, du sagst nun mehrfach, Wettbewerb ist bei Frauen nicht so angesagt.
Ja, und jede Frau, was bei mir auch nicht. Also ich gehe mal wieder zurück zu mir.
Ja, weil man dir gesagt hat, Wettbewerb ist nichts für Mädchen?
Weil man, glaube ich, tendenziell negatives Feedback gibt an Mädchen, wenn sie in einem Wettbewerb treten. Also es wird tendenziell sanktioniert. Also wenn Frauen in Unternehmen, ich sag mal, sehr stark männlich auftreten, also sich so ein bisschen wie so ein Platzhirsch oder eine Platzhirschin verhalten, dann wird ihnen das wesentlich negativer ausgelegt, als wenn Männer das tun. Dann sind sie das Mannvibe, also allein, dass es dieses Wort schon gibt, spricht sehr stark dafür. Und sie sind dann schnell ausgegrenzt. Und auch da, ich fresse ja immer eine möglichen Studien, auch da gibt es Studien zu, die geschaut haben, wenn Männer sich wie Frauen verhalten, also wenn Männer diese Soft-Skills, die man Frauen ja stärker nachsagt, sich aneignen und so handeln, dann wird das honoriert. Dann finden das alle toll und applaudieren, und jeher endlich mal ein Mann, der auch nicht nur so durchsetzungsfähig und hart ist, sondern der auch emotional Intelligenz mitbringt und der kommunizieren kann. Toll, super. Wenn Frauen aber zu ihrem Report waren, was sie vielleicht als Kind mal gelernt haben, noch hinzufügen, durchsetzungsfähig zu sein und stärker in den Wettbewerb einzusteigen, dann wird das sowohl für Männern als auch Frauen als negativ ausgelegt. Und dann entstehen so Begriffe wie eben Mann-Vibe, aber auch Stutenbissigkeit ist auch so ein sehr bezeichnender Begriff. Ja, aber wenn Frauen, Frauen sind doch so stutenbissig. Wenn Frauen Konflikt miteinander haben.
Bezieht sich der Begriff nicht mehr auf den Umgang von Frauen untereinander?
Untereinander, ja, aber das ist ja leider logische Konsequenz.
Das man versteht, von Hengstbissigkeit ist nicht die Rede.
Nein, nein, das sind dann die, das gibt es überhaupt nicht, das wird überhaupt nicht problematisiert, wenn Männer, ja, ja, Udelkämpfe, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, auch bei Männern halt so um die Vorherrschaft etc.
Harnkämpfe.
Ich meine, diese Vergleiche mit der Tierwelt und Biologie liegen ja immer auf der Hand so, also zumindest gehen sie vielen in den Debatten leicht von der Zunge.
Das ist sehr nervig, das ist wirklich sehr schwierig. Also der Biologismus ist auch einer der schärfsten Gegner, würde ich mal sagen, die der neue Feminismus hat, weil das gerade auch aus Amerika sehr stark betrieben wird von Biologen und immer wieder neu beweisen zu wollen, was die Unterschiede zwischen Männern und Frauen sind. Das wird dann meistens mit Hormonstudien, also wo irgendwelche Hormonsachen untersucht werden und daraus resultierendes Verhalten untermauert. Man hat herausgefunden, dass wenn junge Mädchen auf die Welt kommen, dass die Gehirne schon unterschiedlich sind. Dass das vermutlich daran liegt, dass sie im Mutterleib bereits in verschiedensten Hormonen baden. Also die Jungs baden dann eine Zeit lang richtig im Testosteron, damit sich die sekundären Geschlechtsmeidmale rausbilden können. Und das hat eine Auswirkung wohl auf das Gehirn. Und das ist wohl mittlerweile auch ziemlich erwiesen, dass Jungen und Mädchen unterschiedlich auf die Welt kommen. Und dann gibt es halt diejenigen, die sagen, ja, das ist doch der Beweis. Also ist doch klar, wenn die schon unterschiedlich auf die Welt kommen, dass das dann nie wieder gleich werden kann. Und dann gibt es aber auch die Neurobiologen, das sind dann eher die leiseren Töne, die halt sagen, naja, wenn Jungs anders auf die Welt kommen, da gibt es verschiedenste Beschreibungen, was das bedeutet. Also Jungs haben zum Beispiel häufiger Koliken und sind häufiger Schreikinder, als es Mädchen sind. Dann brauchen sie eigentlich viel mehr Sicherheit, viel mehr Liebe. Man muss sich tatsächlich mehr um einen kleinen Jungen kümmern als Baby, als um ein kleines Mädchen. Mädchen sind schon stabiler, auf irgendwie eine Art und Weise. Aber es ist wichtig, dass Jungs dieses quasi Defizit, mit dem sie auf die Welt kommen, dass man ihnen die Möglichkeit gibt, das aufzuholen einfach. Und diese Möglichkeit gibt es auch. Also das Gehirn entwickelt sich irgendwann nicht mehr aus den Genen heraus, denen es unterliegt. Also die Anlagen sind weniger in den Genen, als viel mehr in der Umwelt. Und die Umwelt ist das, was ein Jung...
Das Lernen bringt uns voran.
Ja, das Lernen macht das aus uns, was wir sind.
Auch wenn Leute nicht lernen und irgendwie dumm gehalten werden, dann sieht man es ihnen irgendwann auch im Gesicht an.
Ja, genau. Use it or lose it heißt das bei den Neurobiologen. Also benutze eine Nervenbahn oder sie geht dir verloren. Und so wie du deinen Gehirn benutzt, so wirst du auch. Und das ist halt ein ganz zentraler Punkt für mich auch. Also ich habe ja drei Jahre in der Biologie studiert, deswegen kenne ich mich da auch einigermaßen aus.
Richtet sich dann der Feminismus, soweit er eben auch wirklich die Frauen betrifft, nicht vor allem dann auch an die Frauen? Dass man sozusagen sagen muss, ihr müsst die Angst vom Wettbewerb verlieren oder? Ist es eher notwendig, wenn nicht den Männern einzutrichten, dass sie nicht so viel Wert auf Wettbewerb legen sollen?
Das ist beides zu vereinfacht. Also an mir selber habe ich gemerkt, dass ich auch eher Wettbewerb gescheut habe, bis ich bei der Grünen Jugend dann mal war und festgestellt habe, dass Wettbewerb auch Spaß macht. Beziehungsweise, na, es war nicht nur die Grüne Jugend. Du hast gerade den Schachclub erwähnt. Ich war auch mal im Schachclub und eine meiner Lieblingsdisziplinen war Blitzschach. Ich bin dann tatsächlich auch in so Meisterschaften, so kleinere Schachmeisterschaften mitgezogen und habe dann nicht sehr erfolgreich Blitzschach gespielt, aber ich habe es einfach geliebt überhaupt gegen verschiedenste Leute, diese Nervenkitzel beim Blitzschach.
Ich habe es gehasst.
Ja, weil da geht es ja auch nicht so sehr um die Logik, sondern eher so um diese Nervenkitzel, wahrscheinlich, weiß ich nicht.
Das ist konkret der Wettbewerb, weil mir ehrlich gesagt an der Stelle egal.
Ja, man muss halt schnell sein. Nicht nur gut, sondern schnell. Beides gleichzeitig. Das habe ich immer schon mitgekriegt.
Man muss auch etwas verlieren können. Ich glaube, das ist das Entscheidende. Ich messe mich gerne, aber die Qualität dessen liegt auch immer darin, wie sehr man in der Lage ist, verlieren zu können.
Beim Blitzschach muss man verlieren können, weil es ja so schnell ist, dass man nicht immer die beste Entscheidung trifft.
Ja, das ist auch so digital. Entweder man hat ganz klar gewonnen oder man hat ganz klar verloren.
Es gibt das Remi. Ja, es gibt das Remi.
Aber wenn man verloren hat, hat man immer so richtig verloren. Es gibt nicht so ein bisschen verlieren oder so.
Ich habe irgendwann gelernt, dass es Spaß macht, Wettbewerb zu machen. Also in einem Wettbewerb mitzumachen, den man sich aber selber ausgesucht hat. Das ist genau der Unterschied. Ich kann nicht hergehen und sagen, Frauen, jetzt geht doch mal dahin und macht das mal. Ihr werdet schon sehen, ihr werdet das genauso gut machen und so weiter. Feminismus ist immer auch Selbstbestimmung. Das ist leider das Paradox des Feminismus. Es verbietet sich mir als Feministin, und zwar auch wirklich von Herzen, Frauen Vorschriften machen zu wollen, was sie zu tun oder zu lassen haben. Wirklich. Also das könnte ich nicht. Und genauso auch Männern. Ich finde es immer ein bisschen übergriffig, herzugehen und zu sagen, ihr macht das und das falsch. Ihr müsst euch jetzt sofort anders verhalten. Sondern was ich halt mache, und wie ich auch an die Sache rangehe, ist zu versuchen, die Möglichkeiten aufzuzeigen. Also ich rede über die Möglichkeiten und über die Freiheiten, die man auch gewinnen kann, wenn man Dinge anders macht. Wenn man Dinge einfach durchbricht. Also es ist einer meiner liebsten Disziplinen, das Durchbrechen von Stereotypen. Seit ich so 14 bin auch.
Also ich meine, die Möglichkeiten, die sich jetzt für Frauen abzeichnen, sind ja relativ klar. Es ist sozusagen die Teilhabe an etwas, was derzeit noch schwer zu erreichen ist. Aber was haben denn die Männer davon?
Die Männer haben davon, dass sie sich einen gesellschaftlichen Bereich auftun und erobern können, miterobern können, teilhaben können, von dem sie bisher, weitestgehend, auch ausgeschlossen sind. Das klingt jetzt abstrus, das ist aber so.
Wovon sind denn die Männer ausgeschlossen?
Von der Teilhabe an allem, was irgendwie sozial ist. Also sie sind nicht per se davon ausgeschlossen, aber es wird ihnen genau so schwerer gemacht, wie es Frauen schwerer gemacht wird, in der Ökonomie zum Beispiel teilzuhaben. Bereich soziale Beziehungen. Oder auch tendenziell werden Jungs schon eher darauf trainiert, von ihren Eltern nicht zu weinen. Gefühle nicht zu laut oder zu sehr zu äußern, sondern zu unterdrücken und stark sein zu müssen. Also dieser Zugang... Ja, Indianer weinen nicht, ist ja so ein klassischer Spruch. Dieser Zugang zu den eigenen Gefühlen... Dieser Zugang zu den eigenen Gefühlen ist, glaube ich, ein sehr großer Gewinn den Männern, der Männern winkt. Wobei sie natürlich erst mal den sofortigen Nutzen nicht sehen. Was bringt es ihnen, wenn sie heulen können? Aber ich glaube schon, dass diese höhere... Ja, diese höhere Tendenz zu Herzinfarkten oder auch, dass Männer, wenn sie arbeitslos werden, viel stärker als Frauen, wenn sie arbeitslos werden, in eine völlige Sinnkrise geraten. Sich auch häufiger umbringen dann oder verkümmern. Weil Arbeit ist ihr Ding. Sie kennen in ihrem Leben Erfüllung vor allem durch Arbeit. Aber durch nichts anderes. Sie haben weniger soziale Kontakte. Kann man zum Beispiel daran messen, wer kauft in einer Beziehung Geschenke, wenn man zum Geburtstag eingeladen ist, und wer verpackt sie? Wer kümmert sich also sozusagen wirklich aktiv um das Pflegen von sozialen Kontakten? Meistens sind es die Frauen, also jetzt in heterosexuellen Beziehungen. Und das zweite große Ding natürlich, Familie, Kinder. Wer ist verantwortlich, wer ist hauptverantwortlich für Kinder? Es sind immer noch Frauen, die angesprochen werden. Ich hatte eine relativ lange Debatte mit einem Mann auf freitag.de, der unter meiner Kolumne ziemlich oft auch kommentiert hat, der selber Alleinerziehender Vater war. Also die Kinder sind jetzt wohl auch schon mehrheitlich aus dem Haus. Der nach der Trennung von seiner Frau das genau umgekehrte Modell gefahren hat mit ihr als Mann zu kennt. Also sie hat die Kinder weniger gehabt und seltener und weniger die Verantwortung auch für die Kinder gehabt als er. Er war so der Hauptverantwortliche für die Kinder. Wurde aber von den anderen Frauen nie als solche akzeptiert. Zum Beispiel in der Schule. Können Sie bitte Ihrer Frau sagen, dass so und so? Warum sollte er das seiner Frau sagen? Er war ja der, der die Verantwortung hatte. Aber er wurde nicht als solcher angesprochen. Er wurde nicht als solcher wahrgenommen. Er war auch weniger vernetzt. Mütter sind meistens ziemlich gut vernetzt untereinander. Und tauschen sich auf den Spielplätzen ja alleine schon ständig irgendwie aus.
Ja, die Spielplatz-Mafia, da kann ich dir sagen, dass es irgendwie gar nicht so einfach da reinzukommen als Mann.
Siehst du?
Da sitzt er dann irgendwie dabei und die anderen schauen dann so ein bisschen so, hm, jetzt können wir ja gar nicht richtig reden, so. Und dann hat man schon auch ein bisschen das Gefühl, so in so eine Geheimgesellschaft einzubrechen, so.
Genau. Und das ist... Ja, das ist eine Realität. Also ich sehe es auch an meinem Vater, meiner Kinder. Der ist mit den Müttern aus der Kita oder mit den Eltern nicht so gut vernetzt und weil das Pflegen der Sozialkontakte zu anderen Eltern, auch bei uns in der Kita, sehr stark noch eine Sache der Mütter ist. Die tauschen sich aus, die sind vernetzt, die kennen sich, die haben die Nummern voneinander, treffen sich auf dem Spielplatz, reden ganz viel miteinander. Und die Väter sind alle so eher Randfiguren in dieser ganzen Konstellation. Das ist was, was Männer sich definitiv noch erobern könnten. Ist aber nicht so einfach. Es ist richtig, richtig schwer. Ich sehe es ja auch an den Müttern, die ich so kenne. Die sind eigentlich, die arbeiten auch alle. Und die sind auch so sehr sympathische Menschen. Aber so die ganz kleinen Verhaltensstereotype, so fast nicht merklich. Aber die Kochen, die sind meistens diejenigen, die überdurchschnittlich häufig die Kinder aus der Kita auch abholen, weil sie meistens weniger arbeiten als die Väter. Und sie sind dafür zuständig, sowas wie die U-Untersuchungen beim Kinderarzt wahrzunehmen oder sowas. Es sind schon sehr viele Mehrverantwortungen immer noch. Und sie sehen in meinen Augen auch häufig nicht danach aus, als ob sie diese Sachen abgeben wollen würden. Also es ist natürlich auch Macht. Das ist in diesem Bereich eine große, große Macht bei Müttern, die sie sehr schwer in der Lage sind abzugeben.
Also eigentlich ist die Geschichte, die hinter dem Begriff Feminismus steht, eigentlich das Auflösen von etablierten Rollenbildern zugunsten einer gleicheren Verteilung der Teilhabe an allem. Im Idealfall zugunsten aller.
Ja, der Gewinn ist, glaube ich, wirklich riesig groß. Also die Freiheiten, das ist immer das, was ich meine. Im Moment findet eine sehr große Freiheitseinschränkung statt. Also jeder Vater, der sagt, ich möchte aber auch aktiv Vater sein, ist fast schon dazu gezwungen, sich andere Väter zu suchen, die das auch tun, damit das funktioniert. Also sie brauchen ja auch Elternnetzwerke, sind schon wichtig in der Kindererziehung. Und das ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig. Also zwischen den Geschlechtern passiert das noch sehr wenig. Also ich selber habe schon auch häufig zu beiden Elternteilen ungefähr den gleich guten Kontakt. Ich habe auch am liebsten, bin ich auch mit Eltern befreundet, wo das egal ist, wo das keine große Rolle spielt. Also so ein bisschen bin ich, glaube ich, auch eine Außenseiterin in den typischen Elternzirkeln. Weil ich da halt auch nicht so ticke oder so funktioniere und mir das tendenziell fremd ist.
Das ist auch noch mal so ein Begriff auf Rollen, den wir vorhin schon mal angesprochen hatten, der in dieser ganzen Debatte auch immer wieder eine große Rolle spielt. Vielleicht auch zu unrecht vermischt wird, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau. Sexismus, das ist schon erwähnt so. Wie definierst du das? Was steckt für dich in diesem Wort?
Dass ich einen Menschen oder eine Praxis aufgrund dessen, dass es einem bestimmten Geschlecht zugeordnet ist oder dass dieser Menschen ein bestimmtes Geschlecht hat, abwerte. Also Sexismus ist für mich, wenn das, was Frauen tun, abgewertet wird, aber auch das, was Männer tun, abgewertet wird. Weil sie Männer sind oder weil sie Frauen sind. Oder dass sie als Menschen abgewertet werden, weil sie Männer sind oder weil sie Frauen sind. Ein Beispiel dafür, das hatte ich vorhin auch schon genannt, dass Frauenberufe weniger bezahlt werden, ist für mich eine sexistische Arbeitswelt. Dass auf der anderen Seite Männern weniger zugetraut wird, sich um ein Baby zu kümmern als Frauen, ist für mich sexistisch im Bereich Familie. Es ist für mich auch eine sexistische Herangehensweise. Anderes Beispiel ist, wenn Frauen zum Beispiel in Werbung oder in verschiedensten Unterhaltungsshows nichts anderes sind als Dekoration. Also wenn ich vielleicht Werbung für eine Fluglinie mache und setze daneben den nackten Hintern von einer Frau oder überhaupt den Hintern von einer Frau oder irgendwie Brüste, ganz beliebte auch Brüste zu banken, wo das überhaupt nichts damit zu tun hat. Ich finde, Brüste sind okay, wenn man für BHs Werbung macht, aber halt nicht, wenn man für ein Girokonto wirbt. Dann ist das für mich auch sexistisch, weil dann die Frau degradiert wird, einfach nur, weil sie Frau ist zu einem Sexobjekt. Aber warum ist das... Also das macht man ja tatsächlich fast nur mit Frauen. Zunehmend gibt es das auch mit Männern, aber weniger. Und Sexismus findet auch teilweise in den gesellschaftlichen Strukturen statt. Also in den Institutionen werden Menschen teilweise sexistisch behandelt. Da fällt mir jetzt wieder ein Beispiel für die Männerseite ein, wo Familiengerichte ganz häufig ohne Ansehen der restlichen Situation einfach entscheiden, nach der Scheidung das Sorgerecht kriegt die Frau und nicht der Mann. Und der Vater meines Kindes ist Anwärt für Familienrecht, der eben sehr viele Scheidungen betreut hat. Und der meinte, sehr häufig spielte der Rest gar keine Rolle, sondern es war einfach nur, das Kind gehört zur Mutter. Und wenn der Vater darum kämpfen wollte, dass das Kind vielleicht bei ihm lebt, weil es ihm da vielleicht besser geht, hat er von vornherein viel schlechtere Karten.
Das war, glaube ich, auch bis vor kurzem auch rechtlich sogar so ausgerichtet.
Ja, da hat der Europäische Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte sozusagen die deutsche Politik erst mal gezwungen, dieses Sorgerecht nicht qua Geburt automatisch nur der Mutter zuzuschreiben. Also bisher ist es ja immer noch so, das wurde ja, glaube ich, noch gar nicht geändert, dass wenn ein Kind geboren wird und das ist nicht ehelich, also in der Ehe ist ja klar, da haben automatisch beide das Sorgerecht, aber wenn es ein uneheliches Kind ist, dann hat der Vater, wenn die Mutter das nicht will, keine Chance, das Sorgerecht zu kriegen. Wenn die Mutter sagt Nö, dann hat er keine Chance. Also es muss mit bisher im Einverständnis der Mutter geschehen und da hat der Europäische Gerichtshof von Menschenrechte gesagt, das kann nicht sein. Da muss es eine andere Regelung geben. Und da wird gerade noch dran gebastelt. Und das ist in meinen Augen natürlich auch sexistisch, klar.
In der Debatte um Feminismus im Netz ist ja Sexismus auch so ein bisschen zum Kampfbegriff in einigen Bereichen angeschwollen. Habe ich so den Eindruck, ja, die sexistische Kackscheiße wird ausgerufen auf der einen Seite, erzeugt dann im Gegenzug auch schnell wieder andere heftige Gegenreaktionen von, was schon erwähnt, so Maskulinisten oder anderen Menschen.
Naja, was der Henne und Ei ist, weiß man oft nicht. Also ob das jetzt wirklich eine Gegenreaktion ist oder ob die sexistische Kackscheiße zu rufen nicht schon die Gegenreaktion auf etwas anderes ist.
Ja, ich wollte da jetzt gar keine Reihenfolge postulieren. Ich beobachte nur, dass da einfach eine Menge Reibungsenergie erzeugt wird, die vielleicht teilweise auch schon besser in andere Wandelungsprozesse umgewandelt werden würde. Aber wie bewertest du das? Wie muss man das bewerten? Wo ist da jetzt sozusagen ein Krieg im Gange? Wo berechtigte Schutzgefechte ausgeführt werden? Wo sind da sozusagen Schutzbereiche erforderlich? Oder wo dreht sich da einfach nur eine Szene selber im Kreis?
Du hast jetzt schon sehr viele Suggestivfragen gestellt, lieber Tim. Naja, das ist ja deine Außenwahrnehmung. Ich sehe das ja ähnlich. Ich bin ja da auch so ein bisschen nicht isoliert, aber ich stehe ja schon so ein bisschen dafür, dass ich genau dieses Kackscheiße sage ich sehr selten. Also das ist für mich ein Begriff, den ich als... Es ist eigentlich ein Angriff. Und nicht, dass ich dagegen wäre, Leute anzugreifen, aber ich mache das ungern mit Buzzwords. Also ich benutze ungern mit Buzzwords dafür, jemanden einfach nur zu diskreditieren. Weil das geht ja damit recht schnell. Ich benutze dieses Buzzword, sexistische Kackscheiße, und muss dann gar nicht mehr viel sagen, aber der Mensch ist schon mal völlig in Frage gestellt und angegriffen. Und ich muss das dann auch vielleicht nicht weiter begründen. Sondern was ich versuche, ist halt schon die Dinge dann etwas detaillierter auszuformulieren. Also warum stört mich jetzt zum Beispiel an etwas? Oder warum stört mich vielleicht die Äußerung von jemand? Oder warum stört mich das Verhalten von irgendeiner Person? Dann versuche ich das zu erklären, was hat diese Person getan? Und ich versuche es aber nicht gleich mit diesem Urteil. Also nicht erst das Urteil und dann die Rechtfertigung, falls jemals eine kommt, sondern erst mal, hallo, du hast das und das getan, ich finde das nicht gut. Weil ich glaube, bei mir ist so ein bisschen die Sonderstellung, dass ich Pädagogik studiert habe. Also ich bin Erziehungswissenschaftlerin. Und ich arbeite gleichzeitig auch in meiner Kolumne nicht nur zum Thema Feminismus, sondern auch immer zum Thema Bildung. Beim freitag.de. Da schreibe ich alle zwei Wochen eine Kolumne. Meistens oder häufiger zum Thema Geschlechterdemokratie als zum Thema Bildung. Aber ich schreibe auch sehr viel zum Thema Bildung, weil es mir eigentlich fast noch wichtiger ist. Und ich gehe Feminismus an, als ich mal geschrieben habe, Feminismus ist Bildung. Also für mich ist der Prozess zu versuchen, Menschen mitzunehmen in diesem Feminismus-Ding einen Bildungsauftrag ein Stück weit. Und da bin ich halt sehr stark geprägt durch die ganze Debatte über den Umgang mit Kindern. Und für mich ist der Umgang mit Kindern und der Umgang mit anderen Menschen nicht so was grundsätzlich anderes, sondern für mich sind eigentlich alle Menschen potenziell ein Stück weit noch Kinder, weil sie in irgendeinem Bereich vielleicht noch nicht so gebildet sind. Und im Feminismus ist das ja der Fall, da sind ganz viele noch nicht so gebildet.
Erkenntnismangel.
Ja, Erkenntnismangel. Manchmal einfach Unwissen oder auch Bequemlichkeit spielt eine sehr, sehr große Rolle. Und deswegen habe ich eine andere Herangehensweise.
Du meinst auch, nicht alles, was gleich nach einem Machtkampf aussieht, ist auch wirklich einer?
Nee, das gar nicht. Also ich glaube schon eine Macht, wenn irgendwo Macht ausgeübt wird und ein Machtbereich verteidigt wird und man da auch kämpfen möchte um diesen Machtbereich, also auch einen Machtkampf kämpfen möchte, dann sollte man das auch tun. Da bin ich ganz klar, auch politische Machtkämpfe sollte man kämpfen. Und Feminismus ist mit politischen Machtkämpfen häufig verbunden. Die Frage ist eher die Wahl der Mitte. Und ich glaube, für mich ist das Mittel immer der Respekt gegenüber der Person, gegen die ich gerade kämpfe. Also Respekt ist für mich eigentlich so ein Universalinstrument oder so eine Universalhaltung, mit der ich an alles und jeden rangehe, auch an alle Menschen, die ich kritisiere. Zum Beispiel Christina Schröder. Ich habe mal einen relativ langen Text über Christina Schröder geschrieben, über ihre gesamte Herangehensweise, an die Fragen von Gerechtigkeit und Gleichheit und versucht dann auch zu analysieren, wie kommt sie dann zu ihren ganzen Ideen über Emanzipation? Also wir reden von unserer aktuellen Familienministerin. Ich habe dazu halt ihre Doktorarbeit gelesen. Und das ist für mich ein Ausdruck von Respekt. Also ich gehe nicht her und sage, die Frau ist dumm, weil die sagt dumme Sachen, sondern Respekt bedeutet für mich auch hinzugehen, zu sagen, okay, warum denkt sie so, wie sie denkt? Ich versuche also nachzuvollziehen, wie bildet sich bei anderen Menschen eine Meinung eigentlich aus? Das ist so eine sehr pragmatische Rangehensweise, auch die halt guckt, es gibt eine Praxis, was ist die Theorie, die dahinter steht? Ich versuche das zu analysieren. Ich nehme das auch ernst. Also ich nehme diese Person in dem Moment ja auch komplett ernst und urteile nicht zuerst, sondern nachdem ich die Person ernst genommen habe und mich mit ihr auseinandergesetzt habe, kann ich sagen, okay, und aufgrund dessen glaube ich das. Und das kommt wirklich, glaube ich, daher, dass ich so grundlegende Paradigmen der Pädagogik gefressen habe. Wahrscheinlich aufgrund meines Studiums, vielleicht aber auch habe ich das sowieso nur studiert, weil ich das vorher schon hatte.
Das ist die Frage, ob jetzt jeder in der Lage ist, sich auch immer so tief einzulesen, bevor ich mich mit so einer Politik beäußere, die Diplomarbeit zu lesen, die er dann vielleicht am Ende noch nicht mal selber geschrieben hat.
Naja, ich habe ja dafür Geld bekommen. Ich bin ja Journalistin, ich bekomme dafür Geld, wenn ich sowas mache.
Das ist ja nicht jedermanns Ding, immer so tief einzusteigen. Deswegen das Gefühl, verglühen sich halt einige dann eben auch in so einem Kampf, weil sie natürlich das Anliegen ganz klar sehen. Also sie das eben voranbringen wollen, und dann eben so tumbes Auftreten. Ja, vielleicht nicht tump, aber zumindest versuchen, mit einer Warnschuss-Mentalität zu begegnen. In der Hoffnung, damit Verhaltensänderungen hervorzurufen, was vielleicht durchaus auch funktionieren kann. Ich höre bloß immer wieder, und in Teilen habe ich es selber auch schon so entdeckt, dass gerade wenn es um das Thema Feminismus geht, oder eben auch Sexismus im Besonderen, dass dann eben auch gerade so die Netzdiskussion dann immer eine besondere Schärfe gibt.
Ja, das ist ja generell bei Netzdiskussionen leider ein bisschen so. Also das ist für mich so ein Phänomen von Hypes, die es im Netz ganz schnell gibt, wo auch manchmal schneller geschrieben wird, gerade auf Twitter und dann verkürzt auch noch in 140 Zeichen. Ich meine, Twitter ist zum Beispiel ein Dienst, der dazu ermuntert, sich möglichst viele Basswörter einfallen zu lassen. Also Wörter, die in einem, die symbolisch stehen für ganz viel. Ich habe mich ja immer mit Triggerwarnung auseinandergesetzt. Also zum Beispiel Triggerwarnung wäre jetzt zum Beispiel. Triggerwarnung ist für mich halt, Triggerwarnung ist in erster Linie sind Triggerwarnungen dazu da, Menschen davor zu bewahren, wenn sie traumatisiert sind. Also wenn sie irgendwie posttraumatisches Belastungssyndrom haben, weil sie in ihrer Geschichte irgendwas hatten, was sie wahnsinnig traumatisiert hat. Dass dieses Trauma nicht wieder wachgerufen wird durch Bilder oder durch Schilderungen von Situationen oder Busswords. Ja, nicht unbedingt Busswords, aber vor allem Bilder und Schilderungen von Gewaltsituationen oder von solchen Sachen.
Und die Triggerwarnung ist sozusagen, dass man jetzt ankündigt, dass man jetzt unter Umständen gleich etwas schildert, was solche Reaktionen auslösen könnte.
Die Triggerwarnung entstand in Foren im Internet, in denen sich Menschen, die traumatisiert sind, untereinander ausgetauscht haben. Und natürlich, wenn man sich austauscht über die eigene Traumatisierung und über das eigene Schicksal, kommt es hervor, dass man darüber berichten muss. Das Dilemma ist, dass wenn man darüber berichtet und andere, die das vielleicht lesen, in denen wird es dann erst nur, weil sie das Lesen wahrgerufen. Also hat man sich halt als Konvention geeinigt, man könnigt es an, dass man jetzt darüber erzählt, was einem da passiert ist. Und indem man das ankündigt, ermöglicht man es anderen zu sagen, okay, das lese ich jetzt nicht. Also Triggerwarnung bedeutet dann in dem Bereich, ich lese jetzt hier nicht weiter, weil sonst geht es mir hinterher drei Tage schlecht. Genau, und das ist ja auch extrem sinnvoll in dem Bereich. Es ist dann halt, glaube ich, gewandert ein Stück weit in Diskurse, gerade im feministischen Bereich auch, wo es dann Triggerwarnungen für sexistische Inhalte gab, Triggerwarnungen für rassistische Inhalte, also für Dinge, die teilweise, es gab eine Triggerwarnung für meinen Blog, weil Leute da auf eine Nicht-PC-Art und Weise teilweise kommentiert haben. Aber es war nie, in meinem Blog gibt es keine Kommentare, die dazu führen können, dass jemand in psychische, in einen Posttrauma verfällt, weil er sie liest oder sie liest.
Was heißt, es gab eine Triggerwarnung? Ich meine, wer hat die dann wo, in welcher Form ausgesprochen?
Ein anderes Blog, das über eine Diskussion bei mir schrieb, schrieb dazu Triggerwarnung für die Kommentare. Also das war dann quasi so, naja, das hat eben eine Form angenommen. Ja, ja, auch Kinder sind triggernd und alles mögliche triggert ja heutzutage. Und das finde ich halt ein Problem. Also das ist was, wo ich denke, das dient dazu, sich einer inhaltlichen Auseinandersetzung ein Stück weit zu verschließen, die nicht mehr zu führen und es einfach schnell abzuwerten. Also etwas abzuwerten auf eine sehr einfache Art und Weise. Triggerwarnung. Na, damit habe ich gesagt, lest es, also man sollte das, eigentlich sollte man ja sagen, lest das bitte nicht, aber der Effekt ist ja fast schon, dass die Leute dann sagen, wieso was ist denn da Schlimmes und das dann erst recht lesen. Also es ist alles ein bisschen, es verschwimmen halt die Grenzen. Bei Triggerwarnung ist das so, dann bei Kackscheiße ist auch so ein Buzzword, wo ganz klar und deutlich mit nur einem Wort gesagt wird, das ist richtig schlimm und furchtbar. Und das geht gar nicht. Also das wird dann aber auch nicht weiter begründet. Und ein drittes Wort war noch, das habe ich jetzt natürlich wieder vergessen. Ist auch egal. Ja, vorhin hatte ich es noch auf der Zunge. Kommt wieder. Also es sind so ein paar diskreditierende Vokabeln, die innerhalb, man sagt sie und schon ist etwas oder jemand diskreditiert. Von Grund auf. Und da kommt in mir sehr häufig so ein Fail. Fail ist das dritte gewesen. Fail, am besten noch mit Hashtag. Also es ist ja sehr schnell gesagt. Und aber sehr häufig schwer begründet, finde ich. Und mit diesen drei Wörtern, um mich zu schmeißen, ist jetzt überhaupt nicht meins, weil ich das Gefühl habe, ich beschäme damit die Leute auf eine Art und Weise, wie es vielleicht nicht nötig ist, sie zu beschämen. Also das ist dieses Bildungsding. Es gibt in Finnland, in den Schulen, ist das Credo aller Lehrer, du sollst deine Schüler nicht beschämen. Und ich glaube halt, ich sollte als jemand, der in diesem Netz Sachen schreibt und die auf Twitter Sachen schreibt, ich will die Leute nicht beschämen. Ich will sie nicht beschämen.
Weil ich glaube, wenn ich sie beschäme, kann ich sie auch nicht mitnehmen. Dann werden sie, wie es bei uns in der Schule auch ist, also bei uns in den meisten Schulen gibt es ja nicht wenige Lehrer, die ihre Schüler beschämen, die sie vorführen. Also das ist ja so ein klassisches Verhalten. Du, komm mal vor, also man holt den Schüler vor, bei dem man eh weiß, der kann es nicht und lässt ihn dann noch vor allem an der Tafel die Fehler machen. Und das ist ja völliges Bloßstellen eigentlich. Ja, solche Sachen. Und diese Methoden. Ja, und ich habe gegen diese Methoden generell eine Allergie. Generell, also ich habe die gelernt in der Auseinandersetzung mit Bildung und mit Schule und mit wie denke ich, dass Bildung sein sollte. Wie sollte man mit Kindern, mit Schülern umgehen? Und ich glaube, das ist eine Frage, wie sollte man mit Menschen generell umgehen? Deswegen reagiere ich da halt auch im Internet allergisch, selbst wenn Verbündete von mir, also die sich eben auch für Feminismus engagieren, wo man eigentlich sagen müsste, oder wo von mir ja auch erwartet wird, Mensch, zieh doch mit denen an einem Strang und stell sie nicht ständig in Frage, wo ich halt, wo bei mir so Gerechtigkeitsalarmglocken anspringen und ich denke, nein, warum muss man die Leute dann so beschämen? Kann man es denn nicht auf eine andere Art und Weise vermitteln? Und das ist das, was ich halt versuche.
Und auf welche Art und Weise sollte man es vermitteln? Was wünscht du dir denn in dieser Diskussion, beziehungsweise was wünscht du dir denn für die nächsten Fortschritte des Feminismus? Wie kann denn insbesondere, aber nicht nur, auch das Netz, also die Gesellschaft als solche da jetzt Nutzen rausziehen?
Ich wünsche mir, dass wieder mehr hingeguckt wird, was man tun kann, also oder auch tun sollte. Also das ist viel mehr, nicht mehr so diese ganze, also Theorie ist wichtig, Theorie ist extrem wichtig. Ich werde ja auch nicht müde, ständig immer die Theorie zu versuchen, zu wiederholen und auch weiterzuführen und an die Leute zu bringen. Aber auch zu gucken, in welche Praxis muss das dann münden? Also bei mir ist es ja der Witz mit meiner Kolumne beim Freitag. Ich bin durch und durch ein politischer Mensch. Und ich habe mich, als ich 2009 die Kolumne angefangen habe und dann in den Alltag eingeordnet wurde mit meiner Kolumne, anfangs echt geärgert und habe gedacht, das kann nicht wahr sein. Warum bin ich jetzt im Alltag? Ich gehöre doch in die Politik. Und mittlerweile glaube ich, dass das ein Segen ist, weil ich meine politischen Themen dadurch gezwungen bin, immer auf den Alltag von Menschen und auf ihr Erleben, auf ihr tatsächliches Leben, ihre Erfahrungen, ihre Praxis zurückzubinden. Und das ist ein ganz großer Gewinn für mich mittlerweile. Also mittlerweile denke ich, das ist super. Das ist genau das, was ich eigentlich machen will. Das ist auch die Art und Weise, wie ich Feminismus denke. Es ist eine politische Agenda, wo ich auch versuche, so ein Agenda-Setting voranzutreiben, in dem ich eben auch gucke, welche Themen setze ich dann jetzt und was möchte ich gerne diskutieren. Aber immer rückgekoppelt an das, was tun wir? Was tun wir? Was können wir konkret tun, um die Situation noch zu ändern? Wo stehen die Menschen gerade? Welche Meinungen haben die meisten anderen Menschen eventuell? Wie haben sich diese Meinungen gebildet? Und wie kann ich sie abholen und versuchen, auch mitzunehmen ein Stück weit? Also ich nenne es so pragmatischen Feminismus, wo ich versuche und auch viele andere Feministinnen, so dieser The Guy's Guide of Feminism aus den USA, ist eigentlich genau das Gleiche zwischen der Vision, oder zwischen der Realität, die existiert, und der Vision, die ich habe, einen Weg zu bahnen. Und zwar aktiv einen Weg zu bahnen. Indem ich schon anders handle, indem ich anderen sage, warum macht ihr nicht mal so, oder was könnte man tun? So die Feature Red ist auch so ein pragmatischer Akt, dass man dann sagt, Frauen sind weniger sichtbar, dann versuchen wir sie jetzt mal sichtbar zu machen. Wie kann man das denn tun? Ja, da gibt es ja Mittel und Wege vielleicht und so weiter. Oder die Vernetzung ist auch ein sehr pragmatischer Weg, Leute zusammenzubringen. Und die wenigen, die es vielleicht gibt, mehr zu machen.
Okay, das verstehe ich aber jetzt mehr als so einen aktivistischen Aufruf. Was Feminismus betrifft, denke ich, gibt es einfach noch eine ganze Menge Wahrnehmungsprobleme. Dass einfach Dinge nicht gesehen werden, teilweise vielleicht auch bewusst ausgeblendet werden. Aber ich habe auch so den Eindruck, dass es sich manchmal auch wirklich nur um Fehler, Unachtsamkeiten handelt. Dass man einfach bestimmte Prozesse so gar nicht wahrnimmt. Dass einfach Dinge so überhaupt nicht so gesehen werden. Teilweise versteckt man das vielleicht hinter Meinungen, Erfahrungen etc. Manchmal ist es aber auch einfach nur so eine Betriebsblindheit, weil es halt normal ist.
Ja, ich...
Was sagt denn dieser Geist Guide to Feminism?
Ich glaube, ein zentraler Punkt ist dieser Listening-Teil, also Zuhören. Hört mal zu und hört nicht immer weg, wenn jemand was über Feminismus erzählt, sondern versucht mal, euch darauf einzulassen und lasst die Frauen mal reden. Oder die Männer, es gibt ja auch feministische Männer, die das Ganze vertreten. Die beiden zum Beispiel Autoren von dem Buch. Hört doch einfach mal zu. Und zwar respektvoll. Der rote Faden in dem Buch ist Respekt. Es ist eine Frage des Respekts, andere ernst zu nehmen. Und das ist auch eine gesellschaftliche Aufgabe, respektvoll, diejenigen auch ernst zu nehmen, die vielleicht an Punkten in der Gesellschaft Diagnosen stellen, die sagen, hier ist irgendwie noch was im Argen. Ja gut, dann nehmen wir das mal ernst und versuchen, das zu verändern. Ich glaube, das passiert schon auch, aber das ist immer ein sehr schleichender Prozess. Und das ist halt was, was nur wechselseitig funktioniert. Ich glaube, Respekt ist eine Zwei-Bahn-Straße. Ich werde nur Menschen respektieren, von denen ich erwarten kann, dass sie mich auch respektieren. Und da ist zum Beispiel ein ganz wichtiger Punkt zu vermitteln, sagt auch der Geist-Guide. Frauen respektieren Männer im Grunde sehr. Sie erwarten nicht nur von uns Männern, dass wir uns anständig benehmen, sondern sie haben den Glauben an uns, dass wir das auch tun können und dass wir das auch machen. Im Gegensatz zu Frauen, die nicht feministisch sind, die vielleicht denken, ja, Männer sind halt Männer und weil sie Männer sind, sind sie halt aggressiv. So zum Beispiel. Das ist etwas, woran Frauen nicht, woran Feministinnen nicht glauben. Und damit eröffnet sich natürlich eine Zukunftschancen für alle Möglichen. Und die muss man versuchen, in die Gesellschaft reinzutragen. Also das ist der gleiche Kampf wie immer. Man muss versuchen, Aufmerksamkeit dafür zu gewinnen.
Ich glaube, es existiert bei manchen so ein Feindbild, dass mit Feminismus eigentlich auch so eine Männerbefeindung einhergeht. Du sagst aber im Prinzip, es ist genau andersrum.
Das ist genau das Gegenteil. Ich hatte meine Kolumne über eine Studie aus den USA, wo es genau darum ging, dass es das Gegenteil ist. Also Feministinnen sind diejenigen, die Männer als vollwertige Menschen wahrnehmen. Also die ihnen nicht unterstellen, qua Geschlecht aggressiver zu sein, weniger fähig soziale Kompetenzen zu haben, weniger empathische Intelligenz und so weiter. Sondern Feministinnen glauben, dass Männer genauso toll sind wie Frauen. Und wenn man mal Eva Herrmann zum Beispiel liest, das Eva-Prinzip, ich habe das mal versucht zu lesen, ich habe da glaube ich zwei Kapitel oder so geschafft, dann wird man ganz schnell merken, dass sie permanent Männer abwertet. Und sie hat auch mal einen Text geschrieben, wo sie gesagt hat, wie Männer in Kitas, seid ihr denn irre, die sind doch alle potentiell pädophil. Das sind die Konservativen, das sind die, die entlang der Geschlechterrollen und Geschlechtergrenzen denken, die sehr negative Bilder von Männern entwerfen. Das sind nicht die Feministinnen. Und klar, das ist das Klischee, dass Feministen männerfeindlich sind, aber das ist wirklich nichts anderes als ein Klischee. Es ist mittlerweile in Studien auch nachgewiesen, dass Feministinnen ein viel besseres Bild, ein sehr positives Bild von Männern haben. Positiver als wenn man eben glaubt, Männer und Frauen sind von Natur aus anders. Männer sind von Mars und Frauen von der Venus. Also man muss ja nur mal solche Bücher lesen, um zu sehen, wie eindimensional und wie einfach gestrickt auch oft Männer dargestellt werden. Das ist oft die Kehrseite von Sexismus in Werbung, dass ich denke, was denken sich diese Marketing-Leute eigentlich? Glauben die, dass Männer so einfach gestrickt sind, dass sie jetzt dieses Girokonto nehmen werden, nur weil da Brüste dabei sind? Glauben die das? Also, was haben die für ein Bild von Männern? Ja, das ist ja auch sexistisch.
Ja, das ist teilweise auch schon beleidigend.
Ja, sehr, oder? Oder ich kenne auch ganz viele Männer, die sagen, ich finde im Internet keinen Porno, der mir gefällt, weil immer alles so gleich, dumpf und rein, raus ist und ich fühle mich dadurch als Mann irgendwie auch völlig entwertet. Also, das ist die Kehrseite. Und das ist ein Bild von Männern, was schon sehr häufig auch gezeichnet wird. Es gibt da Menschen, die haben mal gezählt, wie oft Männer in Filmen sterben. Sie sterben viel häufiger natürlich als Frauen, weil sie sind ja immer die Helden. Aber was sagt denn das über eine Gesellschaft aus? Oder über Menschen, die Filme machen, dass sie kein Problem damit haben, in ihren Filmen einfach mal die Männer sterben zu lassen, so reinenweise? Das passiert halt, oder?
Also, wenn ich sie richtig verstehe, ist zumindest diese dritte aktuelle, wie auch immer, neue Welle des Feminismus sehr viel mehr daraufhin ausgerichtet, eigentlich so das Kooperative zwischen den Geschlechtern zu betonen. War es am Anfang so ein intellektueller Aufbruch, dann so ein sexueller Befreiungsschlag, Widerstand wäre das falsche Wort gewesen, dass es jetzt eigentlich eher sich aufmacht, sozusagen so ein gesellschaftliches Kooperationsmodell zu entwerfen, an dem man sich beteiligen sollte, um einfach auch für beide Seiten die entsprechenden Vorteile loszulösen. Weil, was du vorhin gesagt hast, das kann ich auch aus eigener Erfahrung bestätigen, dass es natürlich auch so ist, dass man sich als Mann genauso in so einer Rollenkammer befindet, in so einem Rollengefängnis und an Erwartungshaltung zerbricht. Die man auch selber gar nicht bewusst hat, weil sie so eingebrannt sind, dass man sich gar nicht traut, sie auch nur infrage zu stellen. Oder wenn man sie irgendwie realisiert, glaubt man, man wäre der Einzige, der so darunter leiten würde. Also dieses Starksein, egal was dir Furchtbares geschieht, da emotional drüber stehen zu müssen. Gleichzeitig dann aber auch immer noch das Schwert in der Hand und den Schild irgendwie alle hinter dir verteidigen, bis in den Tod, den Heldentod leisten. Dann aber auch irgendwie tough und wettbewerbsfähig, dem Wettbewerb sozusagen prädestiniert für den Wettbewerb Leistungen erbringen zu müssen, sich Karrieren zu erarbeiten, sich tot zu arbeiten, was ja auch sehr verbreitet ist. Naja ebenso, nicht ohne Grund wahrscheinlich. Es ist sicherlich auch kein Biologismus an der Stelle, dass einmal der eigentlich Stärkere nicht länger durchhält. Das ist natürlich dann auch ein sich Verbrauchen und das sicherlich in physikalischer, wie auch in psychischer Hinsicht. Weil man einfach irgendwann durchgepfiffen ist und dem dann auch nicht mehr standhalten kann. Vor allem dann, wenn es dann eben so kritische Bereiche kommen, das hast du auch schon gesagt, kann ich nochmal betonen, dieses Arbeitslossein. Für die Frau ist dann so, naja, seid ja ja sowieso meistens so. Das ist ja normal, da leitet man nicht so drunter. Für den Mann ist das irgendwie so ein Default. Weil sich durch diese Arbeit auch eigentlich der Mann definiert. Weil man sich dadurch sozusagen seine Rolle auch bekommt und sagt so, ich bin, was ich mache. Und wenn ich nichts mache, dann bin ich nichts.
Genau. Ja, wir sind uns da einig. Es gibt halt sehr viel zu gewinnen für alle. Das ist, glaube ich, die Botschaft. Vor allem Freiheit. Es gibt sehr viel Freiheit noch zu gewinnen und sich zu erschaufeln. Weil es ist ja immer so, Freiheit ist ja eines der großen Paradigmen unserer Zeit. Das macht mich unfrei oder da bin ich zu eingeengt. Das möchte ich nicht, gerade auch in Beziehungen. Das wird schon immer wieder betont, wie wichtig Freiheit ist, ohne konsequent hinzuschauen, wo bin ich denn wirklich unfrei und inwieweit passe ich mich auch so weit an, dass ich mich selber schon wieder einschränke. Ich glaube, man kann ganz viele Menschen mit der Botschaft abholen, dass man sagt, du glaubst, du bist frei, aber guck doch nochmal genau hin. Ist es wirklich so? Und wenn nein, dann thematisier das mal bitte. Und sag vielleicht, ich bin Feminist, okay? Ja, da gab es in den USA meine Kampagne, I'm a feminist. Also, this is what a feminist looks like. Da gibt es auch ein YouTube-Video zu, wo dann einfach auch unterschiedlichste Menschen und auch ganz viele Männer sagen, this is what a feminist looks like, also sehen Feministen aus. Das kann jeder sein. Muss man keine Prüfung ablegen? Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Meinst du, es ist einfach nur eine Entscheidung, es sein zu wollen? Ja, ist es.
Bei mir war es so. Ich habe ganz lange auch gesagt, wie viele auf Feminismus und Ne, das ist nicht der Begriff, den ich nutze. Ich habe ganz lange Geschlechterdemokratie benutzt als Begriff, den ich dann für mich so benutzt habe. Und mit dem wir Eifermädchen, das war gerade mal 2008, also ich nenne mich jetzt gerade vier Jahre Feministin, vorher auch nicht, habe ich dann gemerkt, okay, warum mache ich denn das eigentlich? Es gibt eine ganz lange Geschichte dazu, also wir haben eine Tradition, die man damit anerkennt, die wichtig ist, wo man auch sagt, Gott sei Dank hatten wir diese Geschichte, Gott sei Dank hatten wir diese Bewegung der Frauen. Und es gibt einen Begriff, den man international kennt. Also wenn du in die USA gehst, oder wenn du nach Frankreich gehst, Feminisme, Feminism, die Menschen verstehen gleich. So tickst du, so denkst du, du hast diese Ideale, diese Grundwerte. Und ich glaube, wenn man so pragmatisch rangeht und diese Grundwerte dann auch entlang von Gerechtigkeit und von Respekt in alle Richtungen errichtet, dann hat man auch einen guten gemeinsamen Nenner, für den sich ganz, ganz viele Menschen anschließen können. Und das wäre eigentlich der Traum, dass das ein bisschen mehr transportiert werden könnte. Also Feminismus ist meistens nicht das, was ihr euch darunter vorstellt, Leute. Echt nicht. Ja, total. Was bringt es denn, wenn einzelne Leute vor sich hinrödeln und diskutieren und einen Text nach dem anderen produzieren und alles anprangern, wenn hinterher die Leute sich davon noch mehr abwenden? Oder wenn sie sagen, das betrifft mich alles gar nicht, fühle mich jetzt nicht angesprochen. Sondern man muss ja schon, wenn man pragmatisch ist und auch wirklich was ändern will und die Vision, die man hat, Realität werden lassen will. Dann muss man ja mit den Menschen, wie sie nun mal leider sind, irgendwie auch versuchen zu arbeiten und da ein Angebot machen. In einer ökonomisch kapitalistischen Gesellschaft muss man ja immer Angebote machen und eine Nachfrage generieren. Und diese Nachfrage kann man vielleicht mit neuen Basiswirts generieren. Dann sagt man, es geht um Freiheit. Es geht um Freiheit, es geht um Gerechtigkeit. Wollt ihr keine Gerechtigkeit?
Letztlich geht es auch um gesellschaftlichen Fortschritt, weil es immer gezeigt hat, da wo sich soziologisch Dinge weiterentwickeln, dann eben einfach wieder Raum frei wird für neue Entwicklungen.
Kreativität, das eingeschränkt durch Geschlechterrollen. Sehr stark, sehr, sehr stark.
Zammersauer, oder? Ich denke, wir haben es. Machen wir mal einen Deckel drauf. Ich bedanke mich.
Ja, ich bedanke mich für die Einladung.
Vielleicht noch nicht lang genug, aber den Rest, den müsst ihr euch jetzt sozusagen selber herleiten. Wir machen jetzt hier mal den Topf zu. Und ich sage danke fürs Zuhören und fürs Mitdenken und vielleicht auch fürs Weiterdenken.